now to a senate hearing on offshore tax
havens and ponzi schemes
one of the witnesses is irs commissioner
douglas shulman
senate finance committee chairman max
baucus has introduced legislation to
crack down on american investors who
incorporate offshore to avoid u.s taxes
this is two hours in 10 minutes
wrote
things gained through unjust fraud are
never secure
today we consider two kinds of unjust
fraud
today we look for ways
to help honest taxpayers become just a
little more secure
today we examined the tax consequences
of bernard el madoff scheme to defraud
investors
and we consider ways to crack down on
the efforts of offshore tax entities to
defraud the us government of the taxes
that they owe
last december during one of our nation's
most severe financial crisis
authorities uncovered perhaps the
nation's largest case financial fraud
on december 11
bernard l madoff was arrested after
revealing that for two decades
he had been running a ponzi scheme that
involved more than 600 billion dollars
a court-appointed trustee found that
incredibly madoff's firm had conducted
absolutely no trading for at least 13
years
13 years of false earnings reportings
and 13 years of no trades
last week madoff pleaded guilty to 11
counts of fraud money laundering perjury
and theft those charges carry with them
maximum sentences that add up to 150
years
senators schumer cantwell and menendez
requested that we hold hearing on the
tax consequences for these victims and
today irs commissioner doug shulman will
explain how these victims can process
their losses on their tax returns
we expect the commissioner to discuss
issues like theft loss phantom income
and fraudulent conveyance
today we'll also discuss an effort to
combat another type of fraud
we will discuss outlines of potential
legislation
designed to stem overseas tax evasion
in the last congress the finance
committee held two hearings on overseas
tax evasion
in a may 2007 finance committee hearing
gao testified about the qualified
intermediary program
and offshore tax evasion
qualified intermediaries are a key
element of the government's overseas tax
enforcement system
qualified intermediaries are financial
institutions that serve as our nation's
eyes and ears on the movement of u.s
funds overseas
but they don't work very well
the go determined that foreign
corporations set up by an american
individual perhaps in the cayman islands
may enable that individual
to hide income tax behind the corporate
bail
and
in july two eight thousand eight finance
committee hearing focused on the cayman
islands by the way as an offshore tax
evasion
i asked the gao to travel to the caymans
and look at the ugland house that's the
five that famous five-story building
that the geo testified has eighteen
thousand five hundred eighty seven
tenants
half of those tenants about nine
thousand of them are reportedly
americans
the geo reported
the following findings related to the
cayman islands just the caymans
u.s taxpayers have reported 1400
controlled foreign corporations in the
cayman islands
two trillion dollars of bank assets are
based there
nine thousand mutual funds
including hedge funds
and a fed hedge fund for every seven
people on the island
after the second hearing i decided it
was time to do something about this
do we could to close that overseas tax
cap some have estimated the overseas tax
cap to total 50 to 70 billion dollars a
year
reminding all of us the tax cap really
those again
taxes legally owed but not timely paid
today we'll discuss legislative
proposals intended to enhance the
transparency of offshore activity we'll
consider how we can give the irs better
tools to deter detect and stop offshore
non-compliance
among other proposals
here are three
the first would require entities
transferring funds offshore other than
on behalf of publicly traded companies
to report the irs the amount and
destination or account information of
the funds transferred
this will give the irs a trail of funds
going offshore
and it will help the irs to deter and
detect offshore non-compliance
the second proposal would extend the
statute of limitations on for tax
returns with certain international
transactions from three years to six
years
this change would give the irs more time
to detect and examine
often complicated offshore
activity
and the third proposal would facilitate
the irs's ability to enforce compliance
with the law's requirement for reports
of foreign bank and financial accounts
proposals require entities to file these
reports along with their tax returns
as we look out at the deficits that we
will be facing over the next few years
the importance of moving forward on the
offshore tax evasion problem becomes all
the more clear
we need to reclaim every dollar of tax
revenue that we can from these offshore
tax evaders
president obama's fiscal year 2010
budget proposes a robust effort aimed at
cripping offshore tax evasion we wait
for the details of his plan it makes
sense for us to move forward
nevertheless our proposals that we think
could do the job
while we're on the topic of scams
i'm looking very closely at tax options
that will reclaim
the outrageous bonuses paid by aig
the country is angry
individual americans are angry
i am angry four and a half million
americans have lost their jobs
at least four and a half american
million americans in this recession have
lost their jobs
and these people who are getting bonuses
are getting multi-million dollar bonuses
while these others are losing their jobs
it is just totally unfair
so we're looking at various ideas and
i'll discuss them with committee members
shortly
and so let's look for ways to address
unjust fraud
as do we can to help fraud's victims
let us try to help honest taxpayers
become just a little more insecure
say grassley
mr chairman
i'm going to just refer to one paragraph
of my opening statement put the rest on
the record
some of the charities that invested in
bernie madoff including universities and
those funded by
hollywood would presumably have
sophisticated advisors the this raises
questions for me about whether the board
members of these organizations were more
interested in helping their friend than
furthering charitable work mr joseph
who's here to testify
will probably
appreciate
that as well
his willingness to be here again today
he's been before this committee before
uh to discuss due diligence requirements
for charities trustees and boards of
directors as well as
other tax implications for board
misconduct under internal revenue
service and then i would spend just a
little bit of time thanking you for
bringing up the aig issue we're here to
talk about ponzi schemes and
and
i suppose every ponzi scheme is
different and aig may not fall into that
category but it surely brings into
question a lot of tax issues that we
have
in tarp and the fact that in some cases
uh income limitations apply and in some
cases they don't
and the extent to which bonuses are
affected or not affected
so i want to back you up on looking into
that and doing what we can to make sure
that these things don't happen in the
future because from the standpoint of
not understanding ponzi schemes after
about seven or eight months of
reading about aig and trying to
determine what happens i'm not even sure
we have a handle on exactly what
happened and in this in this case of
this economic recession uh caused by a
lot of people
taking chances and doing things that
weren't very transparent we've got to
bring some transparency to this so i
appreciate that very much thank you
senator very very much
now i welcome our witnesses our first is
irs commissioner doug shulman thank you
commissioner for being here next we have
the director of tax issues with gao
michael rostec
and finally we have the former assistant
attorney general for the new york state
law department's charities bureau
william josephson
are no more practice so
all your statements have been included
in the record to ask you to speak um
for about five minutes and we'll start
with you um
thank you mr chairman uh ranking member
grassley members of the committee
i appreciate the opportunity to testify
today
about ponzi schemes in general which
also will provide some guidance around
the madoff situation as well as talking
to you about irs's
efforts to detect and stop unlawful
offshore tax avoidance
beyond the toll of human suffering the
madoff case raises numerous issues for
the victims of losses from ponzi type
investment schemes
to help provide clarity in this very
compliment complicated matter today the
irs is issuing two guidance items that
will assist vic's victims of all ponzi
schemes
let me refer you to my written testimony
which has more details and i'll make a
few points about the guidance
the first is a revenue ruling which is
the treasury department and the irs's
best legal interpretation regarding the
tax treatments of losses in ponzi
schemes
determining the amount and timing of tax
deductions arising from ponzi type
investment schemes is factually very
difficult and depends on the taxpayers
prospect for recovering
the lost money and sometimes that can
take years to determine
the guidance we are issuing today
clarifies that ponzi losses are
investment theft losses under the code
and that the taxpayer may deduct
all of the purported earnings on which
the investor paid taxes as well as the
cash invested in the ponzi scheme
it also clarifies that the investment
theft loss is not a normal casualty loss
and therefore is not subject to
limitations that apply to non-investment
type losses
this ruling should provide clarity and
straightforward guidance to taxpayers
in addition we've issued a revenue
procedure with the goal of making it as
easy as possible for taxpayers affected
by these schemes to avail themselves of
the proper tax deductions
key to the revenue procedure is
providing a safe harbor method of
computing and reporting losses the
procedure's goal again is to be helpful
to taxpayers who are confronted
with a very complex area of the law and
difficult facts
mr chairman i'm also pleased to briefly
describe the unprecedented focus that
the irs
has brought to detecting and bringing to
justice those who unlawfully hide assets
overseas to avoid paying tax
in today's economic environment where
the federal government is necessarily
running large deficits to restore
economic growth it's more important than
ever that american citizens feel
confident that individuals and
corporations are playing by the rules
and paying the taxes that they owe
when the american public is confronted
with stories of financial institutions
helping u.s citizens to maintain secret
overseas accounts involving sham trusts
to improperly
avoid u.s tax
they should be outraged as am i and as i
know you are but they should also know
that the u.s government is taking
unprecedented measures and there's much
more to come i can assure you that the
president and the treasury secretary are
committed to taking aggressive action on
offshore tax abuse
over the next several months the
administration intends to propose a
series of legislative and enforcement
measures to reduce u.s tax evasion and
avoidance while i'm proud of the
progress we have made since i became
commissioner we are only at the
beginning you should expect to see a
multi-year effort
of beefing up our resources
and tools needed to address
international tax abuse
since becoming commissioner i've made
international issues a top priority we
actually discussed it at my confirmation
hearing here a year ago the senate
finance committee
i've increased the number of audits in
this area and stepped up hiring of
international investigators and experts
we have been steadily increasing
pressure on offshore financial
institutions that facilitate concealment
of taxable income by u.s citizens and
that pressure i can assure you will only
increase
the irs investigations are getting
results
the justice department recently signed a
deferred prosecution agreement with a
major swiss bank which involved a
payment of 780 million dollars
they're also continuing to pursue a
lawsuit for civil summons to get more
bank accounts from that institution
several so-called tax haven countries
have pledged to reform bank secrecy laws
and just last week have agreed to comply
with international standards for tax and
data sharing
the irs is also looking to improve
information reporting and sharing mr
chairman you referred to the qualified
intermediary program which gives us a
line of sight to foreign financial
institutions we're looking to improve
that program by increasing the type of
information
that those institutions must report
about u.s citizens and also creating
rules that insist better due diligence
on accounts opened or maintained by
qualified intermediaries
we're also exploring the increased use
of and potentially more information
reporting requirements around money
being transferred in and out of the
united states
mr chairman i know that you're
considering legislation designed to
improve tax compliance with respect to
offshore transactions
i appreciate all the support you've
given to the irs i believe that the
general direction of your legislation
will help us combat offshore tax abuse
my staff and i are looking forward to
working with you and other members of
this committee on that legislation i
want to thank you for the opportunity to
testify and i'll look forward to
answering your questions
sorry my microphone wasn't on thank you
commissioner mr bosnick connect
mr chairman senator grassley and members
of the committee thank you for inviting
me to discuss our work related to
individuals use of offshore locations to
evade taxes
my statement describes the
characteristics of individuals found to
have evaded tax and how they did so
describes factors that enable offshore
non-compliance and discusses challenges
that offshore financial activities pose
for irs
taxpayers whose non-compliance involved
offshore locations are a diverse group
some have owed
very relatively small amounts of taxes
interest and penalties but some have
evaded millions
in taxes on hundreds of millions of
dollars in assets
some taxpayers appear to have been
inadvertently failing to pay their taxes
such as when they inherited
money overseas but failed to report
income earned on that money
others have used very elaborate
structures that served to hide their
activities and thus appear to have been
quite deliberate in their evasions
regardless taxpayers offshore
non-compliance can be enabled by the
limited transparency that is a hallmark
of many offshore jurisdictions
some offshore jurisdictions share very
limited information about u.s taxpayers
with irs
and those wishing to evade taxes can
devise elaborate sometimes multinational
schemes to hide their activity
due to the limited transparency of
offshore investments and transactions
compliance for those with offshore
activity relies on self-reporting
years of irs research have shown that
when compliance is so heavily voluntary
taxpayers tend to be non-compliant
financial advisors may also facilitate
many offshore schemes
advisors may cater to a retail market
through confidence conferences open to a
very wide variety of individuals
alternatively advisors may target just
those with very substantial income or
assets
either way advisors can use the relative
ease and low cost of creating offshore
accounts companies trusts etc to help
taxpayers hide their income
these characteristics of offshore
locations and activity make enforcement
challenging
the complexity of offshore cases results
in examinations
with an offshore component taking much
longer than normal examinations that is
audits
for the period we studied the median
time between a return being filed and
the completion of an offshore
examination was almost 500 days longer
than for all other examinations
due to the three-year civil statute of
limitations irs sometimes prematurely
ends offshore examinations
even though declined cases may have more
assessment potential than cases that are
not near the statutory deadline
congress has granted exceptions to the
three-year statute in some situations
for instance when a taxpayer fails to
report listed transactions
jao suggests that congress consider a
statute extension for cases that do
involve offshore activity
to promote offshore compliance irs has
established the qualified intermediary
program qi program in the year 2000
the program does help ensure that u.s
source income paid to foreign persons is
properly taxed
u.s source income includes for example
interest on u.s and corporate bonds
stock dividends and rents
qis are foreign financial institutions
that contract with irs to withhold u.s
source income
that they pay to their customers and to
report certain information to irs
these qi program features should result
in qis being
a better source of withholding decisions
than u.s withholding agents
that is because qis are overseas
they are more likely to have direct
contact with the foreign customers than
u.s withholding agents would and should
be better able to judge whether
customers are qualified for lower tax
rates such as under our treaties
second qis accept enhanced
responsibilities for ensuring customers
qualify for lower taxes such as using
irs approved documents to identify their
customers
finally and importantly qis agree to
have external parties review their
accounts and procedures and result and
report those results to irs
however the recent deferred prosecution
agreement for ubs ag starkly shows that
the program is an imperfect tool to
thwart offshore compliance problems
earlier we made several recommendations
to improve the qi program
perhaps most pertinent to today's
hearing is our recommendation that irs
require qi's external auditors to report
any indications of fraud or illegal acts
that could significantly affect the
results of their reviews of qi
compliance
we cannot say that having this reporting
requirement in place would have
forestalled ubs's efforts to defraud the
u.s or led to earlier detection
however the type of fraudulent activity
engaged in by ubs is what our
recommendation would cover
that concludes my statement i'd be happy
to answer questions thank you very much
mr prostate mr josephson
thank you chairman baucus
senator grassley other senators
i'm very happy and honored to be able to
appear before the committee again
as the committee knows i've prepared a
very detailed statement
that actually harks back to the
committee's staff recommendations in
june of 2004
for charity reform many of those
recommendations have been enacted
too many have not
i'd like to submit my statement for the
record it contains a detailed list of
proposed changes in the code affecting
both publicly supported charities and
private foundations that i hope the
committee will seriously consider a lot
of objections
thank you
i'd like to make a few general remarks
about what i think
the implications for charity the madoff
madoff scandal has
and what i think the committee and the
congress needs to do
to try to ensure
that charities do not get so involved
again
the madoff scandal dramatizes the need
for congress
to make a public policy decision
that has needed to be made for a long
time but which it has deserved deferred
we can go on as we have been
paying lip service
to the federal and state laws that
affect fiduciary investment
responsibilities
in fact
the state laws are extremely difficult
to enforce
and have very little teeth
and the jeopardy investment rules which
are most pertinent to the madoff scandal
have also very little teeth and
the enforcement resources available to
the irs to do something about them
are meager and inadequate to the task
these facts send to charitable
fiduciaries the wrong
but unmistakable message
that their fiduciary responsibilities
somehow
are less onerous and less important than
those that they owe for example
to trust some of them may have for their
children
alternatively
congress can and should
rewrite
not just
the
private foundation jeopardy investment
rules though they certainly need to be
rewritten
and apply it not just to private
foundations but to all exempt
organizations including public charities
but
treasury also
can rewrite the jeopardy investment
regulations
to make them as detailed and
comprehensive
as
the excess compensation and benefit
regulations are with respect to public
charities that pay too much
to their managers
and while congress is doing this
hopefully
it can clean up various anomalies in the
code
between the treatment of public
charities and private foundations and
the treatment within those categories
that i discuss in detail in my statement
and most important
congress can at last give the internal
revenue service
the resources that it should have had
since 1969
to do the necessary
public charity and private foundation
enforcement that 40 of the 50 states do
not do it all
and the other 10 do
inadequately
otherwise
the parade of charity scandals will
continue endlessly
of course
the charities trade associations will
object
they will argue that we will not be able
to get people to serve as directors or
trustees
but i know of no
systematic empirical evidence that that
is true
from my own experience i know that if
one truly cares about doing good one
serves one takes one service seriously
and one accepts those responsibilities
and those liabilities
the charities arguments in this area
remind me of those that were made
when i was the head of the charities
bureau and attorney general eliot
spitzer
reversed the long-standing precedent of
his predecessors to give donors standing
to enforce their restricted gifts
the charities argued that there will be
a plethora of lawsuits that charities
will have to spend charity money
defending
well
unfortunately perhaps that has not
happened because
unlike for what one example the
robertson family in the princeton case
where i was an expert witness
too few donors have the motivation
the resources and what marilyn guardia
used to call the intestinal fortitude
to enforce their restricted gifts
the committee staff recommended in june
of 2004
that the size of charity boards should
be limited most of them are far too big
as compared for example to the
for-profit boards of public companies
this is bad
because responsibility
of those fiduciaries is diffused and
deluded and those fiduciaries do not
feel and cannot be held accountable for
what they do
thank you mr chairman be glad to answer
any questions thank you very much mr
joseph that was
very persuasive
um i start with you a commissioner
let's just take say
uh just do the math
uh say an investor who lost
five hundred thousand dollars
with the pretty madoff
under these new guidelines
maybe not so new what
would the tax treatment be what could
the investor recoup
well a couple things um one uh
any investment made with and these i
want to clarify the the ruling and
procedure we put out uh today is trying
to be applicable to all ponzi schemes
right not just the madoff situation but
i'll use the example under madoff um
it's an investment theft loss
um if the 500 000 uh it can include both
money put in
as well as earnings over time that were
left in their account with madoff right
um and this is assuming they they paid
taxes on those earnings right um
it'll be deductible in the year
discovered and we give some guidance in
in the revenue procedure about how to uh
how to determine what the year is that
it's discovered the full 500 excuse me
and then and then uh i'm sorry i was
deducted
what amount
an amount and and then we have a
procedure a safe harbor that says you
can deduct up to 95 percent
uh without us you know looking further i
mean we'll obviously make sure the
documentation is correct but there's a
safe harbor of 95 immediately
subtract from the 95 percent private
insurance including cipic that you might
get back
and you can deduct that 95 percent
immediately and then the remaining five
percent if you recover more uh in later
years it's taxable if it's over if
you've already taken a deduction and if
you don't just recover the five percent
uh you can then take that deduction
later so there's basically a safe harbor
for 95 percent so about 95 percent
is deductible then
basically more or less or less okay
and um
these regulations when are they in
effect when can taxpayers expect to be
able to utilize them um they can utilize
them immediately we uh are planning to
put them out on our website later today
okay
respect to um offshore problems um
mr boss
mr brostek um last week fence committee
released a
bipartisan limited draft of
legislation intended to give irs more
tools about eight proposals
one
is the information reporting to the
service when funds are transferred to
offshore accounts and
another requiring the federal banking
account
report fbar to be attached to tax return
just give me a sense of um
of how effectively will this help us
begin to solve this problem
of
of
well as i noted in my statement hello
i've abated
taxes
as i noted in my statement when
compliance is really dependent on the
self-reporting of individuals data
indicates that uh taxpayers tend to take
advantage of that right lack of
transparency right in general the
provisions in the bill appear to be
trying to get more transparency over the
transactions of individuals right and
therefore
they ought to have something of a
deterrent effect on the non-compliant
behavior reduce it just because the
reporting is there
and the provision should also give irs
some additional information to use in
making more efficient use of its own
resources to identify who is likely
being non-compliant and when they're
doing audits to be more efficient about
conducting those audits and determining
how much non-compliance there is
but how effective you think
it'll be is this enough we need to do
more what's your sense
if we want to close this down this
overseas tax evasion this tax gap what
do we have to do
well um i i hate to be pessimistic but i
don't think that we're ever going to
watch it be realistic
but
but you're a good public servant
to be realistic i don't think we are
ever going to completely shut down tax
evasion
those who would like to evade tax are
very inventive
they have
people who are very inventive for them
particularly those who have a lot of
resources can hire very good talent
so i can't say how much precisely your
proposed legislation would reduce the
gap i do think it would be helpful i do
think it would reduce the amount of
non-compliance so what more could we do
i don't have a set of proposals for you
today just some thoughts some ideas okay
well
as i noted in the statement i do think
that one of the things you have in your
legislation is to expand the period of
time that irs has to conduct audits
to extend the statute of limitations we
do that three to six yes and i think
that's desirable for a number of reasons
but in part because irs agents are very
careful not to extend over the statute
of limitations when we did our review of
of this situation we found a number of
individuals i believe was about 35
agents who have been disciplined for
taking more than the statutory allowed
time
in a two-year period so extending the
statute will make the irs agents more
able and willing to investigate complex
cases that run beyond a three-year
period
okay
um
before i do that i've um
[Music]
just
you know americans are quite angry about
these ambassadors your commissioner
stolen quite angry about these eig
bonuses paid and other bonuses paid
um
and so the my basic question to you
um it really outrages me um as it does i
think most most americans
we want to do we can't stop this
nonsense
and
president obama has made lots of
statements about he's trying to stop it
um i think to some at one point the
treasury was in a position to stop the
bonuses but for some reason did not
um i think in part because uh
listen the argument we need those folks
they're experts and all that if we don't
get they don't get their bonuses and
they might leave they don't know how to
unwind all this stuff and i don't think
i i that that has no effect on me there
are enough bright people in this country
who i think would go to work to try to
unwind this
um if people there don't have to receive
bonuses to stay and as i'm told they're
really retention bonuses retention
bonuses
designed to encourage the folks in this
product section to
to stay um
but i don't think those bonuses should
be paid
um
and i don't think to question we can go
back and
get them
um don't know
but another option is to tax them so the
basic question is what's the highest
tax that we could impose on those
bonuses that is sustainable in court
let me let me say a couple things uh mr
chairman as a as a citizen i share your
outrage um i can't add a lot to what uh
the president said yesterday that he was
outraged by these uh bonuses um i think
you know we obviously operate within the
the contours of the tax law and i
haven't looked and don't know the
specifics of this situation um but i
will tell you what you know i heard you
say earlier that this committee is going
to look at this and we stand ready to as
we explore these issues for the irs to
do what it can to assist in that
exploration with both the committee and
obviously with the department of
treasury
all right but i can't answer that right
where you're at i'd like you to work
with us and we'll work with others too
but we got to finance that question
what's the highest excise tax we can
impose that sustainable in court
sarah nelson you're next perhaps 90
percent mr chairman
let's find out what it is
i want to congratulate the irs and the
justice department
when you expose the massive fraud on the
swiss bank ubs
do you have any
reason to believe that ubs
is a one-time aberration or are there
other banks out there engaging
in this fraudulent activity
um yeah thank you for your uh
your uh commendation we
we've been trying to be very aggressive
uh around tax off offshore tax evasion
um i guess i can't speak to uh other
financial institutions i think as mr
brostik said um you know this is an
issue that uh you know people will push
the envelope on what i will tell you is
we have a robust voluntary compliance
initiative we have a whistleblower
program um we know that taxpayers who
were hiding assets overseas
we have their attention and are very
nervous because the irs is applying more
pressure and committees like this are
talking about
legislation i also tell you that
financial intermediaries that are
facilitating this through a lot of
formal and informal conversations have
paid attention and are making sure
they've got their ducks in a row and are
abiding by the qualified intermediary
program we're going to intensify and add
to the tools in the qualified
intermediary program and then hopefully
work through some legislation and so
can't talk to you about numbers uh and
can't talk about specific investigations
but i can tell you that um we are uh
heartened by the successes we've seen in
this in this case we plan to continue
pursuing our summons around this case
and we're going to pursue anyone we find
is facilitating offshore tax evasion
okay so the answer is you don't know of
any others
i think the answer is we got a whole
bunch of things we're looking at we have
taxpayers coming in under the
whistleblower program i i'm not in a
position to speak publicly and
authoritatively uh about others but i
can tell you this is an area we're
looking at very closely all right well
thanks to the chairman uh we're gonna
get into some legislation on this and uh
the chairman's file one version i filed
another version with senator levin
there's a unique little wrinkle here
that
an american citizen
uh
can go to a very exclusive tax shelter
the virgin islands economic development
program
how many taxpayers participate in this
virgin islands tax shelter and what kind
of oversight is the irs exercising on
them
um
the first question i don't have the
number
as you know the law allows the u.s
virgin islands to set up its own
economic development zone and have
special tax rates
anytime we see special significantly
lower tax rates it's obviously potential
opportunities for people to play games
we have some public lawsuits going on
around this
we have
a number of open cases where we're
pursuing
these issues the real issue hinges on
the residency is someone really resident
of the u.s virgin islands and what's
their source of income is it u.s virgin
island source or u.s source very fact
intensive um and we've got a
number of open cases some are which are
docketed and you can see in the courts
but we're um we're pretty focused on
this just like we're focused on you know
a lot of places that have much lower tax
rates where people are taking advantage
of the system will you share with the
committee how many taxpayers participate
in this virgin island shelter yeah i
don't know i will share with you what we
have i'm not sure we have a clear
definition of the virgin islands
shelters but i'll get you as much
information as we can okay thanks to the
good work of the gao
uh you found out
that a number of financial
institutions that have been receiving
considerable federal assistance from the
tarp program
uh have utilized these subsidiaries and
countries or territories
as tax havens for example
aig has five subsidiaries in bermuda
citigroup has 90
subsidiaries in the caymans
uh bank of america has 59 subsidiaries
in the caymans
and even others in the bahamas bermuda
and the virgin islands
now
part of this outrage that the chairman
has talked about
uh is that
the the taxpayers want to know why
if they're receiving all of these bail
outs are they also getting the shelter
in these tax havens
is it valid
a valid business reason that they are
creating these entities
so do you believe that
tax avoidance underlies the decision or
is it a legitimate uh decision by banks
to create
these subsidiaries in low or
no tax jurisdictions
question
i think it's a mixture sir
the work that we did for the chairman
and ranking member on the cayman islands
suggested that there are subsidiaries
created in some of these low-tax
jurisdictions for what i think we would
all agree are fairly legitimate business
purposes
for instance we saw that the sale of u.s
manufactured aircraft
was facilitated through
the
oversized overseas private investment
corporation
a u.s government-affiliated entity that
had
worked with boeing other manufacturers
to sell airplanes through the cayman
islands
but i also think that a number of these
facilities are set up for legal tax
avoidance trying to minimize the tax
that the corporate structure pays as a
whole
and there are undoubtedly some
situations where
these are used to step over the line and
illegally evade
tax mr chairman we've got to put a stop
to this nonsense we do it's an outrage
is it absolutely outrageous it's it's
part of the way that we can solve the
budgetary deficit problem get the tax
that's owed instead of allowing all of
this tax avoidance and that's true i
mean as senator as mr prostate said i
don't think we'll we have first of all
distinguish between individual attacks
invasion then and corporate with respect
to tax havens there's a difference um
but nevertheless um the tax gap
in each case is is very very large and
it's it's about time you know this
country has given lip service to that
for a while we've made several attempts
at it we've never really done enough
significantly about it and now is the
time to do it
uh center inc you're next
thank you mr chairman i appreciate you
holding this hearing today
it's already been educational i
appreciate commissioner shulman's
explanation of and clarity
of the announcement on the tax treatment
notice you're listening very intently as
a government accountant i'll
commissioner shulman was saying
and i'll submit a few questions that are
probably more technical than anybody
around here be interested in but i i
would have an interest in a little more
clarity on that but
it it is clear that there was massive
undersight of this fraud by both the
securities and exchange commission
charged with investor protection and the
financial industry regulatory authority
charged with the oversight of the
broker-dealer members
can you give me a little idea of your
authority as irs commissioner and
investigating false income statements in
this regard so can you give us
suggestions for ways the irs can keep
this from happening
well i'm you know at the end of the day
most of our enforcement resources are
focused on making sure we collect the
proper amount of tax um and that's what
what we've been focused on uh it's you
know what it's it's not our primary
responsibility to oversee investment uh
schemes with that said um we've got for
instance in our criminal investigation
division some of the best forensic
accountants who can follow the trail of
money in criminal cases
we make those people
available to the fbi to other agencies
who are investigating fraud and will
continue to do so
i believe that information sharing
amongst federal government agencies so
we all view ourselves as the u.s
government trying to do right by the
american citizens
is is the way we should approach things
so to the extent we can either
synthesize information or we can compare
information on tax returns albeit within
the uh responsible uh not sharing of
taxpayer data um and and not breaking
that trust is important things to do and
so we actually have had conversations
with a variety of our agencies about
what of our resources we can offer to
help them as they try to go after a
whole number of frauds that have come to
light around this current financial
crisis that we're in
uh it's estimated that we stand lose
about 17 billion on this tax scam and
taxes that we won't be able to collect
on i'm sorry on the madoff scheme
um hadn't seen that estimate i'm sorry
okay
um i would be interested in an in an
estimate of what was probably lost by
the time we do the tax uh adjustments
that'll be coming up
um chairman baucus's proposal for
treatment of offshore funds
transfers requires financial
institutions to report to the irs any
amount of funds transferred out of the
country
based on my reading of the text this
includes transfers such as remittances
to families living abroad and u.s
citizens making purchases overseas
could you comment on that that
interpretation
um i i can't comment on the
interpretation because i think the you
know the the legislation will still be
hashed out i'd refer to committee staff
um what i would say is i've had a lot of
conversations uh with this committee
with the chairman um one of the keys to
really getting after the tax gap if not
the key
is information reporting and so as a
general concept i'm a big fan of
information reporting this specific
proposal we're going to look forward to
working with the committee on any time
we get information reporting
there's responsibility for us
to take that information
and make sure we sort through it and
pursue people who are uh involved in
abusive uh transactions and not pursue
innocent people who are just in the
business of doing financial transactions
and so if if that is in there i think
the onus will be on us to make sure
we're not uh you know pursuing somebody
who's wiring money to their daughter
who's happens to be studying abroad but
that we're
actually following a money trail to
people uh who are hiding assets overseas
and trying to avoid paying taxes and
what particular groups would those be
excuse me what particular groups would
those those be that this would now
target that we're not already
requiring
reports for income transfers under the
current law well as i understand it
the proposal is actually putting
responsibility on the financial
institution to send information to the
irs
right now every citizen has to
voluntarily report
what what's happening overseas uh with
their account the taxes that they are
due and the you know the problem of that
system is uh honest taxpayers are
reporting and paying taxes dishonest
ones we don't often have a line of sight
to and so i think all these legislative
proposals are trying to get us a line of
sight so that honest taxpayers cannot be
footing the bill for the dishonest
taxpayers
thank you and my times expired and i
look forward to working with the
chairman on that proposal
thank you senator might say that um
clearly
work this out so that you know
some of the concerns you you're implying
or are addressed
and i think the main point being this is
third-party reporting third-party
information reporting it kind of gets at
the point that mr prostek was making
that sometimes people don't voluntarily
report everything
um average american taxpayer i think
does
but i think to large we're not talking
about average american taxpayers we need
third party information reporting thanks
schumer
thank you mr chairman and i want to
thank you for holding this hearing at
the
in part at least at the request of
senator campbell
i have a brief opening statement to make
and then i'll ask some questions of the
commissioner
uh the perfidy of bernie madoff is now
well known
his ponzi scheme victimized not only
well-known names such as steven
spielberg and fred wilpon the owner of
the mets
but hardworking middle class people who
thought they were making prudent
investments for their retirement
madoff's fraud has jeopardized dozens of
union pension funds in upstate new york
as well as a hundred fifty thousand
philanthropical
foundations
the fraud affected hard-working middle
class individuals who thought they were
investing wisely and safely for their
retirement years and just like that
they're wiped out
i'd like to ask the committee's
permission to enter into the record
personal stories of three made off
victims
ronnie sue ambrosino richard friedman
adrian biondo
the pain this man inflicted is as
widespread as it is piercing
two weeks ago today i wrote you along
with senators menendez and cantwell
asking for the finance committee to hold
a hearing on the various tax issues
related to the madoff fraud
i asked for the hearing
because i was worried that not only had
people lost their life savings but they
also would have paid taxes on money they
never received
and they should be able to get that
money back
i want to thank you mr chairman for
agreeing to the request and scheduling
the hearing so quickly
after madoff's arrest several questions
arose about provisions of the tax code
related to the theft loss deduction
and when taxes paid in past years on
phantom income might be eligible for a
refund among other issues
people were confused about what to do on
their 2008 tax returns and needed
guidance from the irs
i am very pleased
that the irs has decided that in each
area in which there was a major dispute
that the irs sided with the victim
the irs ruling says that people can take
a theft loss deduction in 2008 for any
money directly invested with madoff
including any reinvested gains
and that such losses can be carried back
for five years and forward for twenty
years
by treating the theft losses this way
victims will not have to worry about
filing amended returns for prior years
this means that victims will not owe
taxes on income they never received
victims will receive the most lenient
tax treatment in a simple
and straightforward way
the guidance the irs is issuing today is
clear
it's comprehensive and it comes at a
crucial time and i want to thank the
commissioner and your entire team for
their good work with my office and those
of others
there are some issues left unresolved
and i'll explore those in questions but
for the most part
i believe the prominent issues have been
addressed and we are hearing from
victims and their lawyers that they are
very pleased with what the irs has done
so i want to thank you mr chairman and
uh now i'd like to just with my
remaining time
ask a question or two
first
to the commissioner
and again thank you commissioner you did
a very good job here
your testimony states that the safe
harbor procedure outlined by the irs
says the taxpayers should deduct from
their losses their expected sipc
recovery of 500 000 per investor
i can see how part of this guidance
might raise questions
since it might be many years till the
sipc claims are paid
or until it's clear that the sipc what
the sipc recovery will be
does the irs guidance allow taxpayers to
simply decline to make an sipc claim and
assert the position by some form of
affidavit and increase their eligible
theft loss
why wouldn't it be preferable to allow
people to defer the sipc reimbursements
and take the full tax loss now but if
they receive an sipc claim in the future
then the tax implications can be taken
into account at that time because people
are worried they're desperate and they
don't know what the sipc is going to do
for them yet yeah i mean a couple of
issues one is we've actually um
met with sipc i've met with the the
chairman um you know unfortunately in
this tragic situation probably the best
chance of people getting some money back
is through sipc and then recovering some
of the taxes uh that they've that
they've paid um and so it's important
what i would say is um each taxpayer is
a little different um
sipc is is treating uh you know some
different
they're treating people directly
invested different than they are people
not directly invested
and so you know the way that our
guidance read and again it's not just
made off because we're trying to cover
ponzi schemes in general because in down
economies that's where you usually see
more ponzi schemes come to light is that
it's deductible except for reasonable
prospect of recovery so what i i guess i
would say is
whether or not people expect to get sipc
you know as a facts and circumstances
depending on where they were situated in
this in this madoff scheme and people
are going to have to use their best jobs
come in under the safe harbor and again
there's a true up at the end so if they
get money and they took a deduction
they're going to have to pay taxes on it
if they didn't
if they thought they were going to get
money and they never get it they can
take that as a deduction later i would
just ask you in this guidance to be
again
uh as
uh
as much on the victim side as you can be
given the awful situation they're in
thank you thank you senator mandela
chairman
i have other questions are we going to
have a second round yes um great thank
you senator the wise man
thank you mr chairman i want to join uh
my other colleagues who asked you for
this hearing and i appreciate you doing
it so quickly as well
bernie madoff is probably the most
visible uh an incredible example of a
calamitous failure of the federal
government's uh responsibility and its
regulatory agencies to oversee
the market and we've had some of those
uh hearings in the banking committee the
failures of regulators to detect his
crimes are pretty outstanding and we're
left with the aftermath of personal
tragedies for people who
have had their entire life and their
nest eggs become empty shells and face
some real real difficult choices in
their lives so
i appreciate the commissioner the
guidance that you're issuing today i
want to follow up with one or two
questions to uh hopefully you'll have
the answers and if not we'll we'll hear
it subsequently um
just to follow up on senator schumer's
question uh according to your guidance
victims of the madoff scandal who
invested through feeder funds have to
wait
for
those funds to file their tax returns
and distribute the proceeds from the
securities investor protection
corporation payments and the deductions
proportionately now these leaves a lot
of these victims
many of whom had no idea that they were
even invested with madoff at the mercy
of the prompt action of their funds i
know you said you had a meeting uh with
the head of the sipc i is the irs going
to appropriately monitor the
distribution of these proceeds to the
feeder funds to ensure individual
victims receive a timely and accurate
payment from the funds
um
senator uh you know we're pretty focused
on this issue of direct investors in
director investors feeder funds
what i would say is we didn't make up
any new law
in putting out this guidance we did our
best interpretation of existing law
the way that any investor in any kind of
loss through a fund
gets that is usually through their k-1
and so it's really going to be up to
the direct investor to claim this
deduction
and then
flow through to their partners or you
know whoever else is you know however
structured llc partnership
the losses and so if you invested in a
partnership that then invested in madoff
the only way you're going to know what
the gains were in that partnership for
other investments what the other losses
were and what the madoff issues were is
is waiting to get that partnership
return through your k1
they should what we'll be doing is is
making sure that the loss
uh is appropriate
for the actual partnership when they
file it file it to us and so um i'm not
sure if i answered your question but um
the bottom line is that well they have
to wait for the feeder funds to do their
their their work and their reporting
that they're they're left out there
waiting so it's going to depend upon the
the diligence of the feeder funds at the
end of the day at the end of the day i
mean i think there's no other way in any
sort of partnership that you can file a
tax return you got to know what the
partnership has we'll have to look at
how yeah we'd be happy to look at it
we'll talk with your office let me ask
you in terms of documentation of losses
uh what's going to be considered proper
documentation to establish losses
particularly i know you're generally
looking at ponzi schemes in general but
due to the madoff fraud is our
for example is the irs going to permit
those who
were feeder group victims to establish
that they incurred losses by the use of
statements and other documentations that
they received from the feeder group yeah
i mean i don't um in general yes i mean
this is general guidance but um in the
madoff case we anticipate statements are
good enough because people actually um
you know they got this phantom income
they paid taxes on it the idea is you
can now get a deduction for it let me
ask you in our letter uh uh to you we we
asked whether or not you're going to
establish a special unit to process
claims related to the madoff fraud and
similar fraud simply because uh of the
efficiency and and uh the size of this
particular ponzi screen is is that
something that you're contemplating um
what we've done you know across
the board
we've taken a look at this very
significant economic downturn that we're
in
and everything from
[Music]
nol carrybacks for small businesses to
individuals in hardship situations to
those who have ponzi schemes made sure
that we've got streamlined processes to
take care of it and so
what we've done is we already have units
that can take care of this you'll notice
that there's going to be a special form
if you're looking to
operate under the safe harbor so you'll
self-identify that you're a victim of a
ponzi scheme and those returns will be
handled you know appropriately and
expeditiously okay
uh i have other questions i'll submit
them for the record one of them is about
how we treat iras particularly certain
types of iras of individuals who got
invested and made off even unknowingly
that they were invested there and how
those are going to be treated thank you
mr chairman
thank you senator senator grassley mr
chairman if i could before i ask
questions or reinforce the dialogue that
we had at the opening of this hearing
you alluded to some ways in which we
could make sure that the intent of
a portion of the tarp legislation be
carried out in that legislation the
finance committee insisted that anxiety
compensation be limited by ways of one
the loss of tax deduction for the
institution and two a penalty tax for ex
executive
in the cases of excess golden
parachutes under the legislation as
enacted these tax limitations only
applied in the case of an asset sale but
last year we were told that treasury
would no longer purchase troubled assets
in an auction sale instead treasury has
and will continue to infuse taxpayers
funds into a financial institution
largely through direct purchases
it is now high time that we apply the
tax related limitations to direct
purchases
i know that treasury made an attempt to
do this
in treasury guidance in my opinion that
guidance falls short of enforcement
enforcement should be stronger if the
limitations were written into the code
and while we're at it we should write
other limitations into the tax code like
clawback policies and other penalty
taxes on bonuses so i wish you'd
consider that at least you bet
mr commissioner
as i mentioned in my opening statement i
appreciate that the irs is moving
quickly to assist taxpayers during these
difficult times including victims of
ponzi however i'm concerned that the
guidance issued today will cause tax
cheats to consider taking abusive
deductions could you tell me how the irs
intends to monitor theft loss deductions
to ensure that only victims of actual
ponzi schemes
can take advantage to the guidance
that you're hearing are hastening today
yeah sure senator it's great great
question um anyone who takes advantage
of the safe harbor and streamline
implementation
of the um the procedure we're putting
out today
has to attach a form so they
self-identify and that's the key when
people self-identify coming in that
they're uh that they're claiming a
special deduction we can identify that
group we can take samplings out of that
group we can look behind the returns
there and so you know we're gonna we
will balance expediting these so that uh
you know people who are uh victims of
devastating loss actually have the
opportunity to get some relief but we
will also have enforcement and audit
coverage to make sure we look behind
these so that we don't have a lot of
fraud okay next so let's take a look at
the disheartening situation of billions
being lost
by charitable victims of ponzi
in congress
in 1969 we provided the irs with some
tools to curb bad investment decisions
by private foundations including
section
4944 excise tax on jeopardy investments
can you tell me if the irs is
considering assessing this tax on
individuals who ran some of these
organizations particularly the ones
which have been shut
down i'd also appreciate if you could
tell me how often the irs has assessed
this tax in recent years yeah um
i think you're referring to the private
foundation
jeopardy
investment rules
where we have the ability to
assess a 10 percent excise tax on
people who don't
exercise due diligence and proper
monitoring
of investments
i can't tell you because we haven't
gotten returns in yet around
ponzi schemes you know how many
investigations are open what i will tell
you is it is a tool that is available to
us that we certainly uh will consider um
and i don't have the answer off to come
back to you if it's okay on the record
uh than the number of time we've been
imposed the tax in recent years that's
very good thank you mr josephson
your testimony troubles me as you seem
to indicate that many states are not
minding the store when it comes to
protecting charitable assets yet the
panel on non-profit sector and others
recommended that the irs not be given
authority to enforce state fiduciary
duty rules
can you briefly
discuss the fiduciary duties
that states are supposed to
use to police
i would also appreciate hearing your
thoughts on whether congress should
provide the irs with authority to
enforce state laws when the state is
unable or unwilling to uh
to act
as you know mr chairman
excuse me as you know senator grassley
the state laws
for charities are widely unenforced
40 states
have no
charity enforcement capital
capability at all
and very little interest in enforcing
the state laws with respect to charities
of the 10 or so states that do
resources are very limited
and state law does not provide
effective means
for enforcers because many state laws
contain
rules like the business judgment rule
and the exculpatory provisions in the
uniform management of institutional
funds act that make it extremely
difficult
extremely difficult for state charity
officers to get results in these prudent
investment and other abusive situations
that is why
your committee staff in
2004 and myself and my own testimony
before the committee over many years
have advocated
additional resources to the internal
revenue service for this purpose and
also
a revenue sharing that might encourage
states that do not enforce the charity
laws to do so the vehicle for this as
you know could well be
the excise taxes and penalties that
were provided in 1969 tax reform act
which were intended at that time
to be used
for
charity oversight by the internal
revenue service unfortunately that has
never happened and so as my testimony
indicates for example the exempt
organization's people have very few
examiners fewer than 500
and yet there are a million eight
exempt organizations and seventy
thousand exempt organization
applications are filed each year this is
an enforcement burden that cannot be
discharged
thank you mr chairman
thank you senator stavenow you're next
no i won't do that
well thank you mr chairman for holding
this meeting and
let me start by saying i appreciate the
president obama's
comments and and leadership on these
issues and the chairman's leadership and
and senator levins and others who are
working very hard
to address what has become an outrage i
mean i think the majority of americans
feel that we've somehow
now created this culture of greed in
this country whether it's bernie madoff
or aig bonuses or the growth of offshore
tax havens the majority of people that
are working hard every day and
playing by the rules and you know just
trying to have a good life for their
family look around and go what in the
world is going on
and so
i mr uh commissioner shulman i want to
thank you it's uh kind of nice to hear
uh positive things about the irs uh and
uh
what um you've been doing and on behalf
of victims on behalf of people who find
themselves in difficult times uh not of
their making and
i would encourage you to continue to to
keep them foremost uh
in your
in your actions as you as you think
about what needs to be done
particularly right now for people
i'd like to speak a little bit about
what's happening globally because this
didn't happen in a vacuum we're in a
global
financial system we have a global
regulatory system
a global credit crisis
in the last quarter of 2008 the world
economy shrank for the first time since
1945.
the imf expects global growth to be
negative this year
and the first annual global con
contraction for over 60 years
and so it's going to be very important
next month
when we see
the g20 summit
to be
doing everything possible to effectively
work with other countries on this issue
it needs to be a coordinated effort
every country has a vested stake in
what's happening right now
and i would expect that cracking down on
abusive tax shelters and other issues
would be a top priority at the g20
summit and so
my first question would be what
suggestions do you have for
international cooperation as we look at
all these issues
yeah we
i've been very clear that we can't have
a go it alone strategy
that
we certainly have interests that we need
to pursue on behalf of the united states
but when you get to international tax
evasion
same institutions that are facilitating
the same people who are trying to hide
assets are
either cheating our government of money
in our citizens of money or cheating
other law-abiding citizens of money in
other jurisdictions
i think uh uh president obama's been
very clear that international uh tax
enforcement a robust international tax
enforcement is high on his agenda he's
also talked about some tax policy around
deferral and other things that will be
forthcoming as i said in in the next
several months
we've had a coordinated effort through
the oecd
on trying to bring bank secrecy
jurisdictions and so-called tax havens
into line with international standards
uh i'm quite proud of the work we've
done around the ubs case and others to
bring to light and bring international
attention and just last week
liechtenstein switzerland austria hong
kong singapore all agreed to
comply with oecd standards and so i
think it's that kind of combination of
individual enforcement actions bringing
to light these abuses as well as
international pressure
i know it was on the agenda last weekend
uh at when the finance ministers met at
the g20 um i'm assuming you know these
agendas uh morph over time uh clearly
the global financial crisis is a big
issue but i think everybody's very
focused on making sure that everybody's
playing by the rules while every
government is trying to you know take
care of their citizens and be a global
player and in the financial crisis well
there's no question that we're seeing
some increased transparency and more
willingness to share information i'm
wondering specifically with the tax
haven countries uh what we should be
doing additionally
to encourage or require in in some way
for them to be sharing information
specific information with us
yeah well i mean i guess what i would
say is uh if there's tax haven countries
that have been facilitating this um
lichtenstein for instance uh had some
problems with us with enforcement a year
ago they've now agreed
to an information exchange agreement
with us the only way we would agree
is that within a year they had to change
their bank secrecy laws so our
information sharing agreement trumped
their bank secrecy laws and were uh
monitoring that and assuming they do
that and if not we pull back our
information exchange agreement so those
are the kinds of things we can do
i will also tell you that i meet
regularly with a group of 10
tax administrators
globally and we've started talking about
things like more automatic information
sharing um strengthening cooperation a
great example is we have a thing called
jitsik which is a joint information tax
shelter information center where we
actually co-locate our people with
people from other countries
this year by people comparison comparing
notes we brought to light
a corporate
transaction issue that we're
aggressively pursuing called foreign tax
credit generators where basically a
corporation
does one transaction in a foreign
jurisdiction claims a credit both in the
u.s and somewhere else which really
perverts the the
foreign tax credit legislation that's
been passed i mean foreign tax credits
are designed so you don't pay taxes here
and somewhere else not so you can
generate a tax somewhere else and get a
deduction multiple places around the
world that wouldn't have happened if we
weren't co-locating people and in deeper
dialogue uh with people and so i think
it's going to be a combination of
bilateral treaties multilateral pressure
aggressive enforcement action potential
for policy changes as well as real
dialogue and cooperation amongst
countries that have like interests
thank you mr chairman
thank you senator sarah snow yeah thank
you mr chairman and like everyone else
um share and
outrage over
the payment by aig and their
announcement of bonuses it certainly is
a staggering insult
to the american people
it's in a total disregard of the reality
of the magnitude of their unconscionable
behavior
in the first place that has wreaked
havoc on the average american upended
and disrupted their lives you know
people who struggle every day to make
ends meet live by the rules work by the
rules and now they're losing their jobs
they're losing the value of their
pensions
so
i think that this is something that we
clearly you know have to focus on in
fact in talking about uh the bonuses we
had the opportunity during the stimulus
debate in fact senator wyden and i had
legislation that was passed by a voice
vote on the senate floor
that would have
retroactively given choices to companies
and that would have applied to aig in
this circumstance
where they either pay a 35 excise tax on
those bonuses or they would have to
return
the top money the money the taxpayers
have given
to aig and all the other
troubled institutions and we fought
during the conference
to maintain that provision regrettably
it was dropped and regrettably uh it you
know we could have been in a situation
uh today very different
uh have had that provision become law
and so i i would hope mr chairman we
would reconsider it i hope we could take
action perhaps we changed even the
taxation we use the top tax rate of 35
percent but it would have applied in
this instance for aig for any contracts
uh any commitments that were made during
the course of uh 2008 for any bonuses
that were paid
or were about were going to be paid and
so we would have been in a different
situation entirely today had that
provision
been enacted and accepted by the
conference
mr shulman uh ubs has
paid
782 million in taxes and penalties for
criminal offenses
and as we know with aig disclosing has
transferred billions of dollars to
financial
institutions
one of which of course is ubs
and we know that they have received 800
million plus 1.7 billion dollars for a
total of 2.5 billion dollars it's
extraordinary to me
uh that we would have had this kind of
transfer
uh to an institution that has secret
bank accounts we know that they've been
willing they've agreed with our
government to disclose the 250 accounts
in their identities but at one point
during the mid 2000s they had more than
52 000 accounts i think it just looks
like we're simply laundering this money
through
aig so that
ubs can pay back uh there's 782 million
dollars that they paid
uh for criminal offenses to the united
states government
would you respond
yeah um
well i mean a a few things one is as i
um you know as i said before um i can't
really add much to what the president
said yesterday about aig but as a
citizen i share your outrage
about
the bonus situation um
you know regarding ubs we're actually
still in active litigation with them
we're pursuing or the justice department
is suing on our behalf uh john doe
summons to get
all of the outstanding
bank accounts i've been very clear that
we plan to continue to pursue that and
to continue following
this trail i can't really speak much
more about the ubs case the justice
department has asked me not to to so
that you know me as the the leader of uh
agency um you know doesn't jeopardize
that case except to say you know for the
tax evasion case uh with ubs we plan to
pursue all the means we can to you know
there's been a case against the
institution and now we're making sure we
go after the u.s citizens that we're
using that institution to facilitate tax
evasion well just it's inconceivable to
me though that the treasury department
didn't look at these cash flows so on
one hand the ubs is paying 782 million
dollars in criminal offenses and
penalties the united states government
on the other hand they have benefited
through the top funds of 2.5 billion
dollars as a result of the disclosures
that were made by
aig
so yeah i mean i think that
uh something that should have been
regarded at the outset i don't know how
it even happened in the first place it
doesn't make sense yeah
and frankly it's preposterous
and so i don't you know blame the
american people about the extent of
which of their anger
and but this is something that frankly
that the treasury department should have
considered and in the first place
and rather than allowing this to happen
thank you mr chairman
thank you senator sir kerry
thank you mr chairman thanks a lot for
doing this hearing and again bringing
this subject up as you did earlier
last year
we appreciate it enormously this is a
subject that i've been
interested in and following since the
1980s when i stumbled across these
issues with the bcci case
and
i've brought a number of pieces of
legislation
which were passed which have helped to
increase the level of scrutiny that we
have with respect to uh transfers the
ten thousand dollar piece the
amendments with a number of countries on
their cooperative efforts with us but
clearly clearly
we've only scratched the surface and i
want to talk about that for a minute
um
the ubs effort
where we know that uh
there was a sort of initiative taken to
reach out to some 20 000 wealthy
americans and actually flout the tax
laws through the offshore banking
services and evade over 300 million
dollars in taxes now you've mentioned
the case is ongoing but help us
from a legislative point of view and an
oversight point of view uh
last
july when we had the hearing jack blund
testified here and you were here mr
shulman you hear mr roster that uh
the problem of offshore tax evasion is
exacerbated by the so-called revenue
rule the the understanding that
basically no government will help
enforce the tax laws of another
government do you in fact find that to
be true
um
you know i find it to be varying
among governments
i don't necessarily find that to be true
because i think there's a there's a lot
of like-minded
uh governments who understand that
if
one of our citizens is evading taxes and
they don't help us when one of theirs is
evading taxes they need to help us
we have treaties
around
that help us with information exchange
let me say as as chair of the foreign
relations committee i i will say that we
are going to look at those treaties and
we're going to start examining the
degree to which they have been enforced
not enforced or are impediments in some
cases
yeah no and i think that's worthwhile
effort because what i was going to say
is
um you know the the the model u.s treaty
for taxes
has 30 provisions everything from
pensions to annuities to exchange of art
those kinds of things around tax
treatment it only has one enforcement
provision article 26. that enforcement
provision is
generally designed you need to know the
name of the taxpayer you know
right senator kerry got a name you got
to name the account and go after them
and so while treaties are useful um they
don't necessarily spontaneously produce
the kind of information that that we'd
like to get that's why we use a variety
of other tools like the john doe summons
like other international cooperation
like the qi program where we have other
levers and clearly the kind of
legislation that this committee is
considering are levers that we could use
well it seems to me that we we even have
to go beyond that um i mean i have found
that a lot of these governments have
just fundamental indifference i remember
going to visit with the governor the
bank of england
with respect to
offshore
entities
this was about 10 years ago
and i found a remarkable level of
disinterest and even hostility towards
the idea of you know getting involved
gordon brown came here now as prime
minister a couple weeks ago and
announced from the podium of the house
that we have to end offshore
accounts that are basically havens
how do we do that
what's the cooperative effort necessary
for you
to be able to guarantee that those
accounts the chairman referred to in the
cayman islands
uh
are
in fact legitimate business interests
with with a
rather than just pass-throughs and
cutouts and
you know shell corporations and so forth
is there an international standard this
is at the g20 even that ought to be
discussed in a week or so
that they ought to be talking about
an international legitimate
business standard sham transaction
standard
and uh level of scrutiny
um i i guess i'd say a couple things um
one is i'd say there's no silver bullet
there's going to be multiple pieces of a
strategy that include enforcement
regulations
legislation as well as international
cooperation two is i would separate
individuals hiding income offshore
through sham trusts and accounts and
corporations because you have two
different sets of issues i think you're
asking the question about the
corporation
set of issues and as mr brostek said
there's some corporations just doing
some business transactions that make
sense internationally there's some that
are doing aggressive but legal tax
planning and that gets to tax policy and
then there's some who are clearly
you know being abusive and avoiding
taxes and those are the ones that we go
after i think one of the issues that's
on the table that the president's put on
the table in his 2010 budget is the
issue around deferral
because i think your conversation uh
with uh in the uk
you know countries compete on tax rates
uh countries compete to have businesses
and less regulation more regulation i
think what we've seen in recent days is
that all countries are are connected and
that there need to be some standards uh
globally but you know probably
the simplest thing is uh and it's being
discussed as the president signaled in
his blueprint is some of the deferral
issues because once u.s corporation has
to pay taxes everywhere my job as irs
commissioner becomes much easier because
there's not as much incentive to play
games so i can't well
excuse me sarah carper i'm sorry sir
carpers next sorry
thanks very much uh
sean you were good to come by my office
and meet with me almost a year ago i
think it was before you'd been confirmed
you've been in your post for i think
about a year now
and is that correct
a dog year feels like seven
[Laughter]
welcome yes yes
welcome to the pound
uh
i uh
you serve a term of five years as i
recall is that correct that's correct
any idea how long that's been the case
uh five year term for the commissioner
it was part of the
irs restructuring reform act uh 98 was
the first five-year term
and so there i'll be the third
commissioner who was confirmed for
approximately five years i hesitated
asking this question but you think it's
it's a good idea
what's that do i think it's a good idea
to have a five-year term it stretches
across different terms for president um
you know my belief is that um you know
the irs needs to be a non-partisan
by the books agency that enforces the
law
that is
removed from politics
it's also a large organization
with very complex people and technology
issues that take many years to actually
get a strategy and and stick with it so
the reason why i ask the reason why i
ask i chair a subcommittee that has
jurisdiction over among other things the
census bureau
and we're wrestling with whether or not
the director of the bureau of census
should also serve a uh an extended term
as as as you do and other commissioners
will in the future so thank you very
much because the the the parameters that
you just described with your agency uh
are very similar to those that uh that
exist in
the the census bureau so thank you but i
won't comment on the census bureau all
right just fill out your census form and
we'll be fine all right
um
uh as you may recall when you visited
with us we talked a bit about the tax
gap we talked about uh how uh how when
information is reported we actually do a
pretty good job of collecting taxes from
from from those people and the the
stimulus package that we passed we uh we
we sent money a lot of different uh
directions a lot of it to put people to
work as far as i know none of that money
was directed to the the internal revenue
service i'm wondering though uh with
respect to the omnibus appropriations
bill which was just enacted i think just
signed by the president uh were
were there any uh resources provided in
that legislation
for the balance of this fiscal year that
can help you and your colleagues at the
irs do your job better um you know the
answer is uh
yes um
uh chairman baucus a number of uh other
members of of congress have been
incredibly supportive of the irs and irs
budget to go after the tax gap
as we talked about with the tax cap
you know we have a proven return on
investment as an agency five to one for
specific programs thirteen to one
fourteen to one um and so increasing our
resources is going to be
key um there were increase in
enforcement resources in the current
omnibus bill uh president obama's budget
outline uh outlines a couple things one
is robust irs enforcement programs but
also
very clearly a long-term commitment
because one of the things about federal
agencies is if you give a bunch of money
one year and then don't in the last it
takes a while to to plan to recruit when
we bring on an agent we have to pull
other agents off of cases to train them
we have to put them on simpler cases and
pull different inventory off and so
that's a piece of it
the other that's quite helpful that is
in the 2010 budget that this committee
took leadership on uh was credit card
reporting and basis reporting that the
real way to leapfrog uh and get a real
grip on the tax gap is our resources and
also clearly information reporting
because the more information we get from
third parties the better we're going to
do uh at our job and you know the last
thing i'd say is there was 51 million
dollars in
the
appropriations uh or in the omnibus bill
that just passed
for research for the irs the only real
credible way to do tax gap research is
to do audits of returns you wouldn't
otherwise do an audit for because you
don't know what's there unless you go
and look in places you wouldn't look
usually we're auditing returns that have
higher yields where we see indicators
that there'll be collection we actually
do random audits and so this investment
in research so we can continue to hone
in and target our resources better is
key
and so um we've i think we've gotten a
lot of support and we're going to keep
at it good i i share the uh the passion
of our chairman and uh that of a number
of people in our committee to go after
as much
of this uh tax money that's owed not
being collected and you want to make
sure you have the resources the
personnel the technology to to to do
that to do that work um mr you've been i
think good enough to participate as i
recall maybe in a round table that we
had on on this subject uh earlier uh uh
you know several months ago and uh
just
staying with the the tax cap are there
uh some points that you'd like to share
with us uh that that you would have us
focus on this year within particular
within this committee to uh to go after
not just the low-hanging fruit but the
fruits that's a little higher on the
tree
well there are a number of things that
could be done
looking for additional information
reporting is clearly one of the best
strategies
when the information is reported we
collect about ninety percent of their
iris collects about ninety percent or
more yes um i think it's up to ninety
six percent pretty complete information
reporting irs knows exactly the same
income items that the taxpayer knows uh
one area that i think is maybe a little
under appreciated is the role of the
paid preparer community
well over half of taxpayers use a paid
preparer to prepare their returns
there's a pretty good body of evidence
that the performance of that community
is not stellar
sometimes that may be because the
taxpayer is not providing good
information
but there's also a sort of an emerging
body of evidence that the preparers
themselves are not always
diligent and competent
i think that's one of the areas that
might be worth paying some attention to
thank you thank you very much thank you
senator catwoman
thank you mr chairman and i want to add
my thanks for you holding this important
hearing made off uh
fraud and schemes defrauded about 8 000
people and over 50 billion dollars so on
top of everything else we've been
through to have this incident happen is
just
unbelievable and part of i think the
importance of the hearing today is to
also look at the regulatory reforms that
we need to put in place
but first i want to thank
commissioner shulman for being here into
the irs statement of guidance that was
issued today i'm very pleased that the
irs ruled
and procedures that were putting in
place that direct investors can have
more predictability on how to handle
these theft losses and so
i very much appreciate the fact that the
irs has
moved forward on that
my question is
in regards to this to the regulatory
side of this
equation
stephen harbach from the civic told the
house financial services in january
quote it became apparent very early in
the madoff case
that the customer statements mr madoff
had been sending to investors board
little
or no relation to reality
the record sent to customers were
inaccurate when compared with the
inventory of securities actually held by
the brokerage firms
and so
sometimes tax
regulators themselves can
help be the canary in the coal mine and
showing signs of danger
because they can get access to
information that others can't get access
to
so um
while madoff was sending bogus
statements to his clients they were also
making real payments to the irs so my
question is
um
could the irs have connected some of
these dots sooner and perhaps focus some
of the attention on the right
areas and how much interaction does the
irs treasury and sec
have when it comes to coordinating these
very complex investment firms yeah um
you know a couple of uh
a couple of issues one is uh the
majority of our investment uh
enforcement resources are focused on
collecting taxes as you said you know
one of the issues that the reason we're
putting out guidance people actually
were paying taxes on these and that's
you know frankly we've got a big enough
job to do um uh and you know the
complexity of the codes going up that we
need all the resources we can to make
sure we we collect the proper amount of
tax and that's where um we're very
focused you know our first line of sight
isn't to look at um you know investment
schemes and those kinds of things uh
with that said i'm a big believer that
um you know i'm a public servant i i'm
here to serve the american uh people and
that i need to coordinate with other
leaders in the government uh to try to
uh
to to try to make sure it works
efficiently as possible
we've made our forensic
investigators our especially our
criminal investigators who are very good
at following the money trail available
to other federal agencies to coordinate
on uh enforcement and fraud cases we
have a long tradition of that but we're
um doing that especially in some ponzi
related schemes you might have seen we
filed
some tax issues around another prominent
ponzi scheme do you think if you had
do you think if you would have had the
resources and we had bitter coordination
that we could have connected some of the
dots you know i i think it's always easy
to look in the rear view mirror a lot of
people were duped by
bernie madoff from federal regulators to
to very sophisticated uh in investors
we're going to continue to coordinate
and assist where we can we're certainly
going to try to make our resources
available
i've actually
had conversations with the chairman of
the sec about how we take tips in and i
know she's moving aggressively on
getting better at synthesizing tips and
so i'm a believer that we can all learn
from each other and that we should share
as much information expertise personnel
as we can do you think there's any
um legal obstacles for more coordination
um because again it seems to me that you
have access to records and information
that help piece the puzzle together yeah
well i mean
section 6103 which is pretty locked down
provision around
us not sharing taxpayer information is
quite important important to
the the integrity of the whole tax
system that people feel like they're
filing taxes they're bringing it in and
it's not going to be shared
with that said
that's sharing it with the public there
are some impediments sometimes to
sharing with other agencies and we're
certainly open to exploring if the
information we have can be helpful in
fraud cases of how to get those into the
hands of other authorities well i think
i certainly want to explore that with
you because i think the interagency
coordination and cooperation is critical
on many fronts and i would assume with
doj investigations you probably do that
now
to some some degree but if you did it
across several agencies that it would
also help in
identifying these sooner
and i will tell you i mean to the other
topic we're talking about with offshore
um we're actually now
very aggressively having conversations
with other agencies around how do we
triage all the information that the
federal government has to do a better
job and so i very much agree with with
the direction you're headed
thank you and mr chairman i i know that
this is um you know we've had all of
this economic crisis on individuals and
the impact but
the amount of capital losses that
taxpayers can write off against their
income is limited to three thousand
dollars i know my colleague senator
bunning has brought this up before but i
think it's something really the
committee should look at
maybe spend a little more time looking
at this particular area and how we can
help
help consumers yeah thank you senator
um i'd just like to ask you a question
mr
commissioner shulman about ubs
as i understand it
um
[Music]
at the urgents of the justice department
justice department one agreement with
ubs
which ubs agreed to turn over the names
of about 250 customers suspected
of
evading of tax evasion we're not talking
about whiteness here we're talking about
invasion
and ubs also agreed to pay a 580 million
but
bobby burkenfeld a former ubs employee
said the u.s persons hid more than 15
billion in assets
with the assistance of ubs private
wealth management
group and
i think the irs alleges that
approximately 52 000
u.s persons use ups to hide assets
in that swiss bank alone pbs
what's going on here
they've only given us names at 250.
you think they're 52 000 more
what's happening here how do we how do
we get
the information we want
let me say a couple things mr chairman
first of all um i would love to go into
this case with you and brag about it
because i think uh the irs actually
found this brought this to light it
created international attention i
complement that and as you know i can't
really talk about specific taxpayer
cases
etc what i will tell you is uh there's
two things that happen there was a
deferred prosecution agreement that
was around ubs
um being indicted criminally that the
justice department deferred that with a
set of conditions that are all part of
the public record right um there's also
the irs's john doe summons
to
force ubs to produce all of the accounts
and that's being litigated through the
courts now and so what's going on is uh
prosecution was deferred
um on the criminal matter but we're
pursuing the the civil matter and
continuing to try to get as many uh of
the accounts as we can my view is we
should get
all the accounts but i i can't prejudge
it there's going to be a hearing in july
with the judge but how do we get out the
swiss problem because i understand that
switzerland makes its own decision
whether or not the requested
name john doe is is a is violating the
law yeah that's they're making their own
determination themselves and if they
determine well gee maybe this person
john doe is not by law we're not going
to send the name to the irs
that's that's a problem that's not their
judgment as to whether
you know
u.s law is being violated that's
judgment in that state seem to me yeah
one of the problems um we talked about
treaties a little bit before
sovereign law often trumps treaties
these indications we've gotten from some
of the bank secrecy jurisdictions
including switzerland to comply with the
oecd standards would actually have our
information exchange potentially trump
sovereign law so that's one of the ways
to get at it bank secrecy is a big issue
for us uh at the irs um in the swiss
case as i understand it
for us you send in a tax return you sign
your tax return um if if you don't uh if
you if you basically lied on the tax
return it's uh
tax evasion um the swiss interpretation
isn't the same you actually have to you
know actively it's not just about
signing a tax return and sending it in
you have to actively conceal assets set
up phony trust and have acts of
commission rather than omission right so
to what degree do our
would do information reporting
actually trump
sovereign swiss law
would information information if we
require this this legislation we're
contemplating here
uh were to be enacted
um
[Music]
how much how what do that help
well i think what it would do is i'm not
sure it trumps swiss law but we'd
actually see the flows come going out of
the u.s and be able to connect that to
u.s citizens and what we're doing with
the john doe summons is trying to get
the names of the u.s citizens so what it
would actually do is potentially give us
a line of sight wow the money left not
years later when we're trying to trying
to grab back uh the money that's already
gone so i think this kind of information
reporting is definitely worth um
exploring and could give us it could be
a great tool for us so how many other
havens are there you know liechtenstein
is
stepping forward as i understand it
um and dora has monaco is not
does i understand it
i read in the papers that they say they
are but i that's all i know okay well i
don't want to hear the current position
in monaco is to make no comment at all
so the state official now i don't know
common means that's just
what he said
um
under singapore got a problem with
singapore
what are some of the countries we got
problems with here
well i guess i'd rather um i would
rather not yeah listing a name of
countries is uh that's what purview of
treasury state department obviously
we've got our eyes on it i mean what all
i i guess what i would say is we name
names that puts the sunshine on those
countries but they will glare on them
embarrasses them they might do something
well i think we've uh that'd be just
cozy in here you know not going to
vote
let's just say i uh
i'm probably not going to be doing a lot
of ski vacations in the swiss alps
so it uh
the
i think bank secrecy is an issue so
places that have bank secrecy laws
places that don't have information
exchange agreements with us are a
problem and then by definition places
that hold themselves out as low or no
tax jurisdictions and so i'm more
focused on set of criteria the ones you
listed are all ones that that we've that
are on our radar where we see
transactions going on there we go my
time's expiring i just urge you just to
go for it and you have such support in
this country for being just
very very vigorous
very vigorous
almost embarrassingly vigorous
i i think that american taxpayers be
very proud i know i will personally if
you do
okay senator schumer is next thank you
mr chairman i really appreciate your
having the hearing i think it's on two
very important subjects and uh
appreciate the second round
and all the witnesses i'm going to
return to the issue that i care about
i care about both but i'm questioning
about because i agree it's embarrassing
what did you say mr chairman it's
embarrassingly well i would like him to
be embarrassingly vigorous
embarrassingly vigorous on offshore
stuff and i agree right okay um we then
we back off a little bit just be very
vigorous
[Laughter]
for this year
a man from montana has spoken
next question this is back on helping
the victims of madoff uh and this one's
it sounds innocuous but it's very
important technically to a lot of people
how will the irs handle theft losses for
individual taxpayers that invested with
madoff directly but did so inside a
retirement vehicle like an ira or a roth
i.r.a this is sort of uncharted waters
but a lot of victims were affected
inside these accounts average
middle-class people yeah um
you know 401ks iras retirement vehicles
if
an investment was deductible
going in you can't take a loss going out
because there weren't taxes paid on it
right um there are some exceptions as
you mentioned like a roth ira
the rules get very complicated but if um
if it's after tax money there may be the
ability to take losses but mostly you
take losses at the time of distribution
and so i just encourage people to look
at the guidance and to have
conversations with our council's office
right again i would just urge you to be
as
helpful as you can to the victims in
this regard particularly with the roth
ira situation can i can i make just one
clarifying comment about your your
earlier comment um senator you talked
about a five-year carry-back and
indefinite carry forward 20 right
of the of the
law of the loss
um
under general rules it's a three-year
carry-back because you have an
investment theft loss it's defined as a
business
loss under the code and you can carry it
back for three years um a unique twist
of the american recovery and
reinvestment act says for 2008
if you have gross receipts of less than
15 million dollars you get a five-year
carry back so i didn't want people
listening to this uh to be confused so
they're gonna need to look at their
circumstances look when they discover it
but if you were below 15 million you're
okay with the five years
in 2008 yeah okay good uh the one point
um about the ira just to make it the
money in the ira was still stolen it's
in an ira but it was still it's still
gone so anything you can do to be
helpful
okay third
does the guidance uh say anything about
potential clawback payments that the
victims who had previously withdrawn
funds may have had to make what's the
tax treatment of such clawbacks under
current law would taxpayers receive a
deduction for such payments um so the
the
the ruling is it tries to clarify
existing law not make up law
and it's deductible in the year
discovered except for reasonable
prospects of recovery um and i think
people need to determine that in all
ponzi schemes i think you know the the
made off people will understand the
situation better than i will because
they're in contact with the trustee how
much of there is a reasonable prospect
of recovery what i will tell you though
is there's a true up at the end so if
people take a deduction and get that
loss they're going to be able if they
then get some sort of payment they'll
just be taxed on it if they don't take
the deduction because they think they're
going to get it and they never get yes
any sort of recovery then they can take
that lossless good okay again i have to
repeat
uh that the irs has done
all of the rulings and the guidance that
you've given are really helpful to the
victims and i don't know if i mentioned
this we've heard from victims themselves
already since yesterday because we
shared what you had shared with us ahead
of time we've heard from some of their
lawyers that they're really happy with
what the irs is trying to do here it's a
rare day when someone can be very happy
with the irs and this is it it's a good
day
in a difficult situation so thank you um
i'm going to yield back my time because
the chairman's been generous i have a
few more questions could i ask unanimous
consent to submit
and the uh commissioner answered them in
writing within say five days would that
be all right that's true you can do that
yeah but we'll get them as quickly as i
think we'll get them back thank you
fewer fewer than five days because thank
you rule here is what about two or three
what is the rule two weeks
general
we're
three days
because chairman has ruled we just
certainly will obey them there's three
days okay since no uh thank you again um
commissioner shulman
to follow up again on ubs because i
think it's extremely uh disturbing
about this
uh frankly and i realize it's a matter
of the justice department and the irs at
this point regarding ubs and its
unwillingness to disclose all of these
accounts
but regardless
is you know we have a situation where we
have given a bank
2.5 billion dollars
federal taxpayers money
and they're paying 782 million in
criminal penalties and taxes the united
states government for
tax evasion
so the bottom line is we're giving money
to an institution
that has been involved in tax evasion
there's nobody in america that can
understand that
so we better make it abundantly clear to
the the swiss government even so
whether we have a treaty or not we
should make it abundantly clear
we frankly should rescind that money i
mean i just think it's absolutely
preposterous that we're in this
situation today
we're dealing on one hand with the
bonuses
and now on the other hand we're
dealing with the situation that we're
giving
money to an institution that has been
engaged in tax evasion
and i know that secretary geithner will
be making this a priority at the g20
meeting in april
absolutely so in terms of bank secrecy
laws and tax evasion but nevertheless in
this
situation we need to address it
i don't think it's something that we can
defer and well we'll go forward in the
future
we're dealing with the bad we're dealing
with a bank that refuses to disclose all
of its accounts they're saying it's a
matter for diplomatic channels between
the united states government and the
swiss government
but it's also a matter of the united
states congress
and i don't think it's something that we
can ever justify or accept
so i know that going forward everybody
said well we'll address it we need to
address this now and retroactively in my
estimation because i just don't think
it's
at all tolerable under these
circumstances
and to that point this has been
something that
ubs has been engaged in for the better
part of the decade since 2000
was there at any point do you know to
your knowledge
if anybody ever approached the irs
similar to harry mcopolis who approached
the sec regarding bertie madoff
was there anybody who ever approached
irs about ubs
and
these secret bank accounts at any point
between 2000 2007 before the irs
identified this problem
now to my knowledge
it's hard to imagine actually because
this this obviously this institution not
only failed to pay 220 million in taxes
obviously paying penalties and interest
up to 782 million dollars
so at no point during that decade that
anybody ever approached the irs it was
any indication that there was anything
wrong
well i will tell you um you know it's in
the public record i can only talk about
the public record but um we actually um
you know through informants through
going after aggressively other cases
uh
got on to this issue and so again i mean
this is um something that uh
you know
i think that the agency has you know
with our stepped-up focus on
international tax evasion got laser-like
in this started pursuing the john doe
summons started to bring international
pressure and so um you know this is one
where um there's plenty of things that
we don't do perfectly we're always
looking to improve this is one where we
got on top of it uh and are continuing
to pursue it as i said and and you i
want to tell you that um you know you've
got my personal commitment to continue
to pursue uh these matters
i appreciate that too and i appreciate
uh the work
uh mr josephson on the pension benefit
guaranty corporation that's obviously
response responsible for pension plans
when a company becomes insolvent uh
there was a case of the east river
management company which is no longer in
operation when defunct and pbgc had to
take it over in december
um
you know
is it routine for the pbgc to assume
fiduciary responsibility for a company
that didn't even diversify
i mean should there be any standards uh
in with respect to that
uh because it's clear in this case uh
they turned over all of their money to
bernie madoff and there's no
diversification within this plan now
pvgc is obviously
having to assume responsibility
for this now defunct
plan
it depends where you think senator the
risk of loss should fall
obviously diversification is required
by the applicable state law
and for the failure to diversify there
would be state penalties against the
insolvent
corporation that did not diversify
but
where is the pension benefit corporation
going to be able to collect that right
there is a conundrum here
and i don't know that there is under
state law
or federal law any effective remedy in
that situation
but
particularly in response to
the dialogue between senator capper and
mr bostic and ms cantwell's questions i
think we also need to focus
on whether or not
the accounting profession
in auditing
exempt organizations
publicly supported charities
private foundation
pension plans is actually doing its job
in my five years as head of the
charities bureau in new york
i found that the resources that
accounting firms even the big four
accounting firms devoted to this kind of
work were meager
compared to
what they purport to devote to
the major publicly held companies but
even in that case senator you will
certainly remember
that the failures of the auditing
function for publicly held companies in
effect required the federal government
to federalize those accounting standards
in the public company's accounting
oversight board
and there is another analogy here that i
think is relevant because of mr
brostik's remark about the incidence of
tax evasion in returns prepared by paid
preparers
there are in fact no federal standards
for
auditors that account for
exempt organizations
and that is an aspect that the committee
ought to take into account
for example there is a recent precedent
the treasury in response to the
committee's initiative with respect to
donated property
has issued regulations that really
require
appraisers of donated property to meet
set qualifications
and to express their opinions in a set
form
no such requirement
exists with respect to the paid
preparers that prepare returns for
exempt organizations and as i said
before my experience in the charities
bureau is they do not devote the same
kind of resource and the same kind of
acumen there is no evidence for example
that any of the accountants that audited
any of the made off funds ever did a
walk through to try to determine whether
or not
the statements he was providing were
actually backed by transaction slips
madoff's trustee
mr picard has said publicly that there
are no transaction slips for madoff
transactions over the whole 13 years of
the scandal i cannot understand
why the auditing function did not at
some point uncover that and this is an
important subject it seems to me for irs
and committee oversight you are
absolutely correct and thank you very
much for those very constructive uh
suggestions thank you
gentlemen i have a just a couple of
questions uh uh to uh to wrap up at
least for me we again thank you very
much for for being here today and for
your responses and for for your service
uh too
um when i was governor of delaware we
had every year we had a an award um
uh that was uh provided sort of like a
state version of a national award that
was uh offered to either businesses as a
quality award for best quality and some
business operation it could be a
non-profit it could be actually a public
entity that that won i think my last
last year as governor the winner was the
delaware division of revenue
and because they did a very good job
collecting taxes that were owed they
also did a pretty good job in providing
customer service and i think you
demonstrated again here today that that
uh we can do both and uh where we
applied you and and the folks who were
part of your team
um you mentioned uh mr shulman i believe
you mentioned that in the uh the omnibus
appropriations bill to fund the irs for
the balance of this fiscal year there
was maybe 50 million dollars that was
appropriated i think you said that could
be used for research
and you welcomed that
i think the last time we actually had an
extensive study of the tax gap may have
been in tax year 2001 and i would just
ask if the ers might have
any plans to use some portion of that 50
million to update the tax gap are you
aware of any other initiative that's
underway to do so
yeah um
you know the tax gap number uh as i've
gotten under it is you know it's very
difficult to estimate the tax gap um the
current numbers that are public are 2001
numbers um very few of those are actual
2001 numbers a lot of them are
extrapolated numbers from 1986
when we used to do very extensive kind
of random audits to really really get
under it
we've got a commitment to update the tax
gap more regularly
focus on some areas where research
hadn't been done um and also to do
things like i mentioned before do some
random audits rather than just targeting
the areas where um
we normally you know we try to do audits
and have lower lower no change rates so
we target it correctly so
the answer is yes it's all
focused at what we call our national
research program which
tar which gets under
reasons for non-compliance where there's
non-compliance and eventually leads us
to data-driven resource allocation
decisions about how to go after
non-compliance which as you said is a
combination of good service for people
who are confused by a very complicated
tax code and aggressive enforcement for
those who are trying to evade the law
thank you a question mr mr bostick and
also for for you commissioner um
sticking with uh tax cap
again uh we we all know we need
additional third-party uh reporting in
areas that go beyond the measures that
are already enacted we've talked about
some of those today basis reporting is
one we've talked i think today about
credit card reporting however i also
believe that it's important to make sure
that we're targeting what i would
describe as the right uh the right
people
with respect to the statutory authority
the irs has already been given
and may be given in the future
how does the the irs if you will thread
the needle between increasing
enforcement targeted on unscrupulous
taxpayers
while not accidentally imposing undue
hardships on taxpayers who are trying to
comply with the law
well maybe i'll start and pass it over
the the research that the commissioners
referred to is fundamental to their
being able to determine which taxpayers
are most likely to be non-compliant
geo has long supported the type of
research that irs is undertaking
it improves their selection process to
ensure that they are bothering the
fewest number of taxpayers who are
completely compliant
in addition to that
the irs personnel do have informants and
receive tips
they receive tips through the enhanced
whistleblower protections that this
committee was
responsible for all those things help
irs in identifying the most likely
non-compliant taxpayers
if i could i'd like to
mention one other thing in relation to
the research that i think is
sometimes underappreciated and that's
that it helps in constructing
systemic solutions
the basis reporting provision that is
being implemented now that iris has
regulations out and they're being
commented on grew out of research that
we did using the nrp database from the
2001 text year
we were able to go into the files from
that research
to develop the case that basis reporting
was practical and would have an effect
on the tax gap related to that
particular problem
so it's not just that that research
helps with the selection of routine
audits it helps us revise regulations
and create statutory solutions to the
problem thank you and mr chris you just
respond briefly please yeah i mean i
think that uh
i guess i don't think it's a
necessarily a choice the way i think
about it that um basis reporting for
example
anyone who's compliant has nothing to
fear
there's a lot of compliant taxpayers who
spend a lot of time when they sell a
stock digging around and trying to
figure out what was their basis when
they bought it and if they reinvested
dividends and so
i think a lot of people who are trying
to be compliant are actually going to
welcome third party sends it to us third
party sends it to you you attach it and
you're done versus you know the the
rigmarole you go through now trying to
figure out what your basis was and so
if done right information reporting
rather than us suspecting you and going
and doing an extensive audit which is
more burdensome actually if done right
is less burdensome gives us the
information allows us to do our
compliance job without a full-blown
audit
and so should be quite helpful but like
i said before you know our job is as we
get information uh to make sure that we
um use it appropriately and only with
people who um you know aren't or as much
as possible with people who aren't
compliant the other the other thing i
would just say is there's something
about information reporting has a direct
enforcement effect it also uh people's
behavior changes when they think you can
see
and so the w-2 is people are very
compliant not because we're running so
many w-2 versus uh income checks we do
it automatically so we see all your w-2s
but also it's just no one i think would
would think about lying about their
wages because they know it's sent right
to the irs and so it has an inadvertent
you know it has a real effect on
voluntary compliance as well as on our
direct compliance program that's a very
good point um again thank you for your
testimony today and mr chairman i've got
another question too i'd like to submit
for the record but uh you've been very
helpful we appreciate your uh
participation and your your uh testimony
thank you
thank you senator um commissioner i just
have a question about your budget you're
getting a slug
of
uh you get a big increase in your budget
which is great
i think instead of 11 billion is that
correct you have 13 billion
if the president's proposals agree to um
it's a it's a significant increase i
don't i don't think that the details
haven't come out will come out okay yeah
okay i understand it's very significant
the question is how do you tend to put
this extra funding to work
what are you going to do with it
and what about
offshore enforcement
as
what component is offshore enforcement
and third question is what goals and
milestones what measures what benchmarks
will you put in place to determine
whether or not you're successful
sure um happy to happy to go through
that with you um
we're going to put the budget to work by
making sure we get the right personnel
to do what we need to do is one
component we're going to hire examiners
uh agents special agents who some of
which we'll put offshore uh in in other
localities we're going to hire
economists financial product specialists
appraisers lawyers all the people we
need to to go after the complex trail of
money that is involved both in the u.s
and and overseas
we're also going to use it to
perfect the data we have in-house so
that we're doing data modeling correctly
innovate around data modeling so we're
going after the the right evasion that
happens both here and at home and
overseas
get third party information in and
combine it with our data so we can again
be better at targeting and using data
from other agencies and other countries
to make sure we're triangulating in on
enforcement uh issues
um we're also just in a gross sense
gonna open more cases look at more
issues large business for instance you
know every every major corporation has
an audit every year um we're now going
to be able to look at more issues and go
deeper into issues and some of the
things in your legislation should allow
us some more time
uh to go deeper and then on partnerships
uh you know right now we audit a
partnership a partnership is usually a
web of multiple sometimes hundreds of
partners we're gonna use those resources
and the new people we have to be able to
look further through actually trace the
money so that we're looking at the whole
economic picture not just the entity uh
which which we're doing a tax return and
so it's really people
technology do our job better
the measures
that
we will use we've got our traditional
measures coverage
case closures audit by type enforcement
dollars
we clearly the the president has set out
a five to one return or depending on
where the money is going for enforcement
a seven to one return a 13-1 return
we're going to need to
monitor that
i think we also
need to work on measures around earlier
identification of issues before i talked
about foreign tax credit generators we
got on top of that and so having
better trained people more of them
pursuing more issues getting to issues
earlier so we stop problems before they
start
those are somewhat intangibles and
aren't going to show up in our
traditional metrics but they're things
that we're going to need to look at and
then i guess the last thing i'd say is
um as we develop measures i'm very
anxious to work with you and others on
legislation because depending on what
kind of new tools we get we'll be able
to have a much higher bar for ourselves
to go after um
just i just want to answer international
significant portion will be
international um as you know the
president set out 210 billion dollars a
combination of policy uh and enforcement
and frankly um there's only you know
we're going to take year after year
pretty much as many resources as we can
absorb into the international arena get
trained and get up to speed in that year
and continue focusing there i actually
last uh october 1 when we were under a
budget freeze and were basically under a
hiring freeze took some attrition money
from other areas and put it into
international because i thought it was
so important that we continue to invest
in that area and not fall behind okay
um i guess there are a lot of pretty
bright people out there trying to evade
taxes a lot of preparers tax lawyers
others
do you feel that when you hire that
you'll
be able to hire people with sufficient
confidence and talent expertise and
know how all this is how taxes are being
evaded yeah i mean we've we've talked
before uh mr chairman i um one of my
highest priorities is our workforce
getting the right people training them
making sure they're motivated making
sure they have the right tools i
actually have a centralized unit that's
reporting directly to me to revamp a
variety of workforce efforts
for our hiring we've now pulled it out
of the business units and are
centralizing our hiring infrastructure
i think one of the um
one called silver linings but one of the
realities in this economic downturn is
we've got uh
time right now we're getting more
applicants for every opening than we've
ever gotten in our history of incredibly
qualified people so i plan to take
advantage of this that may be true and
there may be an opportunity
major opportunity i've run across this
uh in several different circumstances
um in fact i was talking to one of the
top lawyers in the obama administration
and he
said you know
they thought that um
that when after the president was
elected they'd get a lot of applicants
of
jobs in his shop and
and very talented people he was wrong he
was flooded
and by applicants for people were just
much more talented even just i mean just
the brightest people one could possibly
hope for
um second i was once i was talking to
at the president harvard university not
too long ago she said
you know it's amazing you know not too
many years ago i went what school it was
and it was harvard college or
maybe it was
some other unit that about the large
majority of their students want to go to
wall street because that's where the
money was
and they loved making but she said
frankly
that a lot of people really didn't
they're going because that's
it was peer pressure to go
but now that the wall street is sort of
on the downside
a lot of students said gee that's great
because i really didn't want to do that
anyway
you know i want to go to produce you
know public service what about africa i
want to go help people help do these
things and then i'm running into it um
anecdotally uh people that's in wall
street and elsewhere say hey you know
now i could i don't have to you know
chase you know the dollars much
there's so much pressure to chase the
dollar
and but now i can do some things like i
kind of want to do so it's i think it's
a real opportunity here it's people a
lot of people want to serve they care
about our country they want to help
serve our country and i just i just urge
you to take advantage of that get to get
the best and the brightest and they got
their head screwed on straight too
as they're they're doing their work but
thank you commissioner very much you're
doing a real good job and we'll just
keep working together to address some of
these problems appreciate all the
support
[Music]
brownies francisco in nine days on the
eighth anniversary of the september 11th
attacks those are some of the latest
headlines on c-span radio
washington journal continues
erin arvidlen is the author of too good
to be true the rise and fall of bernie
madoff good morning thanks for joining
us thank you i want to share with you
one of the headlines this morning from
the washington post bernie madoff was
quote astonished that the sec never
caught him that's right i think
i think he expected to be caught long
before he was and what this ig report
the inspector general report shows is
that
it was a series of
almost keystone cop type of examinations
one hand didn't know what the other was
doing
uh and
and uh at one point i think the
the examiners were given his dtc number
which is basically a a tracking agency
showing where custody of securities are
they just never checked
the essence of the book can be found in
the summary i want to share with the
audience what you wrote the madoff
scandal transcends ethnicity religion
class and even international borders and
shows that even the savviest and most
intelligent people can be duped into
believing something that is too good to
be true
that's right um i i wrote that because i
wanted to make clear that this was not
specific to wall street wasn't specific
to the jewish community it wasn't
specific to wealthy people
or people of means
it filtered down
to all levels of america and all over
the globe
what did you learn
i learned first of all i was surprised
to learn that
a lot of people on wall street knew that
madoff was crooked they just didn't know
exactly how as far back as 2001 when i
wrote the original story for barron's
magazine
a lot of people knew that he was
uh doing something doing something that
that wasn't um
wasn't all there and uh but they were
afraid to stick their neck out well the
obvious question and based on this new
ig report in which one of the
conclusions that the sec never properly
examined or investigated the trading and
never took the necessary basic steps to
determine if madoff was operating a
ponzi scheme why
this is a question that i think
we're going to be asking for the ages
this is what
drove harry markopoulos i think
practically to distraction
i think
it's a symptom of
the sec as an agency they hire a lot of
attorneys
they don't hire wall street traders or
you know back office specialists and
it showed when they went to examine
madoff they didn't really even know what
to look for and then when they were
handed the evidence they didn't follow
up
let me ask you about ruth made off
because you're right ruth was a constant
presence she had worked with bernie
since the beginning when he borrowed
office space from her father and decades
later she still kept an office near her
husband in the lipsticks building 19th
floor you went on to say that ruth had a
penchant for secrecy
ruth madoff was a very smart lady and
she was with her husband from the very
beginning they operated out of her
father's
very successful accounting practice to
start
she had a head for numbers
i think of her as sort of a lady macbeth
figure
you know someone sort of as the power
behind the throne however the even the
madoff trustee has said there's not
enough evidence to indict her at least
not yet do you think she knew
uh
i'm on the fence um you know i think she
was
she had a as i said a head for figures
she was the bookkeeper for the
legitimate broker dealer business
and she also had an account with uh
comad which is the in internal marketing
arm so
she definitely knew there was a hedge
fund it's unclear whether she knew it
was a ponzi scheme more from the book
bernie as he was known to as investors
would manage your money and promise
a guaranteed 10 percent even 12 or
higher in an annual return
as long as you didn't ask any questions
that's right uh one of madoff's requests
of his investors
uh was that he basically extracted a
promise uh from you that you wouldn't
tell anyone he was managing your money
um that was very unusual on wall street
especially people like to brag
um so that was a
very distinct red flag
so with all of these red flags it goes
back to the basic question how he was
able to pull this off and for so long
yes um
in the book i talk a little bit with um
a former sec attorney um
who's still in industry
and he said that bernie madoff and his
brother peter madoff
really made themselves available to the
sec in starting in the late 70s
when congress mandated the sec to
deregulate stock trading they wanted to
break the monopoly of the new york stock
exchange
bernie madoff and his brother peter
basically went to the agency and said
we'll show you how to do it your agenda
is ours
and as a result they were very grateful
to him and really revered him
you're right about chris cox the former
chair of the sec in the bush
administration that although the sec had
becoming had
been becoming more bureaucratic and less
aggressive for some time under chairman
chris cox the sec morphed into a weak
defanged shell of itself
why is that
uh i think it came from the top
christopher cox had very little
experience in securities
and i think there was a reason for that
i think under the bush administration
essentially
the white house wanted a weak sec
and they got it
part of the sec's problems you say was
that it did not employ many people who
had been trained in finance or banking
those who knew how wall street ripped
people off instead you say the sec had
an odd tradition of hiring mostly
lawyers many very smart and competent
others just clocking time at the
government agency so they could then go
to work as wall street attorneys that's
right um it's a revolving door
and
sadly um
you know it's it's a way for
young securities lawyers to
get some experience learn how the agency
works learn what it's looking for and
then go work for you know sometimes 10
or
more
times the money on wall street does
bernie madoff have a relationship with
his boys his children
uh
i don't believe so now but you know
everything about the madoff family is um
has to be viewed through the prism of
sort of think of it as like kabuki
theater
uh whereby
um we don't know if his confession was
staged to his sons we don't know
if the sons knew and
they are staying silent and saying they
have no relationship
so i i'm very
skeptical about that we've been reading
a lot about
the madoff homes including the home in
long island but he also had property in
france in palm beach and of course in
new york city where
where what's the status of these
properties uh the house in montauk in
long island is has just gone up for
auction um it's uh
you know not a spectacular mansion um
maybe like you'd see in the hamptons or
um
you know say a mar-a-lago in palm beach
but uh it's ocean front property it's
very valuable
so to me that's the most valuable part i
also visited his
and ruth's house in palm beach it was
the old pulitzer family estate
also you know very very nice but very
subdued
and
he had a an apartment in captain tibbies
in france and
of course the penthouse apartment in
manhattan everything is up for sale
robert is joining us from winston-salem
north carolina good morning good morning
please
miss arvidland
uh steve i'd like to ask uh if we could
suggest a topic for a program and and
see what your thoughts are certainly
and why not truth steve i mean to me
that's where we need to begin
uh i think that when if we deal with
truth
all the other things just simply fall in
place i don't know how you see that
and as far as a politician i think that
i call myself
an eisenhower democrat and
because of the fact that
he'll be the law
and i think that
we've gotten away from obeying the law
we think that because we are such and
such that we can do
as we please
so so with regard to that of the bernie
madoff book how do you want to
characterize it i would like to ask her
mrs arvitan
how much fear
was there
and i'll get off and listen to you guys
how much fear um you mean among the sec
uh are you still there he must have hung
up i would say
in the report that came out earlier this
week the
agency
the inspector general talks a little bit
about
a young examiner who
said he really didn't want to pursue an
investigation one of the many into
madoff because he was a powerful
well-connected person
and i think madoff's position as
one-time chairman of nasdaq
also
maybe prevented uh the sec from pushing
further they just couldn't believe that
he would do something like this ten
years ago harry mcropolis warned the sec
about bernie madoff who is he and why
did they not heed his warnings
so harry markopoulos was a whistleblower
he testified in front of congress
several months ago explaining all the
warnings he had given to the sec
he started out as a business rival to
madoff uh he was he and his boss were
actually looking into the strategy made
of claim to be using and he really was
never trading at all
um anyway markopolis sent
letters to the
new england branch of the sec i think
ultimately that was forwarded to the new
york branch
but for various reasons including turf
wars
and as the ig's report shows and it's
available on the sec's website if anyone
wants to read it
it was again almost like the keystone
cops uh the left hand didn't know what
the right hand was doing in his warnings
which came back in 1999 also the year in
which congress
repealed the depression-era
glass-steagall legislation you wrote
about that in the book saying it kept
commercial depositor banks and
investment banks separate
allowing the resulting supermarket of
financial institutions it was more
profitable for a bank to do business
with hedge funds instead of just
everyday lending against their
depositors accounts right so how did
that
correlate to what madoff was doing well
um
if in fact he'd been running a
legitimate hedge fund um
i think it could have been a very
profitable business
but the fact that he was able to go on
for so long i think was part of the
larger hedge fund mania
which really took off with the bull
market of 19 the 1990s through
i guess the financial crisis in
september 2007. hedge funds have become
a real force on wall street they account
for a huge amount of the trading volume
and
i think madoff was seen as one of these
billion dollar funds among many others
and for that reason
perhaps he wasn't uh as scrutinized as
much
but
under uh the obama administration hedge
funds will have to register if they're
larger than 30 million dollars in assets
at least if the if that part of the bill
passes what motivated bernie madoff
uh i wish i knew
i think
i think he
got a rush out of getting away with it
i think also
you know he liked
giving wealthy people or people of means
what they wanted which was
good returns consistent returns
and as a result
he was able to travel in very elite
circles
loretta is joining us from cleveland
good morning
oh good morning good morning steve good
morning miss erwin thank you
um
i know the question is being asked how
did he get away with this for so long
and i think that this goes
straight
to the fact that
he's white he has privilege
he has prestige
and he's plugged into the good old boy
network
that puts
greed and profits
over obeying the law
and we have seen this
run a muck ever since
bush came into office we have it with
enron we had it with
the communications company i can't think
of the name of it right now
well yeah yeah
you can look straight down the line and
you can see
all of these people
that made
gazillion of dollars and they're not
being
looked at to see whether they obeyed the
law in order to make those profits
which was one of the conclusions from
the inspector general that's right
i wish i could just disagree with laura
but i i think she's exactly right
you know the question is
whether more regulation is required or
not
sometimes i'm on the fence about it i
think
more regulation can hurt the small
advisor and
um i think if the rules had been
enforced and in fact the sec had done
its job in the first place in fact in
this report the inspector general says
the sec could have caught made off in
1992
so i think the rules were in place they
just weren't being followed our guest is
aaron arville and the book is called too
good to be true the rise and fall of
bernie madoff and your first
piece on bernie madoff came eight years
ago correct right it was a story for
barron's magazine uh was written in 2001
i got a tip from a very good source of
mine
his name is ken nakayama he was then
working at deutsche bank
and uh he pointed me to one of these
feeder funds or you know fund of hedge
funds they're sometimes called
which it turned out was the underlying
portfolio was being run by bernie madoff
have you ever met bernie madoff no i
interviewed him on the phone
and um
i only spoke with him for about 10
minutes
do you remember the conversation i do
i actually had uh been working on the
story for a while and i was trying to
gin up as much information as i could
about him
people were very reluctant to talk on
the record
in part because they were worried about
getting kicked out of madoff's you know
supposed hedge fund
uh finally
um about a day or two before the baron
story was supposed to run
i told them i spoke to someone at his
firm and i explained that it was going
to run regardless and then suddenly he
was made available
he was apparently overseas he said he
was in switzerland
maybe on a boat so but he really didn't
tell me much he just said it's a
proprietary strategy i can't go into it
our next call is michael from asheville
north carolina good morning
hey good morning
mike here i was curious when this whole
thing broke last year about where were
the regulators and then
the next question was for the regulators
of the regulators uh where was the
senate finance committee under both
democrats and republicans and likewise
the
house
financial services committee under
democrats and republicans and
i happen to be one of those small
advisors
and it seems like every time something
like this happens i get five more pieces
of paper
to fill out for the poor guy that wants
to put 50 bucks down a month on his kids
529 plan i'll ring off and
take
my answer on the line
um i
i sympathize
i think in
in most cases the sec
prefers to go after the little guy
because it's easier
i mean clearly in the report even i
think one of the examiners says
he he or she didn't want to
go through the madoff trading records
because it would take a ton of time
well that's that's the nature of these
exams
and i think
as a result i really hope that the small
advisors
don't suffer because
you know they're not the ones who pulled
off the billion dollar ponzi scheme our
guest is written for the new york times
barons moscow times and dow jones
newswire she's a graduate of tufts
university a comment from one viewer who
says what motivated madoff is the same
thing that motivated his investors greed
no
i i would agree
for those people who knew that they were
investing with madoff
there were many there were many people
who put their money directly in with
madoff and
perhaps in their heart of hearts
knew that
the returns were far too consistent and
he couldn't lose money that that's again
too good to be true which is why we
picked the name for the book
but then there were also many people who
came in indirectly
you know through feeder funds or
through a retirement plan
these people had no clue that madoff was
the portfolio manager so in their case
um
i don't think we can blame greed i just
think that uh there was
very little disclosure
and he contends in his uh
not testimony but when he uh pled guilty
that the money went to a bank he'd never
invested any of it is that you've heard
as well that's correct um the money
been off had a bank account at jpmorgan
chase
it was essentially a cash in cash out
operation
investors would send him a check
and he would
pay out of redemption from this account
he never made any trades and this is why
um
it was so astonishing i guess as he even
made off said that he was never caught
it would have been very easy to go check
with
uh nasdaq or uh with the depository and
trust corporation but no one from the
sec did you write that madoff's london
office also played a large role in
helping to hide his fraud london may
have started out legitimate but over the
decades it morphed into a financial
outpost for the madoff family a place
where they felt comfortable stashing
what they considered their personal
fortune roughly 113 million pounds by
the year 2008 which is about 220 million
in u.s dollars that's correct um
london was
an office that madoff opened in the mid
80s
and it did start out as a place where he
and his legitimate broker-dealer could
trade stocks overnight
back in the 80s even it wasn't that
common uh to trade you know as we do 24
hours a day um
so
anyway uh by
mid-2000s um probably 2007 and 2008
the madoffs were starting to wire
money back and forth to
make it look as if there were trades
they were also paying for yachts
peter madoff brought an aston martin
through london
so it was really just sort of a family
bank account tom from gross island
michigan with aaron arvidlen good
morning you're on the air hi hi good
morning steve uh you found your niche in
life first of all you're excellent at
what you do hi aaron hi good morning
uh there's a couple of things that
that i i wonder if they're loosely
connected and that would be the
disappearance here in detroit of detroit
national bank of detroit a very
conservative
well-run bank taking over in the 90s
after this i believe regarding this
deregulation
uh taken over by this uh
wildcatters kind of from uh columbus
ohio which i really despised who took
them over uh they were taken over by the
the bunch
they were called bank one
and uh they they failed because they uh
were here to peddle credit cards but
then we have the collapse of long-term
capital management in 99 which they said
if they didn't bail them out the world
economy would collapse and i i sat there
slack jawed on on comprehending what
they were talking about and then we have
things like the society general in
france the stealing of seven billion
dollars
and the ubs uh moving fifty thousand was
it the clients offshore
and is this all connected in some
general way uh could you comment in any
way on that sure um
i can't speak to uh bank one i can say
that the long-term capital management uh
set a precedent in terms of bailouts of
wall street
um
i mean i think ltcm uh that bailout made
the bailout of aig and you know some of
the other firms that we've seen more
palatable at least
i think it's a scandal nevertheless but
uh in terms of um
ubs i can't say for certain whether
there's a connection but i do believe
that it's become harder and harder for
investors to hide money offshore and i
think the
the ubs accounts
are going to
really again set a precedent
for u.s investors in hedge funds or in
offshore accounts
you wrote about this being
it's been written as a 65 billion dollar
ponzi scheme you say that that basically
was 65 billion dollars on paper there
never was 65 billion that's correct can
you elaborate
so
working backwards from 65 billion um
let's assume for argument's sake that
madoff was
claiming 10 gains a year
and
phantom gains as we now know false
profits
i believe that the ponzi began from the
very beginning
perhaps in a smaller scale but beginning
being one year meaning in the 1960s
so if we assume that
he was reporting an average of 10 a year
gains over a period of 30 or 40 years
then
the actual dollar amount if you take
away all the the profits is somewhere
between 12 and 20 billion
that's the actual dollars that went in
now where'd all the money go um
roughly half of the 12 to 20
probably came from these fund of hedge
funds
and those are the billion dollar funds
that we've been reading about that are
being sued either by federal prosecutors
or the madoff trustee to
give the money back
so that brings us to
say six to 10 billion that's still still
missing
there are a number of individual
investors among them stanley chase and
jeffrey pickauer who have
also been
sued by the madoff trustee for allegedly
taking out more than they put in
these are the people who
the trustee alleges were the big
beneficiaries and they probably account
for between one and five
so um there's a very good possibility
that there's some money offshore
i think that's that's what the madoff
trustee is going to be looking for next
our guest is aaron arvindland the book
is too good to be true the rise and fall
of bernie madoff and jim is joining us
from new york city good morning jim yes
good morning uh i'm gonna make a
statement first and then ask a question
a friend of mine had his money invested
in madoff and he showed me his
statements
and after looking at the statements the
first thing that stood out in my mind
was the auditor
nobody but anyone ever heard of this
auditor before that's the thing that
surprised me the most about it uh a way
one way i think he got away with getting
these people in there's an old uh old
jewish statement i've live in a city for
forty years and i'm jewish it used to be
an old thing like i can get it for your
wholesale
and a lot of people
he used that trick uh you know uh i got
my friend bernie he's doing a wonderful
job for me let me call bernie of his
people and get you in the fun and that's
how he got a lot of these people it
wasn't and and one other
my question is this well hey before you
ask your question without um
revealing any of the secrets with your
friend how much money did he lose and
what has he said since the confession
and now his imprisonment um he's not
happy about it but luckily for him he
wasn't totally invested in the man he
had he's not going to lose his house
he's not going to lose a lot of things
but he's going to lose uh
he's going to lose a few million i think
that's my guess at it i mean i didn't go
that far into him i looked at the
statements sure but that the thing that
stood out in my mind i said this who's
just ordered i've never heard this
you're going to ask a question so go
ahead
my question to you is um
i don't like hedge funds and i think a
lot of them are just basically
manipulators of stock but it's my
understanding mr donaldson wanted to try
to regulate them years ago but it was
the statement is and answering this
question they said there's a federal law
that would not allow the securities and
exchange commission to regulate them
there's a law out there uh there's a
bill under consideration as part of this
larger financial reform package that
president obama would like to push
through
and under that
hedge funds
or
advisors of 30 million or more would be
required to register with the sec
how then they would be that would be
enforced is still i think to be to be
decided because both the sec and finra
would like um
their their their own purview over hedge
funds so
this could set us up for another turf
battle between agencies um so
anyway uh but yes they they should be if
this bill passes they could very well be
regulated by the way if you're
interested in reading the full report
from the inspector general it's
available online at cspan.org and an
email from a viewer who says seems like
the corruption runs into the governing
agency how cozy is the relationship
between the sec and the traders
such a good question um
there were reports for instance that
some of the young examiners
who went to madoff's offices over you
know this period of it looks like
15 or 16 years
would leave their resumes on the way out
currently the relationship between the
sec and wall street is incredibly cozy
in part because wall street recruits
from the agency
there's no rule you know say a statute
of limitations on working at the agency
that prevents you from going to straight
to wall street
um
it's it's a problem with this other
email from a viewer in salt lake city
utah saying can the author tell me why
the obama administration has not hired
mr markopoulos in some capacity i heard
him testify on c-span very impressed and
sickened by the inaction of the
securities and exchange commission
yes that was uh that was riveting um
actually i believe one of the
congressmen offered the job of chief
whistleblower to mr markopoulos and as
far as i know he hasn't accepted um he
in his in his own words has said he
likes chasing bad guys he's a certified
fraud examiner which essentially means
that he
will go after frauds against the us
government
and
i think reaps some sort of
compensation for that
chairman shapiro mary shapiro has talked
about
setting up a similar program with the
sec and i think that that's one of the
reforms under consideration by the way
if you're navigating on our website and
looking for that inspector general
report you'll find it under featured
links and we'll keep it there if you
want to read specific details the story
this morning front page in the
washington post inside the business
section
their report in the failings of the sec
and the bernie madoff investigation
gerald is joining us from tucson arizona
good morning republican line good
morning uh in my three score years in
six i've seen multiple scandals such as
this
and the inspector general report talks
about incompetence and they talk about
pure laziness
uh also in my three score years and six
i've seen almost no one held accountable
is there going to be any accountability
for these so-called and i put that in
quote civil servants who
really
created havoc in these investors lives
i'll hang up and listen to the answer
thank you thank you just to augment what
gerald was saying the story this morning
the business section of the new york
times how the sec
missed many red flags in their
investigation so to his point will
anyone be held accountable uh
i haven't heard of any
for instance any sec lawyers or
examiners for instance
going to jail
i also
would love to know whether the sec still
has sovereign immunity i believe they do
actually
although there are some made of
investors who are actually suing finra
which is the
successor agency to the nasd
and i wonder also if any of them might
go after you know some of the previous
uh
chairman of the sec
our next call is gene from los angeles
good morning welcome to the program
democrats line uh good morning um
i get nervous so i'm gonna plug through
this really quickly well don't don't be
nervous we're glad to hear from you and
the forum is yours so go ahead with your
comment question um first of all you're
all heroes at c-span um second of all
um there's a if you go to google and you
put in madoff double bluff there's a
very interesting article um he um
talks about
uh the legitimacy of people who invested
in the fund we'll try to pull it up what
is it what's the google search and we'll
pull it up right now uh yes uh madoff
double bluff
double bluff okay okay but now the other
thing that i think is important is
and these are questions maybe they were
uh looked into
um
the
i understand there's going to be tax
write-offs for the investors that will
allow them to write off three years back
in 20 years forward
that those will be based on pre-economic
collapse dollars i recognize that some
of the
funds or the money was phantom
and then also
there is insurance for many of the
people
lloyd's london etc and then i understand
there's also an sec fund
and i'm wondering
what you've looked into in that regard
and also one other issue was um
i think in that article he talks about a
lot of people who invested in the fund
knowing that it was
uh not on the up and up felt
that the government would come in and
take over
or would um compensate people in that
the sec was ultimately responsible
we'll get a response that wasn't so bad
was it no need to be nervous
i'm gonna phone in again okay all right
thank you thank you
so to answer gene's uh your last
question gene um there is a cipic fund a
securities investor protection
uh corporation their their uh
maximum i believe per investor is 500
thousand dollars currently the madoff
trustee is administering um
the number of claims coming in
and i think that numbers so far about
roughly one and a half to two billion
um
he hasn't paid out at as much
i believe if you look um on the madoff
trustee website you can see that he's
set up sort of an informal uh deadline
running through the end of this year
which explains
how many claims he expects to pay out
and as far as
long-term capital again i think that set
the precedent for expectations that
hedge fund investors would get bailed
out dan is one of the regulars who
tweets us here on c-span he says yes all
i see is wall street making big money
the only number is we should see from
them their prison number
you write in the book in the year
leading up to madoff's confession
investors started to panic and withdrew
12 billion dollars out of the accounts
at the firm about 6 billion was taken
out just three months before the
financier was arrested back in december
and then you say had the stock market in
the u.s not collapsed made off and his
scam probably would have continued right
uh the stock market collapse is what
really unraveled madoff um everybody
came to uh bernie madoff at the same
time because he was the only one
supposedly not losing money um
i don't know if your 401k is
anything like it was two or three years
ago but uh
you know if you're losing an investment
elsewhere you're going to go
to where you can always get your cash
out but it just wasn't there i think
some are now calling them 201s we'll go
to sean in vancouver washington good
morning you're on the air good morning
miss arvalon a front-running
front-running front running the reason
markopolis was ignored was that there is
the gentleman's agreement on wall street
that the market makers and specialists
all front run the tape everyone was
willing to look the other way with
bernie because everyone else was in on
it in 2004 the sec had reached a
settlement with the specialists and they
had to pay something like 200 million
dollars which was nothing compared to
what they've been stealing from the
american people all these years bernie
madoff started off as a market maker and
even the market makers on the nasdaq got
busted in the 1990s and still they were
able to settle and
these people
these wall street pigs
are intellectual and ethical bankruptcy
your worst suspicions about these people
don't come close to the criminality and
and
psychotic nature of these people
front running it's all front running the
tape could you address that thanks sure
um this is the initial suspicion uh that
madoff was front-running his clients um
that was part of the reason why
a lot of hedge funds wouldn't do
business with him because they thought
he was front running is when a broker
steps in front of his customer his or
her customers orders
and
so that was my suspicion
back in
2001
the inspector general's report as
outlined by uh you know a couple of
different papers today
uh showed that that's what the sec was
looking for but they never addressed
harry markopoulos's claim that madoff
was running a ponzi scheme in fact they
didn't even know about the entire floor
in his business
that was you know the supposed hedge
fund
another uh tweet where is bernie madoff
being held he's down in prison in butner
north carolina
and he's currently serving 150 year
sentence from the washington post the
inspector general's report concludes
that the agency's failings were a result
of misjudgment not improprieties
uh that's putting it kindly um
i i have no particular beef with the sec
um
i know they try and do their jobs just
like everyone else but um
it's it's embarrassing when you read
this inspector general's report and this
is only the executive summary the full
450 page uh report from the inspector
general hasn't come out yet i'm i can't
wait to read it
uh so
yes harry markopoulos said the same
thing he testified in front of congress
and said
you know the sec is incompetent um maybe
not corrupt but definitely incompetent
our guest is aaron arvidlen our next
call is michelle from tallahassee good
morning
good morning
uh i've had a couple of questions one is
the
sec
implemented and what congress and
administration actually
assisted with setting up the sec
and uh if a ponzi scheme correct me if
i'm wrong is basically you know were you
collecting
money and you don't really have any
dividends because you're not making any
money but you take future investments
and that's kind of how you pay your
dividends off if that's correct then
that would be and he started in the 60s
and that would be about the same time
that social security was taken off of
being locked down and so therefore
social security would be the largest
ponzi scheme of them all well first on
the creation of the sec in the 1930s
sure um
my understanding was that it was
set up to correct some of the abuses of
the great crash of 1929
and um
among others uh ferdinand pacora us had
a commission that helped to um
uh question some of the big wall street
bankers and
he was one of the ones i quote in the
book
talking about how to correct some of the
abuses on wall street
as for your second question i've i've
read this in many other places comparing
madoff's ponzi scheme to that of social
security
so
ponzi schemes are are pretty basic it's
just a pyramid scheme
whereby
early investors put their money in and
their money is used to pay later
investors and
uh money always has to keep coming in um
in order to pay people off and uh and
where does the name ponzi come ponzi
comes from charles ponzi
he set up one of these original scams in
america anyway um in the 1920s but his
was using um postage stamps so um
how did that work i i believe he was
selling postage stamps
overseas and he said that he could make
50 or 100 percent investment in 30 days
so
again if the returns were just too good
to be true in madoff's case the returns
were
maybe upwards of 10 a year
but um he never lost money and that was
just impossible which is the title of
the book too good to be true our guest
is the author and tommy from nashville
is next good morning
good morning steve good morning uh
america and thanks for c-span uh you
might want to get your pencil uh i've
got a couple of good points here okay
can we take one at a time
okay one at a time is um the uh
deregulation of the markets
and and uh what mccain and uh bill
graham
and the repelling of glass-steagall you
just mentioned the clash of 29 how much
that was apart and that law that the
fellow caller called before that was a
2000 law passed and it was
where where it was
against allowed to even look at these
hedge funds okay let's take that point
we'll come up with the follow-up sure um
i know what he's referring to um
actually i think it was the uh capital
markets modernization act of 2000 but
i'd have to double check it but uh the
point was that um there was a there was
a period um
during the
dot-com boom and um i guess subsequent
in the bust um where
congress tried to legislate
derivatives
and also
there was a push under
chairman donaldson which one of the
earlier callers mentioned to regulate
hedge funds
it never went anywhere
and i think once the market recovered in
2002 and 2003 when people are making
money they're less apt to ask questions
and ask for regulation and i think all
of that has come home to roost tommy
follow up all right my follow-up is uh
during the deregulation time also
to the best of my knowledge in
absorption absorption of the facts is
the defunding of the scc also
and the changing of the uptick rule
right that's true
i think the the sec has finally um made
a ruling on on the uh the uptick they
reinstated it as i unders as i
understand
but uh
you know look there are always calls for
um
federal agencies to get more money and
more staff and uh better training and i
think in the sec's case
they really deserve it however um
you know again if you read this
inspector general report it seems as if
they if they had just done what they
were supposed to do
uh madoff might have been caught a lot
earlier who is eric swanson
eric swanson was
an attorney with the sec
he was
involved in one of the exam early
examinations i believe it was in the
2004-2005 period
he ultimately became romantically
involved with bernie madoff's niece
shauna madoff and they got married in
2007.
he
there were some questions about whether
or not he influenced the sec
to not look so closely this actually
clears his name
so
anyway that's that's who eric swanson is
libby joining us from the cape edgarton
massachusetts good morning good morning
i apologize i have terrible call but
i've been fascinated listening to this
um i do know families here in
new england that were wiped out
um by madoff are a good part of their
equity was wiped out
the questions that i have
are
in terms of the sec
i think it's grossly unfair
to try to put the blame on the federal
employees the blame belongs on every one
of the political appointees that were
put in
and i know this for a fact because i
came out of a mess called bayou
investment
chris cox when he was put in there the
former congressman from california was
told by the administration the burch
cheney administration not to do any type
of investigative work
i happen to know career employees who
are married to friends of mine from
childhood who said that basically all
they could do was um
do busy work
for the last eight years and then prior
to that when the republicans had control
of the congress and that's why harry um
what is his name
who is absolutely the white knight that
wrote in was dismissed he was considered
a quack he was considered a goof ball
and every added a basic nuisance to the
sec right now and you know something
this is all of a part
bernie made up is a thief he is a ghana
in in yiddish
and to tell
for anybody to say that his wife and his
kids his brother-in-law knew nothing is
absolutely beyond belief libby will stop
you on that point appreciate the call
i'll just uh say to libby that um yeah i
think the mayor harry makapala said it
right he said the sec um especially the
lower level employees were discouraged
from making big cases we've been
watching this video and it's been on
youtube as he was making his way to
court for his initial court appearance
where he pled guilty and then
subsequently appeared for his uh
sentencing
what kind of a person was bernie madoff
and what social network did he have in
new york yeah
bernie madoff and his wife came from
pretty humble roots they came from a
middle class neighborhood in queens
laurelton
went to public schools and
public universities
but i would say by the 1980s as a result
of his legitimate business
madoff was making millions of dollars a
year he had a very successful trading
operation again his legitimate business
and was meanwhile running this um
phony hedge fund on the side
uh this really vaulted uh the madoffs
into
high society particularly in new york in
palm beach
and
in london um but you know madoff was a
very private person he kept people at
bay in part um to cultivate that uh
velvet rope as it were um the idea that
he was a vip and that was really part of
the marketing of his hedge fund this
tweet from raul mccartney saying besides
bernie who actually made money off of
his business who were the big players
sure
um i mentioned two earlier um the maid
electricity is alleging that
one by the name of jeffrey pickauer took
out roughly that he believes five
billion dollars over the years
so that would have been much more very
likely than he put in and the way that
he was able to do that allegedly was
that madoff would just write down on
paper
a made-up gain or loss so for instance
i believe pick our received or perhaps
it was stanley chase who raised a lot of
money in hollywood for madoff
received upwards of 900 percent one year
so
once um
once these investors were able to reap
these kinds of gains and oftentimes
order up losses
so that they didn't have to pay taxes
our next call is from surprise arizona
ronnie sue is on the phone good morning
hi good morning uh good morning erin how
are you hi ronnie sue
um i have a question in light of the sec
report that came out yesterday
which obviously
puts a lot of doubt
in a lot of victims minds and i am a
madoff victim
it made us
realize that maybe we need to look into
other
regulatory agencies that should have
some responsibility
and as such we contacted finra a few
weeks ago and asked them for
an accounting of their
investments to date we haven't heard
anything um
just
this past week we found out that there's
another
a complaint issued against finra by
merivet securities
and in that complaint they mentioned
that they believed that
the investment portfolio of
uh finra was invested with bernard
madoff that's correct caller can i go
back to something earlier that you said
that you were a victim as well
yes i am how so
um i invested with bernie madoff for
probably more than half my life about 30
years
and lost everything that i have and i'm
actually involved with a group of other
victims bernardmade or victims.org
is a website where victims we have 400
victims that have come together
to try to find justice and restitution
and why did you invest with him
i invested with him because he was rock
solid he was known to be
a pillar of wall street and
i i had seen other people that had
invested with him and were successfully
withdrawing money it wasn't a black hole
that the money went into
and um we researched him we did our
homework
and there was absolutely nothing wrong
with this man
let me read an excerpt from aaron
arvalen's book and get your reaction she
wrote that it was this high level of
trust that led smart and savvy people
especially in the jewish community to
invest with madoff over the ensuing
years without asking serious questions
and they were not driven by greed but
rather by the desire to invest in their
futures with someone they felt they
could trust do you agree with that
well it was trust but it was trust
instilled by the sec
so it wasn't um
you know i think it crosses all
boundaries of ethnicity and age and
demographics um
when
the very agency that's put in place to
tell us that our investments are safe
does so
you know that crosses all boundaries
yeah and how much did you lose if i may
ask
um you know i used to say that i've been
pretty visible um in the media and i
used to say that and and i think at this
point i i've changed my my ammo and i
think just to say that i lost every
penny that i've ever had
um
every
asset that i had went in tomato if we
sold a house about four years ago and
all that money went into madoff so
when you lose ten thousand dollars and
that's everything you have or whether
you lose 10 million and that's
everything you have and you're left with
zero it doesn't matter where you started
from
ronnie sue thank you for the call from
arizona um i'd like to uh you know make
a comment about
the suit that ronnie sue mentioned
it was filed i believe a few weeks ago
and it's
the suit is alleging that finra which
was the successor to the nasd
has they have their own investment
portfolio and that at some point in the
past i don't know exactly when
but that the agency finra may have
actually had investment money with
madoff
so it's something that's going to be
coming out in the courts we're going to
george next from personalville virginia
good morning you're on the air with
aaron arvalen
okay thank you very much um
great sounding great book question about
chris cox how long was he there and
didn't he have heart surgery so he
really wasn't on the job for part of the
time i don't know and the other one is
when arthur levitt was there he tried to
make changes
and congress republicans and democrats
both shot him down
this is true
i don't know exactly how many years cox
was at the agency but
he he really was considered a very
laissez faire
uh chairman of the sec
and as far as arthur levitt um
you know he actually his his career
dated back to um bernie's career they
were they were contemporaries um and
they knew of each other and i believe
arthur levitz even said you know he was
shocked to find out that bernie madoff
had done this
um it's uh i mean it's it's the fact
that until mary shapiro has come into
office
really no sec chairman has had a has had
a mandate um to make serious changes and
i really hope that she's able to do that
mary is joining us from houston good
morning welcome to the program
thank you speak c-span i would like to
comment on this
question how did the regulators miss
this
i'm an administrative lawyer
in a privately owned
heavily regulated industry here in
houston
and i see a mega trend
of the
regulators really regulating heavily the
good citizens
and doing inspections and reports and
lots of make work
for people who have no complaints
yet in our own industry
we have some real bad actors
and they never closed in on them
uh they beat up good citizens
all day every day for
minor paper infractions
but they're not doing the real job so
i don't think this is a surprise
i think when you start regulating
everybody
then you're gonna you're gonna miss
the main task which is to go after the
bad actors
uh this is this is another um a vote for
a whistleblower program especially one
that compensates the whistleblowers
particularly on wall street
i
totally agree with you and
you know more regulation is not going to
help
the small advisors
and the people who are doing their jobs
correctly and honestly
from the financial times
again a quote from the headline this
morning from the inspector general's
report that officials approached mr
madoff in some of his
financial dealings and the staff the sec
staff accepted his seemingly impossible
explanations at face value was there no
follow-up
no
there was none i mean i i was reading
this uh inspector general's report which
um as you mentioned is is on c-span's
website
um they themselves say
it's it's shocking um how the uh the
examiners had the time and they had the
capability of doing the follow-up and
they just didn't do it
our next call is david from crofton
maryland good morning
yes good morning i was wondering if
you're aware of any connection between
elliot spitzer being targeted by the sec
and the fbi
because he was investigating madoff and
other people on wall street
he was actually investigating the mutual
fund industry and in fact in this report
the sec
inspector general mentions how every i
believe roughly in 2003 2004
most many of the agencies staff was
asked to turn their attention to mutual
funds i think that was in response to
spitzer's investigation
and
spitzer also raised a lot of money from
hedge funds
he pretty much left them alone
left most of hedge funds on wall street
alone and i think that was
in part because he chose to go after the
mutual fund timing scandal one final
point from the book you say that the
madoff scandal was the product of
several bubbles the bubble in hedge
funds in housing prices in credit cards
in americans living beyond their means
uh you know
the hedge fund industry was
probably i would say
50 funds sometime starting in the 1980s
and
perhaps 500 million dollars
by
2007 i believe that number was 2
trillion dollars in assets it's still
nowhere near the mutual fund industry
but it's certainly growing
since the market collapsed hedge funds
now run about 1.4 trillion i think is
the is the number um maybe 15 to 20
percent of them have closed um it's
still an enormous industry and i think
uh hedge funds are where mutual funds
were say 20 or 25 years ago they're
going to be with us so after researching
bernie madoff and looking into this
case what are the lessons
uh
check who has custody of your assets um
go back to your portfolio manager and
ask um
you know who's who's touching my money
who has control over
the decisions
are there you know independent third
parties
making sure that no one can use make
transactions on my behalf
madoff had custody of all his investors
money and that's very unusual
the book is called too good to be true
the rise and fall of bernie madoff our
guest aaron arvindland the author thanks
very much for joining us thank you steve
please come back again i will
coming up in just a moment live at the
burkins institution vice president biden
uh asking for the ability to speak to
brookings about the stimulus spending he
will be introduced by strobe talbot uh
formerly with the clinton administration
the topic of the speech is reinventing
the reinvestment act and its impact on
the u.s economy the vice president will
be starting momentarily again a reminder
that if you want to read more from the
inspector general report you can log on
to our website at cspan.org and click
under featured links and you can read
the entire report and the interview that
we just conducted with aaron arvalen
will also be available online at
cspan.org we're back tomorrow morning
for c-span's washington journal i'm on
our programming tomorrow a preview of
the supreme court oral arguments that
will take place next wednesday looking
at a movie uh focusing on hillary
clinton and its impact on the 2008
campaign an early start for the u.s
supreme court they will begin the formal
term in
the first monday of october and one
other reminder that our new documentary
on the supreme court will premiere the
first sunday of october here on c-span
thanks for being with us on this
thursday morning enjoy the rest century
she's an economics professor at the
university of maryland for more
information visit umd.edu
brian ross is the head of the
investigative unit for abc news mr ross
in the madoff chronicles what's new in
here there's a lot new here about the
relationship between bernie and ruth
what drove him to do it when it started
and his total lack of remorse we also
take a close look at who else was likely
involved he didn't do this alone despite
his claims that he did
did mrs madoff have a role she
definitely had a role she kept the books
when they started in the early 1960s at
a folding card table in the apartment
she was still keeping the books
at the day he was arrested
if she didn't know directly she
certainly was along for the ride i liken
them to like bonnie and clyde you know
maybe bonnie didn't fire any guns but he
certainly was part of the scheme
do you see that this story will continue
with more trials etc there are more
people and sort of the layers of the
onion are being unpeeled
one of the
significant questions i think though is
the failure of the federal government
here
they sec investigators were after madoff
again and again from 92 on they always
missed it why was that their defenses
they were inexperienced and incompetent
but i don't know that really the
satisfying answer
well as head of the investigative unit
for abc when's the first time you heard
of bernie madoff
the night he was arrested i was sitting
in the lanes in new york next to my
colleague and we just finished reporting
on rod magoyovitz the governor of
illinois in his travails and my friend
got an email from the fbi saying bernard
made off arrested 50 billion dollar scam
i said i don't know who madoff is but
that's a typo it can't be 50 billion
because that'd be the biggest in history
well
i soon found out what kind of resources
did you and your unit turn over to uh
this investigation well we had the
entire abc news investigative unit uh
immediately launched into action much of
it for broadcast but there were so many
great details and facts that just could
not fit into the world news or nightline
2020 so we ended up doing uh this books
the first book i've written
it is your first book first book i'm a
rookie at this and but i enjoyed it it
usually used to the concision of a
minute and a half or on a good day a
minute 45 and here i had as much as i
wanted
so how did you fit writing this book
into your workday
uh 4 30 in the morning it was a good
time to write and they gave me a few
days off over the july 4th weekend so
right after the sentencing at the end of
june i really swung into action i i was
in pretty good shape to to get it out
this quickly
did you have a chance to talk to any of
the madoffs or anybody close to him well
i got to be very very close with mados
secretary for 25 years eleanor scrollari
and she brought out a stack of documents
that she took out of the office she felt
so betrayed and angry it made off and
felt so badly for the victims who were
her friends she's the one who answered
the phone for bernie and when they
called and
say it's not true eleanor she was in
tears when she came to see me she wanted
to do anything to help bring this man
down and so that's how we got the little
black book which is published in our
book and lots of telling details she
gave copies of the fbi and copies to me
it's the madoff chronicles includes
bernie's little black book you can see
up there in the right hand corner and
it's published by hyperion the author
brian ross
a former supreme court clerk argues that
historically the court's major decisions
have reflected the views of the most
powerful people in communist
czechoslovakia part of a weekend filled
with non-fiction books on c-span 2. for
the complete schedule go to booktv.org
too good to be true is the name of the
book by aaron arvidlen the rise and fall
of bernie madoff
miss arvidlen what's too good to be true
well everything about madoff was too
good to be true uh the returns
the consistency of the returns and the
fact that uh nobody seemed to be knowing
and seemed to know how he was investing
the money so all in all it turned out
that if it really is too good to be true
then you should just stay away
why did you get why did you write about
bernie madoff was there a fascination
uh you know i wrote a story for barron's
magazine back in 2001 um questioning his
returns and asking you know how he
managed to run this billion dollar hedge
fund that no one had ever heard of
before
the story ran
nothing happened um seven years went by
and then last december of 08 he was
arrested and so i was approached by
penguin to write a book
when you were writing in 2001
why
hedge funds were on the rise
uh i wanted to write about someone who
was really under the radar so to speak
i knew that hedge funds were going to be
a big deal as you know we see today
they're everywhere
and they're here to stay
and they're probably going to be
regulated by congress pretty soon
back then
bernie madoff was really unknown on main
street and he never lost money and i
just wanted to know how he did it and
that was why i wrote the original story
where does your book end
well it's still ongoing because
on friday in fact two of madoff's
computer programmers were charged
with conspiracy and helping perpetuate
this whole fraud um
really it's gonna it's gonna keep going
probably for another couple of years
because they need to figure out who else
was involved because certainly madoff
did not do it alone
a follow-up book
um writing a paper bag that will be out
in the spring
aaron arvidland too good to be true the
rise and fall of bernie madoff
from the texas book festival in austin
last year's dodd-frank act granted new
regulatory authority to the securities
and exchange commission the needs to
reorganize to handle its new
responsibilities
the hearing also looked into the sec's
handling of the bernie madoff investor
fraud handling of the bernie madoff
investor fraud case
senator jack reed chairs the senate
banking subcommittee on securities
insurance and investment
this is two hours
[Music]
let me call a hearing to order
i want to thank my ranking members
senator crape want to thank the
witnesses for
taking time out of their very hectic and
demanding and important schedules to be
with us this morning our hearing is
entitled management and structure
reforms at the sec of progress report
this is a very
critical
hearing because of
hearing because we understand the
important role that the sec plays
in the regulations of our securities
markets we have had
vocal concerns about
regulation over regulation we
butt regulation we
but it appears indeed that revenues in
the securities industries for each of
the last two years have been greater
than any
year
the industry is in fact
[Music]
growing at a time when many other
sectors of the american economy are in
very other sectors of the american
economy are in very serious distress
and i
believe that those who want to starve
the market watchdogs or days when toxic
financial products were secretly
negotiated and traded
profiting wall street bankers and
leaving taxpayers on the hook to clean
up the mess later
congress acted to stabilize the market
with the dodd-frank wall street reform
and consumer protection act to bring
transparency and certainty into the
marketplace
there is no question into the
marketplace
there is no question that slowing down
the regulations and those who enforce
the regulations will benefit
those and walls to the rest of us i
think that's the lesson of 2008 and nine
and
in continuing the securities exchange
commission has a daunting job is charged
with protecting investors ensuring that
our securities markets are operating in
a fair and orderly manner this is no
small task given the growing volume and
complexity of both markets and products
for example as at the end of october the
total market value of the united states
equity market was estimated at 13.1
trillion dollars submitted at 13.1
trillion dollars approximately 45 of all
u.s households on 92 million investors
make investments in the market
principally through mutual funds
so this is a of interest to every
american not just those who are in the
financial markets there's little doubt
that changes in both technology and
trading practices are affecting
exchanges training venues are
increasingly fragmented with no single
exchange holding more than one-fifth of
the market share
more trading is being done off exchanges
in so-called dock pools or by broker
dealers executing trades internally
over the past
year and a half this type of trading has
increased by more than 30 percent
presenting
new and challenging problems to
regulators
finally heifers in a blink of an eye
although such trades may contribute a
market volume in good times they also
may contribute to shrinking liquidity in
times of market stress
liquidity in times of market stress
while the securities markets have
exploded with novel products and
increasingly fast technologies
many argue that the sec has revealed
troubling failures weaknesses and gaps
in regulation the scc has had
responsibility for the oversight of
investment banks the financial crisis of
investment banks the financial crisis
revealed the sec failed to appreciate
the growing risks failed to ask the
right questions and failed to take the
right steps
this is the same patent we saw in the
madoff ponzi scheme case the agency
failed to stop bernard madoff's
long-running investment fraud despite
repeated warnings it failed to ask the
right questions and fail to take the
right steps
in addition the agency's inspector
general has identified serious missteps
on how the agency has handled
information how it can
others have criticized the agency for
inhibiting capital formation decreasing
u.s competitiveness and taking a light
touch against law breakers
but my sense is that the scp sec appears
to be committed to reform chairman mayor
shapiro has installed new leadership
across the sec's divisions and offices
beginning in 2009 the sec began
restructuring its largest operating
units the division of enforcement and
office of compliance inspections and
examinations the commission
has also created the division of risk
strategy and innovation to more closely
examine new products trading practices
and risks examine new products trading
practices and risk
congress has tried to focus on improving
the sec as well in the dodd-frank wall
street reform and consumer protection
act it was mandated the sec engaged an
independent consultant to examine its
internal operations structure and need
for reform this report identifying
re-prioritizing regulatory activities
reshaping the agency to maximize
efficiency
and effectiveness investing to improve
infrastructure and investing to improve
infrastructure and improving engagement
with self-regulatory organizations the
report also notes that considerable
additional responsibilities and a gap in
funding that cannot be overcome by
improving efficiency
congress must fully fund the sec our
market watchdog if it is to effectively
discharge the mandate to police the
markets and protect investors
the sec has been
valid validly criticized for failures
and its missions in the past today's
hearing will focus on how the sec's
management has responded to this
criticism and a need for reform the
securities markets need to for reform
the securities markets need to work so
that investors and companies can come
together and allocate capital
efficiently and productively allowing
new products new technologies and new
jobs to be created and they need to work
for americans to save for college a new
home or retirement what is being done
and what needs to be done protecting
investors maintain fair orderly and
efficient markets and facilitate capital
formation
and to reinvigorate its staff is that
the free invigorated staff is at the
forefront of our hearing today
our witnesses this morning are the
senior most management of all the sec
division it is critical that congress
understand what is being done to move
this agency forward and ensure that the
missteps of the past are not repeated
with that i would now like to recognize
my ranking member for his opening
comments senator grebel thank you very
much senator reid and i agree with and
appreciate
a number of your comments and concerns a
number of your comments and concerns in
your in your opening statement i also
appreciate you holding this hearing
i am one of those as you know who thinks
that we in terms of our regulatory
approach right now
and uh and appreciate these
opportunities for oversight hearings as
i've indicated to you
excuse me because of my view
excuse me because of my activities in
either famous or infamous gang of six
i'm going to have to leave in about a
half an hour for another i'm going to
miss probably a lot of the testimony so
i'm going to try to identify a few areas
of concern in my remarks and also ask
that i could submit questions as well
following the hearing for questions as
well following the hearing for responses
i do believe that the issues we are
dealing with today are critical
we must continue to think strategically
about which areas of the market pose the
greatest risk and which areas of
potential improvement hold the greatest
benefit for investors
the taxpayer resources in a way
that provides the biggest investor
protection bank for the buck
in addition to these important issues i
look forward to hearing from addition to
these important issues i look forward to
hearing from our different division
directors
of the sec on dodd-frank implementation
questions and ways to promote cap with
regard to capital formation today the
sec is holding two panel discussions on
the issue
and one focuses on current capital
formation issues for focuses on current
capital formation issues for private
companies and another on initial public
offerings and securities regulation
involving smaller public companies
there are restrictions on capital
formation in both categories that should
be removed
the house recently passed some targeted
bipartisan capital formation legislation
that may partisan capital formation
legislation that makes it easier for
private companies to raise capital and
there have also been recently two
reports that make recommend decline
to stimulate the ipo market and spur
more job creation
the recent president's council on jobs
and competitiveness competitiveness
interim report recommends that congress
amend sarbanes-oxley oxley to allow
shareholders of public companies with
market valuations below one billion
dollars to opt out of at least section
404 compliance if not to all of the
requirements of sarbanes-oxley
or alternatively exempt new companies
from sox compliance for five years after
they go public
the ipo task force recommends providing
an on-ramp for emerging growth companies
using existing principles of scaled
regulation
the ipo task force expects scaled
regulation and disclosure to reduce
internal and external compliance for
such company reduce internal and
external compliance for such companies
by 30 percent to 50 percent
both of these recommendations could
result in a larger supply of emerging
growth companies going public
and increased job creation over the long
term
with regard to dodd-frank in addition to
removing unnecessary restrictions
this gives me unnecessary restrictions
on capital formation
we have to be careful that new rules
being implemented under dodd-frank give
sufficient main street and the economy
as a whole
how they interact with each other
and how they impact our global
competitiveness
i'm interested in
competitiveness i'm interested in what
steps you're taking to ensure that the
rules the agency adopts under dodd-frank
are supported by rigorous economic
inconsistencies in the approaches taken
by different regulators
yesterday the house subcommittee on
capital markets approved four targeted
bills to modify dodd-frank
one of the measures
would that pass by a voice vote would
prohibit the sec and cftc from requiring
this that swap execution facilities have
a minimum number of participants or
mandating the display or delay of bids
or offers for any period of time
differs for any period of time
this is in line with the sec approach
which is more principles based and is in
general far less prescriptive than that
of the cf this subcommittee held a
hearing on swap execute execution
facilities
one of the results of the hearing was
that there was bipartisan agreement that
the sec and the cftc
need to provide greater coordination and
harmonization to get the rules right
as many of you probably know i'm one of
those who thinks we should merge the sec
one of those who thinks we should merge
the sec and the cftc but until we can
get into that discussion i'll encourage
that they at least coordinate and
harmonize the ftc should know that
congress is going to ex to closely
monitor how they proceed as well as the
sec and and that we expect
uh this kind of harmonization and
this kind of harmonization and a
changing course when the agencies begin
to divert so that we can have the kind
of
seamless regulatory system that does
protect investors and achieve the
objectives that the chairman pointed out
as he described the
the hope that all of us have as to how
you and other regulatory agencies will
operate
there will be other issues i'd like to
raise in
excuse me mr chairman in my questions
but get to the witnesses and when i have
to step out i apologize i'll be paying
very close attention not only to your
opening statements but also to your
responses to the questions that we
provide and thank you again for being
here
thank you very much uh senator crepe let
me introduce the the witnesses we are
extraordinarily fortunate today to have
the key leaders of the securities and
exchange commission staff
first let me introduce mr robert kuzami
mr kazami is the director division
enforcement of the u.s securities
exchange commission as director mr
kuzami is responsible for the civil law
enforcement efforts of sec personnel
located in 12 officers across the
country prior to his tenure at the sec
mr kuzmi served as general counsel for
the americas for deutsche bank a.g and
before that as the bank's global head of
litigation and regulatory investigations
from 1990 through 2002 mr kuzami was
attorney through 2002 mr kuzami was a
federal prosecutor with the united
states attorney's office for the
southern district of new york where he
prosecuted a wide range of crimes
including narcotics money laundering
extortion bank robbery firearms and tax
bank and immigration forward during his
service mr gosami also leads forward
task force thank you mr kasama
eileen ramanger is the director of the
division of investment management at the
u.s securities and exchange commission
ms rominger was sworn in by chairman
mary shapiro on february 16 2011 and is
responsible for developing regulatory
policy and administrating the federal
security policy and administrating the
federal securities laws applicable to
investment advisors and funds
prior to becoming the investment
management director ms rominger was the
goldman sachs asset management
was with goldman sachs management as the
chief investment officer responsible for
managing
that company's core portfolio teams
including fixed income equity and
quantitative strategies she previously
worked 18 years at opera harbor capital
where she was a portfolio manager
manager
uh miss meredith cross is the director
of the division of corporate finance at
the u.s securities exchange commission
prior to joining the staff in june 2009
mrs cross was a partner at wilma hale
in washington dc where she advised
clients on corporate and security
matters and was involved with a full
range of issues faced at us and was
involved with a full range of issues
faced by public and private companies in
capital raising and financial reporting
ms cross also worked in the division of
corporate finance prior to joining wilma
hale serving in various capacities
including as chief counsel
and deputy director
robert w cook the u.s securities and
exchange commission mr cook has served
in this position since january 4th 2010
prior to joining the commission mr cook
was partner at the law firm gottlieb
stern in hamilton where he was an expert
on broker dealer and market regulation
carlo de florio became the director of
the office of compliance inspections and
examinations on january 25 2010
prior to joining the commission mr
deflourio was a partner in the financial
service regular practice at
pricewaterhousecoopers
while in private practice mr de floria
was one of
pricewaterhouse's national leaders in
corporate governance enterprise risk
management and regulatory compliance and
ethics he has
also led numerous fraud and corruption
investigations nationally and
internationally
and finally dr craig lewis is the
director and chief economist of the
division of risk strategy and financial
innovation dr lewis has served in this
position since june 2011
as the madison s wigington professor of
finance at vanderbilt university
owens school of management dr lewins has
taught corporate finance and economics
since 1983 and has been on the faculty
at vanderbilt since 1986. in addition to
teaching dr lewis has published research
on volatility in stock in futures
markets margin adequacy corporate
earnings management corporate financial
policy
executive compensation select disclosure
and heard behavior by equity analyst
uh thank you
your written testimony has already been
submitted it is part of the record i
would ask each of you to take five
minutes and make an oral presentation
starting with mr kazumi
thank you chairman reed ranking member
crapo my name is robert kazami i'm
director of the division of enforcement
thank you for the opportunity to testify
today concerning the management and
structural reforms at the sec
when i arrived at the sec in early 2009
to lead the enforcement division the
united states was struggling to come to
terms
with the impact of the financial crisis
our job indeed our challenge at the
division of enforcement was to
investigate and hold accountable those
who contributed to the financial crisis
and we took that challenge head on we'd
immediately set to work investigating
conduct that may have contributed to the
financial crisis and at the same time
launched an ambitious plan to reform the
organizational structure of the division
so that we could work smarter and more
efficiently than we had in the past
through hard work and innovation we have
now completed what was the most
significant restructuring in the history
of the division of enforcement
and although the conventional wisdom was
that the dislocation caused by such
significant organizational changes would
undermine our productivity that in fact
did not happen
in fiscal year 2011 we filed a record
735 enforcement actions more than ever
filed in a single year in history of the
securities and exchange commission
those actions included 57 insider
trading actions and nearly 8 percent
increase over last year's total
146 enforcement actions related to
investment advisors and investment
companies a single year record and 30
percent increase over fiscal year 2010
and 112 enforcement actions related to
broker dealers a 60 increase over last
year
and our focus on financial crisis cases
has continued during the two and a half
years the last two and a half years we
filed 36 separate financial crisis
related actions against 81 defendants
nearly half of whom were ceos cfos or
other senior corporate officials and
obtained nearly two billion dollars in
financial sanctions
this includes actions against goldman
sachs citigroup and senior executives at
country-wide new century and american
home mortgage
and equally and perhaps more importantly
our record number of cases include many
involving highly complex transactions
products and market practices
in the past fiscal year we filed actions
against jp morgan for misleading
investors in the cdo as the housing
market began to plummet wachovia for
misconduct in the sale of two cdo's tied
to the performance of residential
mortgage-backed securities two firms
involved in the sale of unsuitable cdos
to five wisconsin school districts and
charges against six executives at brook
corporation and three executives at
indymac for misleading investors about
their financial condition
and in addition to deprive the
wrongdoers of unjust profits and to
deter future misconduct we obtained
judgments totaling 2.8 billion in
discouragement and penalties this year
which was 176 increase over previous
years
and we have also distributed nearly 3.6
billion in disgorgement and penalties in
the last two years to harmed
investors and at the same time we were
doing this we instituted the large
organizational changes in our division
we flattened our management structure we
revamped the way we handled tips and
complaints we facilitated the swift
prosecution of wrongdoers through a
formal program that encourages
individuals and companies to cooperate
in sec investigations and created five
national specialized units focused on
priority areas areas involving high risk
we've also hired many industry experts
non-lawyers with genuine market
expertise and specialized experience to
assist in our investigation
so today if someone's testifying in an
sec investigation about for example
improper bond valuations there's a good
chance that sitting across the table
from them on the scc side of the table
is someone who used to value bonds for a
living and one cannot overestimate the
clarity and candor that that kind of
expertise brings to witness testimony
we're also focused on thinking
creatively and proactively to find
emerging threats stopping frauds earlier
before they become more destructive so
just using investment advisors as an
example we're now reviewing registration
documents for high-risk advisors to
determine who lies about things like
their education or their business
affiliations or their assets under
management
under the theory that if they come
face-to-face with an enforcement
authority early on for relatively small
matters they're going to know that we're
watching and they're going to be less
likely to graduate to bigger frauds
we're reviewing mutual fund fee
arrangements by analyzing databases to
find those funds that exhibit poor
performance high fee arrangement and
sub-advisory arrangements all of which
might suggest excessive fee arrangements
and inadequate oversight we have a
cross-border working group using risk
factors such as language fluency and the
extent of use of overseas auditing
affiliates and oversight capability of
audit firms to identify those us audit
firms with foreign clients that may be
engaged in financial reporting
violations
as a result of our focus on initiatives
and our proactive strategies and our
hiring of experts we're now better
equipped to stop fraud sooner
but to continue to innovate our
resources need to keep pace with our
responsibilities
we've achieved these results in light of
relatively flat budget
amounts that have constrained our
ability to backfill slots to hire
administrative staff and upgrade i.t
and we need those resources to continue
those efforts but with that and our new
ideas and our new structure i think we
will continue to be aggressively
prosecuting fraud thank you
thank you very much uh miss course
morning
good morning chairman reed and ranking
member crapo my name is meredith cross
and i'm the director of the division of
corporation finance at the sec i am
pleased to testify today along with my
fellow directors on behalf of the
commission to discuss the division's
activities and responsibilities and the
challenges that lie ahead the division
of corporation finance's core functions
are reviewing company filings making
rule making recommendations to the
commission that relate to corporate
finance matters and providing
interpretive advice to the public about
the securities laws and corresponding
regulations for corporate finance
matters with a staff of approximately
470 we are responsible for the review of
nearly 10 000 reporting companies
including tens of thousands of
disclosure documents each year
plus initial public offerings and other
public capital markets transactions of
corporate issuers public asset-backed
securities offerings and proxy
statements public mergers acquisitions
and tender offers approximately 80
percent of the staff of the division is
assigned to the review function the
sarbanes-oxley act requires the
commission to review disclosures
particularly the financial statements of
exchange act reporting companies at
least once every three years and more
frequently where circumstances weren't
this is no small task following
enactment of the sarbanes-oxley act in
2003 the division revised its review
program to meet the new review mandate
and hired significant numbers of new
staff accountants which has enabled us
to meet the review mandate each year
we also review the disclosures of many
companies more often than once every
three years for example the largest
companies are reviewed more often and
the largest financial institutions
currently are reviewed continuously on a
real-time basis
corporation finance has been working to
enhance the disclosure review program
including by increasing the focus on
large and financially significant
registrants and achieving additional
efficiencies in our reviews of smaller
companies our increased focus on larger
and financially significant companies
requires greater resources than
traditional disclosure reviews and our
ability to implement these enhancements
turns on whether we are able to allocate
sufficient resources balancing all other
demands on the division and our staff
during the 2011 fiscal year the division
established three new offices the office
of structure finance which focuses on
disclosure reviews and policy making for
asset-backed securities the office of
capital markets trends which evaluates
trends and securities offerings in the
capital markets to determine whether our
rules regulations and review approach
are adequately addressing them
and a new review group and disclosure
operations that focuses on the largest
financial institutions the division of
staffed these offices almost entirely by
transferring existing staff to them
if resources permit we plan to hire
to fully staff these offices to enable
them to carry out their intended work
corporation finance also recommends new
rules or changes to existing rules to
the commission to address areas in need
of change the division's recent rule
writing activities have focused on
asset-backed securities corporate
governance disclosure-related matters
and dodd-frank act implementation
corporation is responsible for preparing
a wide variety of rules to implement a
significant number of dodd-frank act
requirements these include for example
rules for corporate governance and
executive compensation including say on
pay and gold and parachutes disclosure
of pay versus performance pay ratios and
employee and director hedging policies
and listing standards for compensation
committees and compensation consultants
and for clawbacks of erroneously awarded
compensation
also specialized disclosure rules for
conflict minerals mine safety and
payments to governments by resource
extraction issuers
regulation of asset-backed securities
and revisions to the definition of
accredited investor and disqualification
of offerings involving bad actors from
relying on rule 506 of regulation d
finally at chairman shapiro's request
the division is undertaking a
significant new initiative to look for
ways to reduce regulatory burdens on
small business capital formation in a
manner consistent with investor
protection
topics included in this project include
the triggers for public reporting
generally known as the 500 shareholder
rule
restrictions on communications and
private offerings in particular the
restrictions on general solicitation
restrictions on communication in public
offerings and new capital raising
strategies such as crowd funding and the
scope of our existing rules that
regulate capital raising thank you again
for inviting me to appear before you
today i would be happy to answer any
questions you may have
mr cook please
good morning chairman reed and ranking
member crapo
my name is robert cook and i'm the
director of the division of trading and
markets and it's a pleasure to appear
here today with my colleagues from the
commission staff
the division of trading and markets is
responsible for developing rules and
standards for our markets and market
intermediaries including securities
exchanges alternative trading systems
broker-dealers clearing agencies
transfer agents and self-regulatory
organizations such as finra and the msrb
the exponential growth in the size and
complexity of the u.s securities markets
in recent years has created special
challenges for the division's mission
in the past year the division has
focused on several key initiatives to
improve the oversight and function of
our equity markets
the commission adopted a new rule to ban
naked access arrangements under which
broker dealers would provide certain
customers with unfettered access to the
securities markets without any controls
to protect market stability and
integrity
second the commission adopted large
trader reporting requirements that will
help identify and obtain trading
information on the largest participants
in the u.s securities markets
third we are preparing a recommendation
to the commission
for a rule to create implement and
maintain a consolidated audit trail to
address significant shortcomings in the
agency's present ability to collect and
monitor trade data in an efficient and
scalable manner
fourth the division has worked on the
implementation of several key regulatory
initiatives to address significant
market volatility such as occurred on
may 6 of last year
these initiatives include a uniform
single stock circuit breaker program
designed to halt trading in a disorderly
market
we have also coordinated proposed sro
efforts to implement a limit up limit
down functionality for equity markets
that will help prevent trades outside
specified parameters while allowing
trading to continue within those
parameters
in addition the division has assisted
the sros in the preparation of proposed
updates to the existing market-wide
circuit breakers
the division's core functions have
expanded substantially in the past year
under the dodd-frank act
all told the division is primarily
responsible for 27 separate rule-making
initiatives of which the commission has
published 21 for public comment
the division is also substantially
involved in 12 studies of which seven
have been completed
most notably we've been charged with
responsibility for developing the
registration and regulatory regime for
participants in the security-based otc
derivatives markets
including
data repositories dealers major
participants execution facilities and
clearing agencies
going forward this will mean
that trading and markets in coordination
with the other divisions and offices
will be registering these new entities
monitoring market developments and
promulgating new rules or modifications
and guidance where needed
to date the commission has proposed 13
rules related to otc derivatives
once the proposal phase is complete the
division is planning to recommend the
commission seek public comment on an
implementation plan that will facilitate
a rollout of the new requirements in a
logical progressive timely and efficient
manner that minimizes unnecessary
disruption and costs to the markets
the division is responsible for many
other aspects of the dodd-frank act
ranging from rules related to
proprietary trading activities of
broker-dealers the volcker rule enhanced
oversight of financial market utilities
such as clearing agencies and new
procedural requirements for processing
proposed sro rule changes
pending the creation of new offices for
credit rating agencies and municipal
securities
the division is also continuing to work
with osi to carry out our existing
functions in these areas including the
preparation of rules required by the
dodd-frank act
in conclusion
the division's workload is dominated by
diverse range of functions that are
vital for protecting investors and
markets and the scope of these functions
has expanded tremendously under the
dodd-frank act
many of our current initiatives will
extend well into 2012 and beyond
thank you for inviting me to be here
today and i look forward to answering
your questions thank you very much miss
rominger please
chairman reed ranking member crapo
members of the subcommittee let me join
my colleagues from the commission and
thanking you for the opportunity to
testify today my name is eileen rominger
it has been nine months since i joined
the sec as direct as director of the
division of investment management before
coming to the commission i had over 30
years of experience in the asset
management industry as a portfolio
manager and as a manager of portfolio
teams
the division assists the commission in
its oversight and regulation of
america's 43 trillion dollar investment
management industry
in doing this we administer the
investment company act of 1940 and the
investment advisors act of 1940 we
oversee and develop regulatory policy
for investment advisors and funds
the division has devoted the last year
to implementing the provisions of the
dodd-frank act as they relate to
investment advisors
the dodd-frank act significantly changed
the regulatory landscape for these
entities
first it increased the statutory
threshold for sec registration from 25
million to 100 million dollars in assets
under management
second it eliminated a registration
exemption for advisors to hedge funds
and other private funds and finally it
requires advisors that are not
registered to submit reports to the
commission
as a result
as a result advisors that do not meet
the new asset threshold may have to
withdraw the registration with the
commission and register instead in their
home states
advisors to hedge funds and other
private funds will be required to
register with the commission or to
qualify for one of the narrower
exemptions added by the dodd-frank act
in june the commission adopted rules to
implement these changes we anticipate
adding approximately 750 new private
fund advisors to the sec registrant pool
but we will see uh we estimate an
overall decline of about 28
in inves in advisor registrance overall
under new rules registered advisors will
report more detailed information about
their operations including information
about the private funds they manage
this will allow us for the first time to
obtain much needed information about
private funds such as hedge funds
following the implementation of these
rules i anticipate that the division
will shift more work to its disclosure
interpretive advice
and exemptive relief programs
another important area we are working on
is to implement the requirements of the
dodd-frank act that concerns systemic
risk reporting
the dodd-frank act mandated that the
commission require private fund advisors
including advisors to hedge funds and
private equity funds to report
information about the private funds they
manage for f sox systemic risk
assessment
just recently the commission adopted a
rule that requires registered investment
advisors managing at least 150 million
dollars in private fund assets to report
systemic risk information on a new form
called form pf
the initial stages of this reporting
will begin next year for some of the
very largest private fund advisors
the division is also working on a number
of important initiatives in other areas
outside of its dodd-frank agenda one of
which i will highlight
prior to my arrival at the sec and in
response to the the run on money market
funds during the financial crisis
the commission adopted important reforms
in the area of money market fund
regulation these reforms included a
requirement for money market funds to
report detailed portfolio holdings
information on a monthly basis
using this data the division is able to
monitor and discuss trends and any
associated risks in these funds with the
commission and with fsoc member staff
given the structural fragilities that
remain in money market funds despite the
commission's reforms the division
continues to consult with fsaq member
staff on additional on additional
regulatory reform steps
in addition to our role in commission
rulemaking a large part of our
administration of the investment company
act and the investment advisors act
consists of providing legal guidance in
the form of interpretive and no action
letters
as well as exemptive relief from the
from the provisions of both acts we also
review filings of investment companies
in order to both monitor and enhance
compliance with disclosure and
accounting requirements pursuant to the
regulate to the requirements under the
sarbanes-oxley act of 2002 the division
refu reviews the annual reports of all
investment companies no less frequently
than once every three years
the division also provides legal and
policy guidance to the division of
enforcement on enforcement matters
concerning the investment management
industry again thank you for the
opportunity to testify today i'm happy
to answer any questions you may have
thank you very much mr lewis please
[Music]
chairman reed ranking member crapo and
members of the subcommittee my name is
craig lewis and i'm the chief economist
and director of the division of risk
strategy and financial innovation thank
you for the opportunity to testify on
behalf of the securities and exchange
commission regarding the division's
operations activities and challenges i
joined the division as director in june
of this year before coming on board i
was a professor of finance at the owen
graduate school of management at
vanderbilt university where i focused on
research and teaching primarily in the
area of corporate finance i'm also a phd
economist
the division was created as part of the
agency's modernization initiative to
share expertise and bring together
critical data from across the agency it
was established in september 2009 to
provide the commission and its staff
with sophisticated analysis that
integrates economic financial and legal
expertise risk fin provides economic
analyses as part of the commission's
rulemaking process and supports its rule
review examination and enforcement
programs with data-driven risk-based
analytical models
it also oversees the commission's tcr
and interactive data programs the
division has been especially focused on
the agency's increased use of
computerized risk analysis and data
sharing
the division participates in the
rulemaking process by helping to develop
the conceptual framing for and assisting
in the subsequent writing of the
economic consequences of the rules the
commission promulgates where appropriate
the sec considers in addition to the
protection of investors whether the
action will promote efficiency
competition and capital formation when
engaged in rulemaking
economic analysis of agency rules
considers the key economic effects of
the various alternatives that should be
considered in developing regulations
analysis of the likely economic effects
of proposed rules while critical to the
rule making process can be challenging
certain costs or benefits may be
difficult to quantify or value with
precision particularly those that are
indirect or intangible
the division is committed to
continuously improving economic analysis
in commission rule makings and to the
integration of risk-fin economists into
the rulemaking process
while the division is striving to fully
comply with these increased demands it
faces challenges in its ability to do so
given current resources
the second core function of the division
is to administer a number of data-driven
responsibilities and initiatives for
example the division currently provides
economic and statistical analysis to
support all aspects of enforcement and
litigation matters for the commission it
also has developed innovative software
tools and uses cutting-edge analytic
methods to identify potential problem
areas associated with investment
managers
the interactive data program provides
information contained in certain
documents filed with the commission and
a structured format that makes the
underlying data readily available for
analysis the division has a number of
responsibilities that include promoting
the use of interactive data
developing data infrastructure and
supporting rule writing to implement
data tagging requirements
to improve efficiency the division has
been reorganized to reassign staff that
have expertise in data analysis and risk
assessment into the newly formed office
of quantitative research which will be
responsible for designing quantitative
risk assessment models this office has
begun to build a data infrastructure to
facilitate the development and support
of analytics going forward the division
would like to expand its capabilities to
develop risk assessment models and to
build a scalable data infrastructure to
support risk-based initiatives although
the division plans to pursue these
objectives simultaneously and has
existing employees with the necessary
expertise to work on these projects
resource constraints inhibit progress
and significantly slow the rate of
innovation for example a project to
develop a model to detect accounting
fraud has been delayed due to resource
constraints
while the division has made significant
progress since its exception in 2009 the
scope of its responsibilities has been
significantly expanded as it continues
to find new ways to assist other
divisions and as it addresses the
additional obligations that have been
mandated by the dodd-frank act thank you
for inviting me to share with you the
work of the division of risk strategy
and financial innovation i look forward
to answering your questions thank you
very much mr de flora please good
morning chairman reed ranking member
crepe bo members of the subcommittee let
me join my colleagues in thanking you
for the opportunity to testify today on
behalf of the u.s securities and
exchange commission
my name is carlo delorio and i am the
director of the office of compliance
inspections and examinations
as you noted i joined the sec on january
25th 2010 prior to which i was a partner
in the financial services regulatory
practice at pricewaterhousecoopers in
new york
since joining the sec i have enjoyed
working with colleagues who are so
dedicated and committed to furthering
the sec's important mission
the sec's national exam program helps
protect investors and ensure market
integrity by examining for fraud
monitoring risk promoting compliance
and ensuring market integrity and
informing the sec as the eyes and ears
of the sec in the field
our exams assess whether registrants are
treating investors fairly and complying
with the securities laws and regulations
that are designed to protect investors
and prevent fraud
the 830 supervisors and examiners in the
national exam program take a risk-based
approach to examining 25 000 plus
registrants
including investment advisors investment
companies broker dealers derivatives
registrants hedge funds mutual funds
credit rating agencies
sros national exchanges clearing
agencies and transfer agents
under the direction of a new leadership
team
oc has undertaken a top to bottom review
and launched over 20 improvement
initiatives to strengthen our strategy
our structure our people our processes
and our technology
accomplishments over the past year
include the following
we have recruited experts
and launched new specialty groups that
bring deep needed expertise and and
specialization
in program areas such as derivatives and
structured products
hedge funds credit rating agencies high
frequency trading and risk management
we've conducted over sixteen hundred
exams that are better targeted at
preventing fraud identifying violations
and addressing higher risk firms
products and practices
we've implemented a new large firm
monitoring group to focus on systemic
risk firms and a new risk analysis and
surveillance unit to enhance our ability
to monitor risk trends and target those
firms and practices that present the
greatest risk to investors markets and
capital formation
we've created a national governance
structure that breaks down silos and
facilitates coordination consistency
effectiveness and accountability across
the country
we've streamlined and automated our exam
process with new technology we've
clearly defined expectations in a new
exam manual and we've implemented a new
internal compliance and ethics program
to monitor our performance and ensure
our accountability
we are working to design and implement a
new examiner training program that
establishes technical training and
certification standards across the
country
no matter how much we improve our
current program however
the fact remains that our 830 examiners
and supervisors can only cover a small
portion of the 25 000 plus registrants
we are responsible for overseeing
this results in a ratio of only one
examiner for every 30 registrants
to give you a sense of benchmarking bank
regulators for instance typically have
an examiner-to-registrant ratio of one
to one or one to two
finra's ratio is one to five
needless to say our one to thirty ratio
presents an enormous gap with real
consequences if not addressed
for instance our staff were only able to
examine eight percent of registered
investment advisors in fiscal year 201
2011.
although we visited firms with more than
30 percent of the assets under
management currently registered with the
sec
in addition more than one-third of
registered investment advisors have
never been examined
we continue to pursue strategies such as
risk focusing our exams and automating
our exam processes to be as efficient as
possible and to maximize the usage of
resources we are provided nevertheless
additional resources would enable us to
more effectively fulfill our new
responsibilities protect investors and
ensure market integrity thank you and i
welcome the opportunity to answer your
questions
thank you very much and i want to thank
all the witnesses for superb testimony
and
your
collective testimony illustrates the the
range the complexity and the vital
importance of what you do
and also i think underscores
the need to be properly resourced to do
a very complicated job which gets
complicated each and every day by
innovations in the marketplace so thank
you very much again for what you what
you're doing what you continue to do and
i think uh
you know
one final point on on this area
if you don't have these resources
you cannot effectively
provide sort of direction and guidance
to the marketplace it's tonight
perhaps professor lewis can come it's
probably more inefficient than anything
else that you're not giving them the
guidance that they need to go forward
and then make
appropriate decisions but let me begin
my questioning and i'm in an envious
position because i have lots of
questions that i have experts before me
uh mr kuzami uh
one of the most notorious uh incidents
of the last few years was the madoff's
uh scandal
recently the
the final act perhaps has been
undertaken which is the disposition of
allegations against members of the
sec their behavior there are some people
in the enforcement division was involved
there have been sanctions but no one has
been dismissed and um
that's a question which uh is
uh
forefront in many people's minds
accountability i mean we you're asking
for accountability of marketplace i
think the american public is also asking
through us accountability at the sec can
you comment on
on the disposition and whether or not
you feel that that was appropriate
um yes senator uh i think you're
absolutely right that accountability
is our obligation as well and with
respect to
not only the madoff matter in general
which has spawned and generated you know
many of the forward-looking reforms and
changes and
organizational revisions that you've
heard this morning with respect to
individualized disciplinary decisions
the inspector general's report
identified
a total of 21 persons approximately who
he believed warranted follow-up for
possible disciplinary actions about 10
of those left the division
since the report was issued and the sec
has no ability to discipline
ex-employees who have departed so that
left approximately
11 and
we conducted an extremely thorough
process
to make these decisions including
bringing an independent law firm to come
in and conduct its own independent
investigation and then make
recommendations to the proposing
officials and ultimately the deciding
officials because ultimately it's an
agency decision
and um all of uh
of the 11 persons who were recommended
um nine um uh were recommended for
actions by the law firm and action was
in fact taken against all nine
um
in a couple of cases
it was i think the two cases perhaps
less than what the law firm had
recommended and i think i'll defer to mr
diflorio who i think
it was in the oc program that um the
individual whose uh who the who the
proposal was should be terminated in
fact a different result was achieved but
generally
um
all the persons recommended by the
outside law firm suffered a range of
discipline
uh mr defloor can you comment and i have
a follow-on question sure senator as uh
my colleague mr kazami noted
speaker is the microphone on yes are you
able to hear me okay
as my colleague mr kazami indicated a
very serious review was undertaken and
and all of the individuals ultimately
that were identified were disciplined
in one instance the independent third
party law firm
recommended termination of an individual
or
if termination would have a significant
negative impact on the operations of the
sec
than to
fashion an alternative remedy that would
significantly change that individual's
roles and responsibilities
and such is a
demotion and a reduction in pay so the
sec followed that recommendation of the
independent law firm and refashioned the
roles and responsibilities of that
individual
they no longer have supervisory
responsibilities
their role was reduced they received a
reduction in pay and there was a
suspension of 30 days
i would also just
assure the congress and the american
people that we've taken the lessons
learned from madoff very seriously and
have implemented significant
improvements to help us identify and
prevent fraud so we can better protect
investors ensure market integrity and
facilitate capital formation could you
just follow up very quickly of some of
the steps you've taken
looking forward based upon the
experience with madoff sure
so we have undertaken significant
training for all examiners and
investigators
in the sec
of fraud techniques fraud tools
and make sure that our
forces truly understand the various
fraud scenarios that are out there how
to identify them and how to act quickly
to shut them down i think our results
as articulated by mr kazami and some of
the results that i identified
demonstrate
how we're beginning to have that impact
in addition we've really brought
technology to bear so we have a new
system for tips complaints and referrals
that centralizes any such tips
complaints referrals that come in and
make sure that we have the right people
triaging it and following up on it so
we're bringing better technology better
resources better people to the job thank
you very much uh mr cassano let me
return to another
topical issue
[Music]
judge rakoff has
raised some questions about the
appropriateness of a settlement that
you've proposed with city court but it
raises a few questions
one is
[Music]
you're you have allegations against the
company
but there are no individuals that have
been i think pursued in this case in
other cases
and to a lot of people on the street
they're wondering how a company
can
commit serious
violations of securities laws and yet no
individuals seem to be involved and no
individual responsibility is assessed
and that i think that is at the heart of
one of the concerns that judge rayquaff
has can you comment on that
sure senator um
look we focus first and foremost on
individuals for exactly the reason you
identify individuals commit wrongdoing
um uh not institutions but i think it's
a misperception that we haven't charged
individuals first of all in the
citigroup case itself we charged the
individual
who was responsible for the particular
transaction and we're in litigation now
with him we also charged a second
individual who worked for the collateral
manager on the deal
the firm that
represented that it was independently
selecting the portfolio when in fact
that was not the case so two individuals
were charged
in this case and overall across our
credit crisis cases just to take an
example as i mentioned in my opening
remarks
in approximately 26 cases 89 individuals
and entities half of which are
high-ranking corporate officers
um have been charged i mean the the the
the entirety of the executive suite at
you know new century and indymac and
other companies and
individuals who
who have sold these deals have been
charged i think part of the concern is
that why hasn't in some of these cases
have gone all the way up to the
executive
suite and why haven't the heads of banks
been charged but it's a difficult
challenge in certain transactional cases
because
what's going on occurs you know two
three and four levels below the
executive suite if you're selling a cdo
it's being
put together
by individuals working on the desks and
the disclosures being written by
individuals who are
not at the executive level so the
the evidence and the duties and
obligations don't always rise all the
way up to the top of the executive suite
unlike say an accounting fraud or
financial statement fraud where
ceos and cfos and others may have to
sign off on the accuracy of financial
statements so to some degree
if that's the concern it's a function of
the nature of the cases but we have
aggressively charged as i said over half
of the individuals in these cases 40 to
50 high-ranking ceos cfos and senior
corporate executives let me follow up
with one additional question before i
recognize senator merkley and then
senator menendez
you are of course talking about civil
charges which is your responsibility but
there's been many other commoners who've
raised the issue of
why aren't there any criminal charges
because there are at least
suggestions allegations of criminal
violations as well as civil violations
and as i understand it you would have to
refer those cases to the department of
justice
but the record
is not
they're very few i can think of
criminal cases that have been taken in
the wake of the worst financial crisis
in the history of the country and
behavior
which at least to the outside observers
seems to be
highly questionable
have you been making referrals
and have justice been systematically
turning you down or
how can you comment on this relationship
senator we work extremely closely with
the justice department with the u.s
attorney's office in new york and other
offices and i can assure you
they are keenly interested
in cases arising out of the credit
crisis and look extremely closely
at the evidence in these matters conduct
their own inquiries and reach their own
determinations
it's a hurdle for them they have a
higher standard of proof in a criminal
case they must prove a case beyond a
reasonable doubt
and so
some of the challenges that we face they
face even
even more forcefully because of that
higher standard of proof but i can
assure you
it is not for a lack of dedication or
professionalism or talent that criminal
cases aren't being filed
i i presume from that answer that you
have made referrals but they have not
been
followed through because of the judgment
they have to make independently well
yeah it's referrals but it's also we
work very closely with them we don't
just take a case and refer it over to
them and wash our hands of it we are in
constant communications and discussions
and reviewing evidence and working
collaboratively
thank you very much there will be an
additional round of questioning but let
me recognize senator merkley now for his
statement or questions or a combination
of the vote
ah thank you mr chair i don't have a
statement i do have some questions if
that's appropriate
uh thank you i wanted to start uh to to
get anyone's opinion on
the congressman defazio's proposal
on high frequency trading which goes
back to kind of thinking a little bit
about the
flash crash and i believe i believe what
he had in his most recent proposal
is a three basis point
fee
that discourages if you will the
multitudinous uh
high-speed trades while having very
little impact on regular in invest
investors
any any thoughts about that
mr cook thank you senator um
i'm not familiar with the details of
that but i i think that proposal or very
versions of it have been um raised at
several times and i think um you know
there are a number of interesting uh
issues that it raises obviously there
are concerns about the extent to which
the traffic that's generated by high
frequency traders
is of itself a um
interfering with the effective
functioning of the markets and to some
extent um some type of
fee whether it's order can't or
a message fee or an order cancellation
fee the various versions this might take
um that might be helpful in uh
addressing that i think the the the
challenges are um uh first picking the
the right metrics for when that would
happen
uh when it would kick in what the type
of fee would be and and second probably
more importantly
you know to not undermine the liquidity
in the markets that
may be
very important and certainly during
normal market circumstances
given the prevalence of high frequency
trading in our markets today i think
this is an area where we have to move
very carefully to ensure that whatever
changes we uh introduce
uh to a significant portion of the
volume in the markets is uh very uh you
know carefully considered
to avoid any unintended consequences
anyone else want to weigh in on that
very good uh thank you
the
a second issue i wanted to get some
insights on is the crowd funding of of
companies
uh as we move to this internet world as
people become familiar with peer-to-peer
lending
uh certainly this is a very different
avenue than traditional in investing
very different for the investors and
very different
for the companies
and in some ways it's very
exciting possibility but also poses uh
risks related to uh to to fraud
and how does uh any any insights on how
this uh
gets
pursued supported
uh or guided
so that it will be a win for investors
and a win for companies
um i'll start off
first off i have to note that i'm not
participating in the crowdfunding matter
because of my prior work for a
peer-to-peer lender but in general with
regard to the new capital raising
strategy ideas that are being considered
in in congress and also at the
commission
the the key here is to
um make sure that whatever is is built
um doesn't become fraught with fraud so
that it becomes uh so investor
confidence is is destroyed and then
people won't invest in that market since
that level of deregulation wouldn't help
anyone um so we're working with uh the
market participants and
and and members of congress and looking
at the various pieces of legislation to
help
put in safeguards that would we keep
that from happening i think um one of
the ideas that's been discussed is the
possibility of intermediaries um as a as
a means of of protecting investors and i
i can let mr cook address that
so when we think of uh
investors purchasing securities one of
the traditional tools we have to help
provide protections for them is the
registration and regulation of the party
who's doing the selling
and when we registering as a
broker-dealer and one of the
some of the factors we think about when
we think about whether that's
appropriate include
is does the broker have a salesman stake
in the transaction are there conflicts
of interest that might arise is the
intermediary handling customer funds and
securities
and so i think you know in our
experience in in this area i think a
couple of of um observations
one is that um
the
they're very fact patterns matter and
they're very different forms in which
these intermediaries may it may relate
to
investors and i think in some cases
we've given guidance that they are not
subject to registration or wouldn't be
because
the regulatory policy concerns haven't
been triggered
i think another area that we need to
think about though is is whether we have
a sufficiently flexible regime because
the types of rules that might be
appropriate for
one type of entity may not be
appropriate for a traditional brokerage
house for example and i think
if there were a regulatory regime in
place here i think that would be a key
area in which you'd want to have some
flexibility to tailor the requirements
to the specific
facts and circumstances
thank you my time's up so i'm just going
to say i appreciate your feedback on
both those there's about 10 other topics
i'd be happy to extend the conversation
on but i'm going to defer to my
colleagues
senator menendez thank you mr chairman
ms cross i authored section 953 b of the
dodd-frank legislation which requires
publicly listed companies
to disclose um the pay of their medium
work or compared to the pay of their ceo
and we weighed in with the sec earlier
this year about
both our intention with this provision
and where it is that you were at we got
an answer that was
uh less than satisfactory uh because it
was a non-answer as far as i'm concerned
so can you tell me
where it is
that uh
you are at and in terms of being on
track
for finishing this rule on this
provision by the end of this year
i'm i'm happy to do so um right now the
division is in the process of preparing
the recommendation for the commission so
that they can could
act on a proposal we're trying mightily
to make it by the end of the year that
is the
schedule that's up that that's the goal
that's up on our public website and i
can assure you that we're doing
everything we can to get there
we have a lot of things we're trying to
do right now and this this is one of the
very important ones but i can assure you
we are trying our hardest to make the
year end i would hope that what we see
happening across the country and
people's concern about inequality
would spur the sec
to have a mere transparency we've we've
had testimony here particularly from the
from those who have come from the
private sector about how hard this will
be and they actually have said that they
do not believe that it is that difficult
to produce the information so i hope we
understand particularly in light of
actions that are being taken by citizens
across this country
about how important i know you have a
lot of work we gave you a lot of work to
do i understand that but this
is something that clearly uh people are
looking for to have some transparency
and to have it sooner rather than later
so we're looking forward to you
achieving it by the end of the year at
least bring it before the commission
we're doing our best as i said okay
that means you'll get it done before the
end of the year uh let me ask you uh
this uh as well uh earlier this year i
introduced the shareholder protection
act with several of my colleagues to
disclose corporate spending
in elections in the wake of what i
believe is a misguided
decision on citizens united
since then my staff has been told by sec
attorneys
that the sec already has the authority
to implement rules that would require
corporations to disclose their political
spending to shareholders is that
accurate
yes it is accurate that the commission
has the authority to require that
disclosure if they if they decided to do
so through through rulemaking
i note that
the citizens united case has certainly
piqued an interest in this topic we have
two rule-making petitions pending at the
commission right now seek asking us to
um consider providing requiring
disclosure about political spending i
also note that this is an area where the
market is moving um in that direction as
well there's a recent report showed that
more than half of the s p 100 is already
providing this disclosure
also shareholder proposals are included
in
under our rules are included in proxy
statements so that shareholders can vote
on whether they want this disclosure so
this is certainly an area of of great
interest the staff's carefully
considering all this as as we think
about the of the issue
well i hope the sec believes that this
type of disclosure would be helpful for
investors uh in october uh 2010 zogby
poll of business leaders found that 77
of them believe that corporations should
disclose
all the direct and indirect political
expenditures uh and is that something
the sec disagrees with
well i can't speak for the commission on
on that point we haven't taken this
staff level is that where you're where
you recommend where you're headed on
your recommendations we haven't
concluded what we should recommend i
think we're
reviewing the petitions and and
considering the issue in light of many
large companies microsoft wells fargo
merck aetna have already taken steps to
disclose their political uh expenditures
and to me it illustrates the ease of
which can be done
and so i'm hoping that the sec
looks for that to be for shareholders
across the board
a reality
so i'm looking forward to what your
recommendations are on that as well mr
cook let me ask you one quick question
what is the sec's expected timing for
issuing the remaining proposed rules on
capital margin segregation and
record-keeping requirements for
security-based swaps under title vii of
dodd-frank
uh the rules you refer to which are the
final
rules in uh the substantive proposal
phase of rotc derivatives regulation are
um are at the top of the list for our
otc derivatives work
the goal was to get them done by the end
of the year
you know whether we hit that or not i'm
not sure but we that's the probably the
next item out of the
commission on the otc derivatives front
so
let's say for argument's sake that you
reach at the end of the year what would
be your overall implementation
schedule and or propose implementation
rules for its final rules well what we
propose to do after
we propose all the substantive rules is
to issue two releases that are also
underway now so that we can get them out
as quickly as possible
one is a release that
discusses how our rules would apply
internationally so across border release
looking across each of the
different subset of rule makings whether
it's execution facilities or dealer
registration or cr
clearing agencies and talk about how
those rules apply or would apply in a
cross-border
context and solicit comment on that
because it's a very important piece of
the implementation and the second thing
would be to issue an implementation plan
both of these would be for public
comment that would lay out the process
which we would propose to roll out the
new framework uh in a timely efficient
manner uh with the goal of uh sort of
approaching this as a project management
task where if we are can be as uh
thoughtful in how we roll it out we'll
get to the end more quickly and
efficiently all right mr chairman thank
you very much appreciate it thank you
senator mendes let me uh begin the
second round by
asking mister
because zombie uh
again in the context of this recent uh
litigation
under judge rakoff with respect to city
co-op and this is not exclusive to one
company but typically
you will reach a settlement which the uh
the the corporation neither admits nor
denies
and um it strikes a lot of people oddly
why if you don't have any culpability
you're paying 700 million dollars
uh have you reconsidered whether or not
that is at all
uh effective or what role it plays
that's one question and and the second
question would be they typically also
say that they'll never do this again
and i'm not using the precise language
of the
uh of the finding but uh and then you
find that and again not exclusive to one
company in many companies that troubling
patterns of behavior emerge in the
future maybe not exactly identical but
certainly
within the same sort of context of uh
and yet
there doesn't seem to be action in your
division to take people up on their
commitment never to do it again or
anything like it again
are you rethinking what you can do in
terms of these settlements and on both
those points
uh yeah senator let me let me explain
our approach in these in these areas
first um
the bottom line is we settle cases um
where we believe that
the sanctions that we can obtain
including the
monetary sanctions and the business
reforms et cetera
are what we could likely obtain should
the case go to trial taking into account
the risks the strength of the evidence
the law et cetera
um
in monetary sanctions
which is another matter that's been
discussed i have to make it clear that
we cannot obtain penalties in the amount
of investor losses
we are limited by law to getting
disgorgement which is the ill-gotten
gains of the perpetrator and then a
penalty in general equal to the amount
of that gain so if you had somebody who
earned 20 20 and defrauded investors of
a hundred we can get a hundred
representing the gain for the
perpetrator excuse me we can get 20
representing the gain of the perpetrator
and another 20
in a penalty but we can't get the
hundred in most circumstances and so
to some degree there's been commentary
about our settlements that they don't
seem to be uh significant enough in
terms of the financial sanctions that
reflects
frankly you know our view of the
strength of the evidence and the case
and the risks associated with it but
also some statutory restrictions on the
amount of money that we can get but
in addition to that um
with respect to no admit no deny um
uh
we um
our goal is to get money in the hands of
investors
as soon as possible if we were to demand
admissions in every case and keep in
mind it's no admit no deny which means
companies can't deny liability they're
not required to admit it but they can't
deny liability as well
and so under that provision
if we were to insist on admissions
because of the collateral consequences
of those admissions both with respect to
private civil litigation and even with
respect to criminal exposure companies
going to open themselves up to that kind
of
that kind of exposure now i don't have
any particular sympathy for that it's
just a reality of the negotiation
process that they will not settle cases
and they will take more cases to trial
so we're
we're left with a situation with if we
can settle a case now
for the amount of money and the range of
sanctions that we believe reasonably
approximate what we could get if we were
successful without the risks
of a trial and most importantly get
money in the hands of investors today
rather than two years from now or three
years from now or four years from now
when that case goes to trial and even
more if it goes to appeal
and most importantly we have more
resources to attack the next fraud
because there's opportunity costs in
everything that we do
if we are prosecuting case a we are not
prosecuting case b
and so
it's it's cold comfort to other victims
of other frauds if we are putting all of
our resources
taking a case to trial and one's not
settling
when their case is not being prosecuted
if we're getting a package of remedies
that are strong and send a meaningful
message i would also say that in our
cases we issue a complaint with very
detailed allegations the company pays a
large amount of money they agree to
business reforms
they cannot deny liability
my view is um while i certainly
understand the desire for people wanting
someone to stand up and admit to the
wrongdoing there's not a lot of mystery
under those circumstances that the
company is in fact engaged in wrongdoing
they wouldn't be writing a check for 300
million dollars or agreeing to reform
their business
in the face of these very pointed and
specific allegations of what happened
and so on balance trying to
serve many values
we adopted no admit no deposit like
the ftc like the department of justice
civil division like the cftc and just
the other day the national credit union
administration settled a case against
two banks for 300 million dollars for
mortgage-related problems also on a no
admit no deny basis the supreme court
has endorsed it so while i understand
the desire for it and there are cases
where
where i might like to see it as well and
we do review our policy the fact of the
matter is is that we have to choose
among some competing goals
that we're trying to accomplish and
that's where we come out with respect to
repeat offenders
this deals with the question of contempt
and i think there's a little bit of a
misperception around our authority in
this area if a company engages in a
securities law violation in 2005
and agrees
not to do it again by way of an
injunction and then in 2008
sells a securities product that violates
the law
we're not able we can only get civil
contempt but civil contempt is only
available if there's an ongoing fraud so
that we could go in court and say your
honor this company is engaging in
conduct now that violates their previous
promise not to break the law again you
have to stop them from doing this
conduct right now but that only works if
the conduct is ongoing if the sale of
the securities is over there's no
ongoing fraud there's no there's nothing
to to order um
compliance with and that's the vast
majority of cases there has to be
ongoing fraud in order to bring a
contempt action in addition the most you
would get from a judge is he would say
stop doing what you're doing now but if
it's already over there's nothing to get
there i think what most people want in
this area is criminal contempt which is
punitive which is
sanctions for simply violating the
previous order and that only the
department of justice has authority to
do but we by no means ignore recidivism
we take it into account deciding how
much a company should pay that
in that second action what kind of
business reforms might need to be
adopted and other packages so we
thoroughly take into account prior
misconduct but contempt is a poor
vehicle in most cases to accomplish that
i mean i have one quick follow-up
question before i recognize senator
merkley i promise they will
ask the other panelists on our return
questions uh but uh
it recently
you have used language in the
sarbanes-oxley legislation to claw back
[Music]
gains that an individual received that
although he was not directly charged
with any type of violation is that a
practice that you're going to
pursue uh with more frequency going
forward
uh yes senator that is uh section 304
obeying the 304 of sarbanes-oxley which
allows
us to sue and require a ceo or cfo to
claw back
certain
incentive-based
bonuses and equity awards as well as
certain stock sale profits
when the company that they work for
fails to
comply with certain financial reporting
requirements as a result of misconduct
and we have used that tool and we look
in all of our cases to whether or not
that tool
is is appropriate it is
a strong tool because like you say
these are standalone actions the ceo or
the cfo doesn't have to be involved in
the misconduct if the company they're
working for does it their their
compensation can be clawed back and so
we we look at it closely
it's not without you know some issues
obviously ceos and cfos are differently
positioned some are completely absentee
and don't do their job at all
and misconduct occurs others may be very
active maybe even following best
practices and nonetheless misconduct
occurs so
you know you need to be uh you know
exercise of range of discretion in these
cases but it is a tool we look at
closely and we've brought a number of
actions in this area thank you uh
senator merkley
[Music]
ah thank you very much mr chair and i
wanted to turn to mf global
which if i understand right mf global
was both broker dealers
if you will
regulated by the sec and a futures
dealer regulated by the cftc
i believe it's on the futures
side
that the issue of
client accounts in the segregation of
client accounts is in question that is
whether their their accounts the money
was used uh in a proprietary trading or
hedge fund style operation in violation
of the sanctity of those those
individual accounts
so this you know it's very confusing to
the the public certainly to to us as to
where the oversight comes and what went
wrong
but recognizing
that sec is primarily on the broker
dealers side of the firm did things go
wrong on the broker dealer dealers side
or is the broker dealer's side deeply
impacted if you will by the which i'm
sure it is by the by the future side
um
how does the cftc and sec coordinate
their regulation of this type of complex
firm
senator as you've
noted the firm was duly registered as
both a broker-dealer and an fcm a
futures commission merchant
what that means is that both agencies
and their
the self-regulatory organizations under
them
have oversight over the firm in some
respects
you know our oversight
about certain activities would focus on
securities uh and the cftcs and the dcos
under the the cftc would focus on the
futures activities
we both have rules as well that would
apply to the entity as a whole for
example capital rules and the ending
would be subject to have to comply with
both sets of rules so being jointly
registered means that you have to comply
with the rules applicable to a
broker-dealer and the rules applicable
to fcm as you noted the the the
shortfall that's been
received a great deal of attention in
the press and is a significant concern
is on the futures side the segregation
of customer assets related to futures
positions
your question does that affect the
brokered dealer side i think of course
it is one entity and that's now in
bankruptcy and and shortfalls can are
obviously a significant concern
in any customer protection regime
we are
continuing to work with the trustee to
uh as is the cftc uh and other
regulatory agencies to help identify
exactly what is the position of the firm
both on the security side and the
futures side because one of the
challenges here is that the
um the the books and records of the
firms uh are
appear to be challenging in terms of
getting to the bottom of some of these
questions
i think you know just having uh been in
close contact with the cftc and other
regulators through the weekend
when the firm was exploring strategic
options
i think absent
this shortfall being identified there
would have been a significant
chance of a deal happening that would
have transferred this the customer
counts out
in the way it's meant to happen so uh if
broker dealers and fcms fail sometimes
our goal is to make sure that that
happens
there's a credible and
reliable way to protect customers
and
that only works if the customer assets
are available to transfer to it to a new
firm and so in that sense the shortfall
obviously impacts all customers of the
firm and so is that happening on the
broker dealer side
is there you mean is there on the
customer in terms of customers who
owned stocks or placed orders through
the the securities broker dealer side is
that their accounts been transferred out
to some other firm not yet the um the
there were many more futures customers
so i think the the trustee
has transferred 17 000
futures accounts that had positions in
them there are more that he's seeking to
compensate that didn't have
positions but had collateral just by way
of contrast on the
security side he has solicited uh
interest in acquiring 450
securities accounts
so it's a much smaller
number of affected customers
those
he the trustee has
solicited
interest from potential transferees of
those accounts so that they and their
property could move forward
so is it is it likely that the account
holders on the broker dealer side are
are whole and undamaged
i wouldn't want to provide any
assurances at this time i can tell you
that the um the what the firm
self-reported was a shortfall on the
future side uh the firm's calculations
on the security side with respect to
their
customer segregation requirements
indicated uh
that they had that they were in
compliance with the securities customer
segregation rules but as you can imagine
we're not
taking that
at face value we are uh currently
working hard to try to uh verify exactly
what's there and who those what so that
we can provide assurance the reason and
i'm over my time now so i'll just
summarize this the reason i'm i'm
pushing to this point is trying to
understand whether there's insights here
about the complexities of regulating a
firm that is both a broker dealer and a
futures dealer whether there needs to be
stronger firewalls between the two
halves
of the business in order to
ensure both the coherence of regulation
and the uh the the security of one side
of the firm if you will or the and the
customers from from fraud on the other
side of the firm those were the types of
pieces i'm pushing and i'll look forward
to kind of can maybe my team can
continue the conversation with you about
insights that can be derived
from this absolutely thank you
thank you senator merkley
let me
resume and this course senator crapo
indicated his interest in the formation
of capital particularly for small
companies i know you and your colleagues
are working this could you let us know
your latest efforts in terms of capital
formation particularly the small
enterprises
absolutely um
so at chairman shapiro's request last
spring we started an initiative to look
for
to take a fresh look at our rules to see
if there are
steps we could take to reduce regulatory
burdens
that would help facilitate capital
formation by smaller companies
if it could be done consistent with
investor protection as i noted if if
investors aren't confident then they're
not going to invest and so you don't
actually help anyone raise capital so we
in everything we do we try to balance
the capital formation mission with the
investor protection mission
the the staff has uh several work
streams going right now uh that are
in the works one one is to
do a study of whether the 500
shareholder threshold for reporting
should be changed and that in 1964 when
congress not adopted the current the 500
shareholder threshold they had tasked
the sec with doing a robust study so
we're doing that again with help from
craig's group
so that's one of the pieces we are
working on a concept release on the
general resuscitation issue in private
offerings and we are looking at whether
there's ways we can
extend some of the benefits that we give
to larger companies in
capital raising extend those to smaller
companies for example easier access to
shelf registration things like that
we're being helped tremendously in this
effort by our new
uh advisory committee on small and
emerging companies it had its first its
kickoff meeting two weeks ago and
they're already working on
recommendations having considered these
topics that we brought forward to them
at the at the first meeting and then
tomorrow is our i think it's the 30th um
of the annual uh government business
forum on small business capital
formation is being held at the
commission and i think every
commissioner is speaking at it and
attending it so there's obviously great
interest in the topic
thank you very much
uh mr lewis you have
an increasingly challenging role to play
the
relevant legislation requires
publication of a rule for the sec to
consider
market effects
but given the recent court rulings uh
it's hard to tell
what consider means uh
in fact there seems to be suggestion now
and and at least rhetoric now that
that's
sort of a detailed course benefit
analysis weighing every conceivable
option etc which goes far beyond the
literal term consider
but can you talk about your role in
providing that kind of analysis you
alluded to it in your
open remarks but and also
if you have a practice practical
difficulty of getting cooperation from
market participants and giving you the
data you need
which sort of sets up a catch-22
you can't do the analysis to promulgate
the regulation unless you get
cooperation you don't get cooperation so
now you're vulnerable for a challenge
can you comment
yes chairman like comment um as you can
imagine the recent ruling on the proxy
access case um
provides significant challenges to the
division sort of reassessing the way it
conducts cost-benefit analysis i think
the
d.c circuit court clearly took issues
with the way cost-benefit analysis has
been conducted historically at the sec
and but and there are lessons i think i
think what they're really asking us is
to take a look at the way you actually
conduct cost benefit analysis and
the big takeaway from a lot of the
recent decisions in my opinion is we
need to provide a more fulsome
discussion of all the various
alternatives that are on the table a
folsom cost-benefit analysis around the
proposed rule but also around viable
alternatives to the rule
one and part of that will be to provide
a complete discussion not only of the
costs and benefits that we're able to
quantify but of the qualitative costs
and benefits and that's really one of
the rubs in trying to analyze
cost-benefit analysis is that so many of
the benefits that are associated with a
particular rule simply don't lend
themselves to regular ready
quantification and it's really not
feasible
in a lot of situations i think the other
takeaway from the proxy axis decision is
that while there's a currently the
typical practice is to involve the
the phd economist at the sec at very
early stages in the rule making process
i think we need to formalize that
process and bring them in in a more
formal prescriptive way
any comment about access to information
from proprietary information that could
be decisive in your analysis
yes that that that is one of the the
challenges we face because to quantify
benefits or costs associated with the
rule
you have to avail yourself to data
and if data is not publicly available
many times the only way you can get it
is to
try to
request the data through the comment
period process from market participants
and and so we when we propose rules we
frequently will design questions that
are designed to give us the data but
you've you've mentioned a real problem
with that process is that
frequently there aren't the incentives
to provide the data on the part of
market participants so if you don't get
that data it's very difficult to do the
subsequent analysis thank you very much
uh i want to begin with
ms rominger
in this question but i'd like all the
panel to to weigh in if appropriate and
that is that
so much of what you do depends on sort
of having a feel for the marketplace
real time information data intelligence
and particularly with your supervision
of mutual funds one of the the issues
today is sweeping across the atlantic is
our sovereign wealth funds and who's
holding what et cetera
can you just comment general terms about
[Music]
how you deal with
making sure you have access to the most
relevant information in real time
to to make these judgments to supervise
in your case mutual funds but in the
case of others investment advisors
broker dealers etc and you can begin mr
um
robinson
start by saying uh uh maybe giving an
example of where having additional
information uh has been very helpful to
us and that's in the area of money
market fund uh regulation
uh and oversight money market funds as i
mentioned in my opening comments um have
a structural fragility and that they're
susceptible to runs as we saw in
september 2008
uh and in the first round of money
market fund reform early in early in
2010
there was a requirement put in place for
money market funds to disclose holdings
information to the sec on a monthly
basis
and we've started receiving that
information exactly a year ago so at the
end of november uh 2010
uh and so you know we now have uh
monthly uh holdings for money market
funds so this is i think an instance
where having that data has provided us
very important information with respect
to the way these funds are structured
and the implications of that with
respect to systemic risk and so it's a
subject of much uh conversation uh
amongst the sec
and and other regulators who are
involved in systemic risk work so i
think that's a very you know good
example of where it's been put to good
purpose
i think from uh as as i uh look at our
responsibilities and think about you
know where our greatest needs are i
think it's with respect
to uh to experts technical experts
market experts uh experts in analyzing
uh complex financial strategies
i think that um the chairman uh has
identified that as an area of uh
increasing focus and increasing uh
resource need for the sec and that is
certainly true in the investment
management division
mr kokyo comments from your perspective
yes sir um in terms of access to data as
i um indicate in my opening remarks one
of the
key challenges we face in monitoring the
securities markets the the listed equity
markets in particular is just the
enormous volume of data that's there and
the relatively
significant gap between our access and
ability to analyze that data
and
in an efficient way so
we are
working on a number of initiatives to
try to narrow that gap i'd say part of
it is a rule making process to
to make sure that there are the rules in
place or a structure in place to get
that data to the regulators that would
be for example the consolidated audit
trail the large trader reporting system
where we will have better access to data
but the second piece of it really is
having the resources internally to be
able to make something of that data so
we're working closely with our
colleagues in other divisions for
example when it comes to the
consolidated audit trail to make sure
that what we're designing
is going to be useful for the
examination program for the enforcement
program as well as our own market
oversight program but it requires both
people and technology to ultimately
realize the uh the promise of some of
these uh
data enhancement initiatives another key
one that we're working on is in the
swaps markets and there we are
have a regime for the reporting of all
swaps
to data repositories
but that will both
present opportunities and challenges for
us again in terms of having greater
access to information but now we need
the people and the technology to be able
to leverage that information and be more
effective regulators
mr durio
i would just add chairman reid that
there's been a tremendous amount of
improvement i think with the division of
risk strategy and financial innovation
to really help the sec think about
taking in
significant amounts of data and doing
more sophisticated analytics around that
data
that's been very helpful for instance
with us on the examination program to
make sure that we're agile and we're not
planning our exams based on old data but
taking in new data doing analytics and
as we learn about trends or risks being
agile and directing our efforts there
it's also been helpful to work with the
division of investment management and
the division of trading and markets to
say what's data that we might be able to
gather through the exam program because
we're in the field every day
and we've i think strengthened our
ability and our coordination to be able
to have dialogues with the firms around
specific data that we think we need for
instance exposure to europe so that we
can not only get data
in a raw form but then have the critical
dialogues that we need to have with the
firms to have it make sense and have us
be able to have a significant risk
response to that data
is the lowest miscross
[Music]
i would note in the division of
corporation finance what we have focused
uh our resources on recently in the
review program
is looking at the largest companies on a
real-time basis so
historically we would have looked picked
them up once a year looked at their
filing given them some comments and and
perhaps moved on after they responded
and what we have figured out is that if
we if we have our accountants and
lawyers looking at most of what they say
and do over the course of the year
we're able to pick up trends and
improve the disclosures across whole
areas of industry based on what we're
seeing with the leading companies and i
think this has been a great innovation
in the division and we hope to do more
of it um because i think that's much
more valuable than the episodic picking
up a company looking at us filing and
giving out some comments all right this
is louis your comments and then mr
kazuni yes i could just give an example
of the cooperation collaborative effort
we've had with with carlos division and
what we have done is we have taken
the data initiative
in my division and the idea is to build
risk assessment tools that can be used
to
essentially score investment management
companies as to certain classes of risk
and so we take we're taking a layered
approach and what we do is we begin by
discussing what the needs are in the
division finding out what the key risks
are that they face and starting with
fairly simple models that just perform
basic screening of filers and the idea
is as we learn more about the risks in
the space we develop increasingly
sophisticated analytic models so we move
from screening techniques to let's say
regression based techniques and
in that order thank you mr any comments
from the enforcement perspective it's
slightly different but um same theme you
know we uh we do everything that we can
um to get access to data and to analyze
it but we are
um seriously behind the curve and our
ability to do that i mean if you want
uh you know if you want to conduct a
thorough and proper insider trading
investigation and make sure
you get all the parties who may be
involved in an illicit scheme you know
you'd love to have ready access to all
equity trading data and derivatives data
and debt data and overlay a chronology
of market moving events and you'd be
able to see patterns and trends you know
we're trying to do some of that but it
is difficult we need better tools not
only in analytics but to be able to
upload information and manipulate data
to investigate it it can take
weeks and even months to upload the
massive amount of electronic information
we get in our investigation and we don't
have the the proper tools in order to be
able to analyze it the way we'd like to
let me uh i have two
final questions but uh senator mark do
you have additional questions let me
recognize you now and then
and take your time and then i'll
conclude i hope quickly okay thank you
mr chair i wanted to continue this
conversation about information but
really focus on on derivatives
and um
certainly we didn't have a very good
understanding of uh the the writing of
derivatives here in the united states
and i'm not sure that we have a very
good uh understanding of it currently
abroad
conversations with some of the uh
experts from our own rating companies
have uh generated kind of the response
of
no we don't really understand who's
writing who's holding what the how the
dominoes are set up regarding
europe and of course a lot of a lot of
uh credit default swaps are are being
written on a host of uh
of european uh
firms and uh sovereign debt and
so i wanted to start by i realized this
is a this is a world where
the credit default the the swap world is
so divided uh with interest in foreign
exchange swaps on the cftc side uh
equity swaps um
on the sec side so you all have a piece
of this this this picture but
let me say what do we know about uh
european
credit default swaps
um
how do how do and if we don't know
enough
how what needs to change
so now maybe i could start with that and
then invite mr lewis to comment a little
bit um
the uh um
the primary entities that we regulate um
that would be likely to take on direct
exposures to this uh at least in my
world are the broker-dealers um
and anecdotally and through finra you
know our impression is it's not
significant exposure to credit defaults
officer capital rules that make it um
uh uh expensive to book a credit default
swap in a broker dealer
however
obviously those
transactions can be booked at other
entities um that are also of general
regulatory interest whether they're
banks or holding companies or financial
institutions
and other regulators may have access uh
to some of that information as well but
i think the
overall there is a a a gap in our
knowledge of this and i think the
the solution
that we're working on
in the cftc is as well
is the development of a mandatory trade
reporting regime pursuant to title vii
of the dodd-frank act which would
require
all swap transactions to be reported to
a data repository
and there's a uh
that would be available to regulators
there's a separate piece about that
reporting out to the marketplace which
is a sort of a transparency piece but in
terms of prudential
um sort of systemic oversight of
the markets and the risks
uh the um let me hold you on for just a
second there on that repository when do
we expect to have it up and operating
well we don't have a
we have our proposed rules out for the
data repository um and uh we would um as
i mentioned earlier we'll um
uh
we need to finish our proposal phase for
title seven and then begin adopting so i
think we'd like to see adoption of this
rule sometime in the next sometime in
2012 but i'm not exactly sure the uh the
the order in which we adopt these rules
is one of the things in which we want to
get uh public comment i will say though
that most parties we've spoken to have
suggested that this would be ought to be
one of the first things that we do
because it will enhance
the information that we have as
regulators about what's out there and
may help inform our uh rulemaking in
other areas of title and i will say in
the context of what's going on in europe
uh it seems like a critical element and
it seems like one of the simpler
elements that ought to be able to be put
in place is there any parallel effort on
the european or or asian side
there are efforts to
develop data repositories and other
jurisdictions yes and and to some extent
some of this information is available
today through the trade warehouse that
um is operated in the u.s and
mr lewis's group has done some work in
analyzing some of that data
it's not complete and i think that's
what we're trying to get to is a
complete picture
so let me briefly tell you senator about
some of the work that my division has
done on the credit default swap data
that has been provided by the data
warehouse
one of the
one of the
projects that we have
worked on is to characterize
the
positions and exposures of the
participants in the swap market and one
of the i think takeaways that we have
going up through the data through june
of 2011 is that
in financial institutions have been
unwinding their exposures to greek to
the pig's debt to basically sovereign
european debt
one of the
issues i think that's critical if we
want to consider and evaluate systemic
risk is that we need to have a complete
picture of all the all the parties that
transact in this space and to give you
an example of why i think this is
important one of the experiments we
conducted in our group to see how
important this issue might be
is we looked at positions by only
considering u.s financial institutions
and u.s counterparties and then
but excluded
u.s affiliates
in foreign domiciles so
take an investment bank new york
investment bank consider their uk
affiliate
ignore those uk affiliate transactions
and you get a picture of what the
counterparty exposures are what the
positions look like across
counterparties gross exposures and net
and then
run the experiment again including all
the exposures by inc also including the
trades that occur in the international
affiliate or the foreign affiliates and
what we discovered was that positions or
exposures could could reverse so if you
look like you were a purchaser of
protection in the credit fault swap
market when you incorporated all the
affiliates that we all the transactions
we had actually access to you could
actually see the positions reversing
this is if we're going to manage
systemic risk i would advocate we need
to get all the trades not just the
trades that take place by
u.s banks and their affiliates but if
you want to measure systemic risk you
want to look at everybody who's in this
market so you can get a complete picture
of what the what the credit risk is like
how does the office of financial
research fit into this issue of of
understanding
the collective picture i've actually had
discussions with the office of financial
research and alerted them to this issue
and i believe that they are they're
actually working on it i probably
shouldn't
attribute workload to the office
financial research but it's certainly a
suggestion that i've made to them that
they they should investigate
thank you
thank you senator merkley and uh let me
just say that
they would even be more responsive if
they had a confirmed head
of the office of financial research so
that's a message to the
broader public
uh
final uh
question i think it's an important one
to ask and it's just really two parts
one is that there has been criticism
lodged against the sec about being too
close to the
institutions and the businesses that you
regulate
related as the issue of the of a
revolving door process
and i i would be one beginning with mr
deflourio comment on
how you sort of
deal with that in terms of
making sure that does not affect
the your your ability to
effectively perform your duties on
behalf of the public and then a related
question i asked this with trepidation
because one of my form of experience was
commanding a paratrooper company if
anybody asked
my company how the morale was i
shuddered a little bit in terms of what
they might say but you might also
indicate just
what you sense the morale is in your
division those are those two sort of
related issues sure
uh first senator reid we're very
cognizant of the revolving door issues
and have put in place a number of
significant controls
uh that really focus on that issue we
have an office that is of ethics that
reports directly to the chairman
and has a new head and is very
focused on ensuring that there are
effective policies and procedures there
are limitations on
how people can interact with the sec
once they leave the sec they need to
maintain that dialogue with the office
of ethics so there's a lot of rules both
civil and criminal that govern our
conduct with regard to the evolving door
in the exam program in addition to that
we have our own code of conduct that
adds additional requirements because we
want to make sure that examiners don't
present that conflict of interest
and there's additional controls that
require supervisors to be dialoguing
with individuals on their team involved
in various exams and make sure that
there aren't any conflicts or
relationships
i would make an observation on the flip
side
which is that we've been able to bring
in some terrific talent to the sec
that makes us relevant and current with
regard to
complex structured products derivatives
hedge funds because we're able to
recruit people who have their finger on
the pulse of industry practices and my
observation in my own view has been that
individuals that we've brought in with
industry expertise and experience have
been some of our most effective and
aggressive
examiners in because they understand the
games that registrants can play they're
very focused on
targeting our efforts exactly to those
high-risk points of interaction or
product and making sure that we're
identifying those issues so i think
when it works well the complement of our
talented and dedicated
existing team at the sec coupled with
incoming individuals from industry to
bring new expertise and experience
really strikes a terrific balance and
makes us more
effective in protecting investors
ensuring market integrity staying in
front of issues and being able to uh to
protect the markets and and investors
with regard to the second issue
on morale
you know i think that that's a terrific
question and something that we're very
focused on at the sec uh chairman
shapiro
has fostered a very open culture of
teamwork and collaboration and i think
that's stronger than it's probably ever
been at the sec
at the same time we have an incredible
workload with dodd-frank and requests
for more resources to help us meet that
workload and i think that tension can
create some morale challenges that we
need to be very cognizant of there's a
relationship between resources and
morale and an ability to do the job well
at the same time we've initiated
throughout the agency human capital
surveys to make sure that we're keeping
our finger on the pulse of morale what
are the root causes of morale concerns
or issues and putting in place action
plans every year that are monitored to
follow up on the morale issues and i
think that that's something that we all
need to make a priority and we do as
directors of the various divisions and
offices i know in the national exam
program
people culture and morale is one of our
top priorities this year
thank you mr lewis please any comments
with respect to the issue of morale or
or or
people coming in and out too close
you're you're somewhat removed because
of your analytical uh responsibilities
but
those two topics comments that you might
have well if i had to comment on the
revolving door i would say it's probably
a good thing for economists because they
basically go back to their academic
institutions when they revolve back out
and
actually
if we can
engage
financial economists in becoming
interested in regulation
it creates a lot more opportunity to see
research being conducted independent
research being conducted around our rule
making space so you could argue it's a
positive for my division
with respect to morale i've only been in
the office since june but i'd like to
think that things are going pretty well
right
[Music]
this rom jubilee
uh in the investment in the division of
investment management uh there are uh
there are very few
people in the division with the
exception of myself
who have come from the asset management
industry uh frankly i think we need
additional people from the industry it's
grown much more complex over time
some of the challenges we're facing
today are uh you know quite different
than the challenges that the division
faced uh five or ten years ago and with
that increase in complexity we you know
we need people on board who understand
how these instruments and how these
strategies actually work in the real
world and so uh we we absolutely must
have the correct protections in place to
make sure that we have the appropriate
uh distance as regulators but you know
we do need that expertise
uh so um with respect to uh morale um in
my uh nine months at the sec i found
that uh
that most of the people i work with are
are motivated to engage in public
service because of their strong desire
that they can make things better and
that is what drives them and um and
motivates them and and i think um you
know morale is is quite good because i i
think they um they get a sense that
there's a great deal of positive change
occurring in the agency right now thank
you
mr corp please
thank you i think the uh keeping in
touch with the markets and keeping up to
up to speed with what the latest
developments is is critical to our
effective implementation or
responsibilities we do that through a
variety of ways including the comment
process meetings with with market
participants but the ability to bring
in folks who've been on the other side
and have uh
know where uh the the issues lurk i
think is is pretty crucial i echo
comments of my colleagues about how it's
obviously crucial to manage the the
ethical obligations associated with that
but i think that uh that can be done
um and and done effectively and and i
think it's it's really enhanced and
enriched our uh ability to try to get
the rules right um in terms of morale i
would just add that i'm um
having come from outside of government
into government i am uh truly amazed by
the dedication of the staff and their
their their long hours they put in um uh
on the task that we give them uh the
productivity in our division is many
multiples of what it's been in some
prior years in terms of just the output
same number of people much more
being asked of them and it's truly
remarkable uh how far they're willing to
go i think to some extent this is why
they're there this is a great time to be
working at the agency and working on
these key issues but i would echo the
concerns have been mentioned already
about how
ultimately people do need to feel they
have the resources to do their jobs
effectively and
it's hard to take the hill if you don't
have the
you know the right equipment and
manpower absolutely of course
um i agree with everything that's been
said about the revolving door the the
fresh insights that come in from people
who've recently been in industry help us
do our job better um and we are
extremely careful about the ethical
concerns you've heard me mention
recusals today we
uh there's no there's no shame in saying
i can't work on something because i had
a contact with it on in my prior job and
and i think that's right that regularly
occurs and i think that's an important
if i may one of the concerns is not so
much people come in it's the people
going out
and i think on the going out front i
would say since i've done that right um
i think that the the overall the
investing public benefits because people
who've worked at the commission
have a have an appreciation of what it
is that that we're trying to do
and i think that sec alumni are
especially careful practitioners i think
they they go out and populate the
securities bar with people who want to
do the right thing that so i think
actually it's a a very positive
development um and and i would i would
hope it will continue
um on the morale point i'd like to i'd
like to echo what robert said about the
incredibly hard work the staff is
currently going through i
i worry sometimes they don't that we
don't say enough about how much we
appreciate them
you have to stop and take take a deep
breath and remember to do that a lot
because they've all been sacrificing um
their personal lives and and um to work
through the dodd-frank rule-making and
before that we were very busy in in my
division with rulemaking so it's been
flat out for two and a half years since
i've been there
and then on the review program i i'm
amazed every day at how
enthusiastic and fresh they remain in
when they pick up a company and they
look at the filing and they go search
the internet see what else the company
is saying and come up with good comments
that improve the disclosures and i think
that um you know i i hope morale is good
you know it's hard to know with with as
many people as we have but i i'd say
that um i know i appreciate how hard
they're working
thank you mr kusami
yes thank you mr chairman uh
i agree with the sentiments expressed
here um with respect to
the expertise it is critically important
you know it wasn't um very long ago at
all that everyone was criticizing the
sec for lacking the expertise in order
to deal with complex products and
transactions and markets and we have
done that and
we have you know as good if not better
set of ethical restrictions on the way
out with respect to permanent bans on
involvement in matters
that you participated in once you leave
two-year ban on being involved in
matters that you supervised and just
down the line a great deal of
restrictions
and second of all um
you know in my experience both in the
department of justice uh and here um
particularly the sec
the ability of one person even if they
were so inclined
not to do anything other than follow a
case on its merits and make a
recommendation and decision and take
investigative steps that were in the
best interest of the case
virtually impossible to do we work in
teams with with great levels of review
by multiple people
thorough oversight
you know one person
would be very difficult for one person
to do that even if they were so inclined
and i haven't met such a person in
addition
that's not the way you gain you would
gain any respect within the within the
enforcement division and within the
commission you're respected if you are
hard driving and thorough and
professional and disciplined and
intelligent and to do anything else um
uh uh hurts your reputation hurts your
ability in the outside world when and if
you were to leave and lastly the people
who leave the sec are really ambassadors
for compliance
and good practices i mean they go to
firms and they advise clients and they
know
um the consequences of what can happen
if they cross the line and we have to
leverage those people so that you know
some ceo who may be inclined to to take
a shortcut will listen to their general
accounts or their compliance officers
here's what can happen to you here's
what the sec might do if you don't act
appropriately so i think it's a win-win
um all the way around gao looked at our
revolving door issues as part of
dodd-frank and came away with the single
recommendation that we should better
document our ethics advice
and so i think all in all um the
arrangement is is the right one for
investors but specter morale
look people work incredibly hard and are
incredibly committed uh the
undifferentiated criticism that
sometimes occurs takes its toll quite
honestly
people are not afraid of being told that
they can do things better
we restructured the entire enforcement
division people responded in a way that
is in the is in the best traditions of
anybody in the public or private sector
you know ignore the ignore you know
don't shoot the messenger look at what's
the right thing to do make changes that
are necessary that's occurred up and
down throughout the division
what will happen is eventually if the
market turns
and
people
don't have the resources they need you
know they'll be more attracted to jobs
on the outside and that would be a
terrible
i think result for investor protection
and our efforts because
our employees are highly valued and
experienced they want to be at the sec
they want to be public servants it can
be difficult if you're at the xerox
machine at 11 o'clock at night
photocopying your own you know trial
exhibits that's what happens
well thank you all very very much uh
today for not only for your thoughtful
responses and testimony but for your
dedicated public service and
particularly your patients uh uh thank
you all uh if members uh
my colleagues have their own written
statements or additional questions for
witnesses that they should be submitted
no later than
next wednesday november 23rd
and i would ask the panel to respond as
quickly as possible any written
questions you may receive
all the written testimony that you've
submitted will become part of the record
and
again i thank you for your service and
for your testimony this morning with
that the hearing's adjourned
[Music]
hi
hi this
is um
up next on c span 2 our interview with
national review contributing editor.org
or tweet us at twitter.com
booktv
and now on book tv laurie sandel
recounts the fallout from bernie
madoff's ponzi scheme and the effect it
had on his family the author was given
access to all members of the madoff
family and reports how mr madoff's two
sons andrew and mark and his wife ruth
reacted to bernie madoff's illegal
activities this is about half an hour
hello
i'm diane leslie and i'm
here to welcome you to diesel a
bookstore
when
the information broke i guess i saw it
in the new york times
about
the i don't even know what to call it
the um
the the
mad
madoff
debacle the made of scandal i it was so
shocking and so fascinating and i don't
think since watergate was i rushing to
get the paper every day to read the next
episode of what had happened
so as the story unfolded
i was thinking well this is like a greek
tragedy this is amazing and you know if
only we had escalus here to write about
it and then later on as we got more and
more information and the victims we
started seeing what happened to uh some
of the people who invested with the
madoffs we i started thinking no
shakespeare should have done this
this only shakespeare could write this
fully
well
now
sometime later
three years later
here we are
and
i came across lori sundell's book
and i want to say
that it's utterly fascinating i mean we
thought we knew everything
but we didn't and just reading
about
the family and finding out that
even though bernie madoff is kind of
absent from the book because you didn't
interview him but you
at least i as a reader i will say i
realized this man was a bully and he
bullied his wife and sons and so they
got to the point that they were afraid
to ask him questions he they certainly
never he didn't answer
their questions
um
and so there's a whole psychological
element that laurie managed to get into
this book
that
just was never in the newspapers
and i want to say that i think
the madoff family was
incredibly lucky
to pick lori sandell because of all the
possible journalists who could have
written this book she is the best
because she herself
grew up with
a con man in her life
so i now present to you
someone who really knows what she's
talking about lori sandel
[Applause]
thank you so much for that very generous
and wonderful introduction and thank you
diesel a bookstore for having me today
um i just want to tell you a little bit
about how this book came to be and then
i'm going to read a chapter from the
book
in 2009 september of 2009 a book that i
had written called the imposter's
daughter about my own father and his
cons and his deceptions came out and i
was reading from it at a bookstore much
like this one and uh backstage signing
books a woman approached me and said you
know i can't believe you're here i can't
believe your story and introduced
herself as the fiance of andrew madoff
that of course my jaw dropped this was a
year after the scandal and it was
completely just mind-blowing and i've
been following it like everybody else
and
um i came to know the family over the
course of two years
uh like so many people that had been
following the story i
of course thought that andrew was most
likely involved that he and his brother
had known all about his father's fraud i
was convinced that ruth had to have
known and it was only really brilliant
curiosity that sort of brought me into
this story i was a journalist and i
wanted to get to the truth of this story
like every other journalist out there
and most of the people in the public and
so when i was you know when it came time
that they were ready to write a book and
i sat down with them and was taken into
the heart of their story i was
absolutely astonished to find that
nothing i thought i knew was true
um so i'm just going to read to you from
the chapter of the confession itself
and uh and there we'll go
the confession
by 6 50 a.m andrew and mark were once
again perched in the conference room
behind the trading floor they shot each
other tense worried looks periodically
breaking the silence to speculate or to
offer a new theory one thing they knew
something was terribly wrong
by eight o'clock am peter still hadn't
arrived mark shook his head let's wait
at our desks
ruth according to court filings had
taken out some 15 million in two
separate withdrawals from her comad
brokerage account in the prior three
weeks
bernie had asked her to move the money
into her wachovia bank account so he
could use it to cover redemptions
she did his bidding unquestioningly
something that the media claimed as
proof of her involvement but then the
family moved millions of dollars around
all the time buying boats and apartments
making large wire transfers and
multi-million dollar donations to
philanthropic organizations
had ruth questioned bernie's directive
andrew says bernie would have barked at
her and that would have been the end of
the conversation
it wasn't until 9 20 am that andrew
spotted peter making his way across the
trading floor peter is bernie's brother
he signaled to mark and they hurried
into the conference room as andrew took
his seat he felt the back of his neck
grow hot with anticipation
peter stood by the door his mouth a grim
line i talked to your father it's bad he
wants to talk to you himself he said
andrew's stomach dropped
he knew that his uncle tended to put a
positive spin on things
the brothers pushed their chairs back
and followed their uncle onto the
trading floor they passed their
colleagues shouting orders at their
desks a row of administrative offices a
cluster of secretaries a large
conference room the walk seemed to take
forever
when they arrived at bernie's glass
walled executive office they found him
sitting behind his desk leaning back in
his chair staring at a television set
mounted on the ceiling
he didn't greet them or even acknowledge
their arrival
andrew and peter took the two chairs
facing bernie mark sat on the couch to
the left of his desk for a few minutes
the four sat intense silence
i don't know where to start bernie
finally began his voice caught in his
throat and tears started to well up in
his eyes
andrew felt a river of alarm rise
through his chest he glanced at mark he
was studying bernie intensely
let's not do this right at your main
desk peter suggested let's move to the
table in the corner
the four gathered around a small
conference table at the far end of the
room where a wall offered a shade more
privacy
again
bernie started to talk and couldn't
continue
dumbfounded andrew watched his father
struggle for words
i can't do this here bernie finally said
andrew looked at his father feeling as
though he had entered quote the world of
the surreal
what could possibly be so bad that he
couldn't even discuss it at the office
why don't we go to your apartment andrew
suggested are we all going up there mark
asked bernie cleared his throat no peter
you stay here and run the show while we
go up to the apartment peter nodded and
left the office the coat closet was
right outside bernie's office
as the three struggled into their winter
gear bernie said to his secretary
eleanor havely bring the car around
where the hell are you going the market
is open eleanor joked liking to bust her
boss's chops from time to time mind your
own business bernie snapped immediately
silencing eleanor who stared at her
computer
andrew mark and bernie rode the elevator
down in silence then waited for lee in
the vast lobby of the lipstick building
watching the rain streak across the
revolving doors there was no small talk
andrew tried to blend into his
surroundings wishing he could be
teleported to his parents apartment so
he could get whatever was going to
happen over with the anticipation was
unbearable
the car pulled up front driven by clive
not lee again they rode in silence
bernie sandwiched between his two sons
in the back seat misty-eyed and shaken
struggling to hold it together as though
he'd already received bad news and was
trying to cope with it andrew says
andrew stared out the window at the
early christmas shoppers his brain a
dead zone
clive dropped them off on 64th street in
front of the entrance to ruth and
bernie's penthouse apartment
the three rode up to the 11th floor
entrance then removed their wet shoes in
the foyer obeying bernie's shoes off
rule
they laid their coats across the
banister of the staircase taking care
not to drip water onto the floor ruth
greeted them at the door her face grim
she too had no idea why her husband had
rushed home in the middle of the day to
talk to his family but like her sons she
suspected the news was bad somehow
connected to the mayhem on wall street
bernie had called her from the office
and said i have something to tell you i
can't tell you on the phone i'm coming
home with the boys
she'd gotten off the phone shaking and
had waited for them in the kitchen
together the family entered the sitting
room a forbidding room that andrew had
never liked with dark green walls khaki
carpeting dark leather club chairs and a
heavy desk bernie sat by himself on a
large leather sofa
ruth sat on a club chair next to the
couch
andrew took the ottoman and marked the
desk chair the four faced one another
sitting a considerable distance apart
i don't know where to start bernie began
again he started to sob the firm is
insolvent i'm broke
how is that possible andrew asked i
don't understand the money is gone it's
over
i don't understand andrew repeated how
can that be we're having an okay year
what happened is this about the
redemptions
then bernie said something more terrible
than they could have imagined it's all
been one big lie it's a giant ponzi
scheme and it's been going on for years
and there have been all these
redemptions and i can't keep it going
anymore i can't do it
andrew stared at his father a mind his
mind a jumble of disconnected thoughts
and phrases
he was trying to piece together what his
father was saying but the sentences kept
evaporating he grabbed at them
frustrated as they continued to
disappear
ruth lit a cigarette her hand shook
what's a ponzi scheme
it means the asset management business
was a fake andrew said
i've been lying to all of you for years
i've been lying to your mother i've been
lying to you i've been lying to the
customers i've been lying to myself
i have an appointment to meet with ike
sorkin on monday bernie continued
returning referring to the family lawyer
and i'm probably going to jail he broke
down then really sobbing
andrew rose from the ottoman crossed the
room and awkwardly draped an arm around
his father for a few seconds at that
andrew started to cry too
he got up and returned to the ottoman
through his tears he said but there was
all this money where did it go
the money is gone i've got 50 billion in
liabilities his voice trailed off andrew
stopped 50 million 50 billion
andrew now glanced at his brother who
hadn't yet said a word he recognized
that look mark's face was red his jaw
clenched a vein worked in his temple
i still don't understand how is all this
going to unfold andrew asked his mind
racing to process what it all meant how
it was going to affect him what was
going to happen
i've got 100 million in cash left there
are certain accounts i'm going to redeem
with that money friends and family i
have a large redemption coming next week
that's when it's all going to unravel
what are all these people going to do
dad what about susie west andrew asked
referring to his widowed mother-in-law
who'd invested her life savings with him
what about roger's widow jen are they
going to get their money back i'm doing
my best i have a list of people wait
andrew interrupted how can you even do
that they're not going to get to keep
that money they will bernie explained
and patiently started to outline other
situations where firms had failed and
investors were made whole
andrew stopped him sickened not wanting
to hear more how long has this been
going on oh god it's been going on for
years
much has been made of when the fraud
started and the truth is no one really
knows bernie started the firm in the 60s
when computers weren't even in use the
records from that time are thin
even modern regulatory requirements
don't require records that go beyond six
years
bernie claims his ponzi scheme began in
1992 that any questionable behavior he
engaged in before then was at worst a
gray area involving synthetic trades to
defray income tax costs for his most
important clients
and there is evidence that he executed
actual trades into the 80s but whether
the original ponzi scheme started when
bernie said it did or much earlier only
bernie knows
and what about me and my family dad
what's going to happen to us
i've been doing the math bernie said
i've been looking through all the
records and at the end of the day the
amount of money i've taken in and paid
out over the years is about a wash
mark stood up this is [ __ ] he yelled
and stormed out of the room
i'm going with him andrew said and and
ran after his brother
mark was in the foyer fumbling with his
shoes yanking his coat over his arms i'm
leaving he repeated okay let's go andrew
said he followed his brother into the
elevator and out into the fall drizzle
clive stuck his head out the window what
am i doing andrew shouted into the wind
the old man is still upstairs you're
waiting for him
mark had already stepped off the curb
and inhaled the cab andrew slid onto the
seat next to his brother the cab driver
turned around where to
just drive andrew instructed the driver
started to inch down lexington avenue
which was congested with cars andrew
felt grateful it would buy him time to
think
he turned to mark what do we do
we need a lawyer right now how what do
we do walk into the lobby of skatin arps
and scream help andrew asked referring
to the white shoe firm famous in
corporate law
no we need a real lawyer a criminal
defense one let's call marty he'll know
what to do
mark's father-in-law marty london was a
retired senior litigator at paul weiss
he'd represented spiro agnew during the
watergate trials and jackie kennedy in
her lawsuit against ron galella he and
his wife pinks were staying at the
beekman tower hotel while their
apartment was being renovated
mark leaned into the partition
take us to 49th street and first avenue
the cab turned left as mark punched a
number into his cell phone
stephanie what are you doing right now
you're with susan blumenfeld get her out
of there he listened his face growing
red make an excuse just get her out of
there he hung up the phone
mark and andrew rode the west the rest
of the way in silence each in his own
world of fear
[Music]
ruth sat at the banquette in her kitchen
smoking one cigarette after another
bernie had returned to the office
there had been no agonizing embraces or
recriminations
he told her that he had two more checks
to deposit that he was planning to go to
the office in the morning to pay the
traders she'd nodded numley yes yes okay
after he left she sat there a complete
zombie eventually she rose and made her
way into the bedroom to dress for the
office christmas party which was
scheduled for that night
at rosa mexicano for the occasion she'd
bought a black prada blouse tailored
like a man's shirt with silver detailing
on the collar
as she fumbled with the small buttons
her fingers trembling she had the
thought i'll never wear this again
she paired it with a black skirt that
fell just below the knee and a pair of
tall suede boots with a heel she'd never
liked her legs
the thought of not attending the
christmas party didn't cross bruce mind
of course she and bernie were going
before he'd left bernie had said we have
to show up and act like everything is
fine
yes she'd nodded again numbly yes okay
it was noon when andrew and mark entered
marty london's suite at the beekman
tower though andrew felt as though he'd
been slogging through that day for a
year
a pile of suitcases sat by the front
door marty greeted them what happened
what the hell is going on
mark strode passed his father-in-law
into the room andrew followed now it was
mark's turn to do the talking
my father just confessed to a huge crime
he said his whole business is a ponzi
scheme that the firm is insolvent and
there's 50 billion missing
50 million marty asked no 50 billion
mark said in what would become a refrain
marty paused oh boy i need to sit down
my whole retirement fund is with him
he recovered himself but that's not
important tell me everything he said
andrew and mark repeated everything they
could remember about the conversation
they'd had with their father
do you think he's sane do you think he
was telling you the truth well yeah
andrew said he wasn't just rambling he
wasn't having a psychotic break
marty sank into a chair by the dining
room table this is incredible okay we
need flumenbaum who mark asked marty
flumenbaum he's a firm senior litigator
and the only guy you want to talk to in
this situation he's got a ton of
experience
he picked up the phone and called his
firm get me flume and baum
after waiting on hold for a few minutes
marty heard flim and bowman sir and he
launched into an abbreviated description
of the day's events i've got my
son-in-law and his brother here and
they've just given me this incredible
story i need to see you right now it's
urgent how quickly can you get here
fluent bound press for details i'm up in
connecticut litigating a case i can't
come straight there can you give me more
information
his father just confessed to a huge
crime and we need to talk about it right
away he urged okay i can be there by 3
p.m
marty turned to mark and andrew who by
then we're looking at him as their
savior okay he's going to come with his
associate andrew ehrlich he's the firm's
newest partner one of the rising stars
in the litigation area the two of them
are perfect do what you've got to do and
let's meet back here at 3 pm
andrew and mark left the beekman tower
they stood on the street feeling lost
they had two hours to kill finally mark
said i'm going home i've got to talk to
stephanie all right andrew said i'm
going back to the office
he walked back to the lipstick building
as he passed through the training room
he saw his colleagues on the proprietary
trading side of the floor working the
phones some were yelling others joking
around on the market-making side traders
worked diligently at their desks
frowning absorbing numbers andrew stared
at the unfamiliar moonscape of their
desks
he entered his office his days had
always been spent at his desk
on the trading floor and his private
office wasn't a place where he spent
lots of time he might enter it in the
morning put his briefcase down hang his
coat on the door and take a conference
call for the energy business now he just
sat down and stared into space peter
popped his head in the door are you okay
no i'm not okay yeah i know i know this
is awful what are you doing
mark and i are meeting with an attorney
at 3 p.m okay peter slipped away
andrew sat staring at the pictures of
his kids on the credenza behind his desk
and at the various awards and honors
he'd received during his 20 years in the
business
drained frightened and exhausted more
than anything he was trying to
understand what had happened 50 billion
dollars the number didn't register it
was inconceivable were it true it would
make blm's asset management business one
of the largest headphones in the world
bridgewater soros renaissance none of
them was even close to that size
he turned the day's events over and over
in his head playing and replaying the
conversations
his phone rang it was catherine his
fiance should i get my hair done or not
she asked sounding as if she were a
million miles away andrew had no idea
what she was talking about your hair he
struggled to remember if they'd spoken
then vaguely recalled texting her for
the party are we going oh yeah yes we're
going i think i have to run
he walked out of his office without
knowing that the next time he would
return would be six months later
accompanied by his attorneys and the fbi
so he could recover his personal effects
marty flumenbaum and andrew ehrlich
arrived at 3pm sharp fluminbaum was
short and stout in his 50s with a side
part and glasses ehrlich was tall
slender and young
the lawyers shrugged their arms out of
their raincoats both were wearing suits
and ties
marty london immediately started to
recap the story for his colleagues are
you familiar with bernie madoff the boys
just told me this incredible story that
he's running a ponzi scheme to the tune
of 50 billion dollars
50 million asked flumenbaum billion with
a b
do you think he was sane was he telling
the truth he asked repeating the same
questions london had posed
no one from family members to the top
lawyers in the country could wrap their
head around that figure it would dwarf
the worldcom scandal which involved 11
billion it would mean bernie madoff had
committed the biggest financial fraud in
history
over the next hour flumenbaum asked
andrew and mark to describe in depth who
they were their jobs at the firm their
relationships to their parents their
wives
he asked them repeatedly if they were
involved in the fraud we had no idea
they kept repeating none whatsoever we
were completely blindsided
they wrapped up the story and flumenbaum
closed his notebook
we need to report this and i'm not even
precisely sure how to do that we have a
new partner at the firm who came on
board from the sec i want to bring him
in and get his thoughts on this flume
and bound picked up the phone
the clock was ticking it was already
five o'clock p.m soon the sec's offices
would close they needed to get someone
on the phone but it had to be the right
person
fleming mem turned to andrew and mark
are you both comfortable doing this he
asked there was a clear sense that
flumenbaum was in charge he knew the
right thing to do and wasn't going to
give them any other option but to do it
yes let's do it andrew said let's do it
mark repeated andrew looked at his
brother we're doing the right thing mark
nodded
reflecting on that moment today andrew
says i would love to say that mark and i
were waving the flags of justice in the
air but the bottom line is we were
absolutely terrified we knew that what
we were doing was going to send our
father to jail and the feeling was awful
absolutely awful
give me a minute andrew said
he walked out of the living room and
into the bedroom feeling his knees
crumble as he crossed the threshold
sinking to the ground holding onto a
radiator he let out enormous racking
sobs that tore through his chest and
burned his throat guttural animal sounds
so alien he wasn't even sure they'd come
from him
doubling over he clenched his stomach
trying not to vomit
when the saab subsided he wiped away his
tears roughly with the back of his hand
and stood up on wobbly legs he cleared
his throat returned to the living room
and sat down
pulling out his phone he sent catherine
a text we're definitely not going
tonight then he turned to flumenbaum
make the call he said
uh with instructions to share nothing
with their wives andrew and mark left
the hotel suite without exchanging a
word they got into separate cabs andrew
headed uptown to the apartment he'd
moved into two days earlier he walked in
the front door turned into his bedroom
and laid down on top of the bed he was
still wearing his overcoat suit and
shoes for the next four hours he lay
there completely numb while a live feed
ran across his brain i've just turned my
father in for securities fraud he's
going to go to jail i have no idea
what's going to happen with my life my
entire family is invested with him every
friend many of the employees at the firm
everyone i know who knows how many
others i just turned my father in for
securities fraud he's going to go to
jail
as andrew stared at the ceiling he
wracked his brain for some inkling he
could have seen this coming how could he
possibly have missed something this big
but nothing came other than the image of
his father rotting in jail because he
and his brother had turned him in
he had no idea how much time had passed
before catherine slipped into the room
she sat down on the edge of the bed an
innocent woman with a beautiful daughter
who brought so much joy into his life he
couldn't allow her to get sucked into
this frenzy it wasn't fair to her she
waited her huge blue eyes searching his
her last moment of not knowing he
couldn't bear the thought of living if
she left he couldn't ask her to stay
andrew set up leaned over and turned on
the light you need to decide whether or
not you want to stay with me he doesn't
remember what he said after that but
when andrew and catherine crawled under
the covers at the conclusion of the
longest most painful day of his life
catherine said something that would be
forever seared into his memory listen
i'm not going anywhere wake me up if you
need me i'll be here all night
she wrapped her arms around him her
cheek resting against his back
in that moment he says those words saved
his life he wouldn't have to face this
alone
he has said those same words back to her
every night since
weeks after bernie and ruth celebrated
their 49th year of marriage the couple
went to the office christmas party in a
daze ruth put one foot in front of the
other smiled had a glass of wine and
left beyond that she doesn't remember a
thing
the evening was lost forever to trauma
and terror she has no interest in
getting it back
the only memory she cannot erase is the
image of her son mark fleeing from her
home the golden child the mama's boy who
called her every day from college who'd
given her three beautiful grandchildren
and had one on the way
it is the image of his back that is
burned into her brain since it is the
last vision ruth would ever have of her
son she never saw him again
that's it
[Applause]
and i'm
happy to take questions if anybody has
questions about absolutely anything
i'll just start with the obvious
questions okay
has anyone given
to bernie
well that's a very good question
actually has any bernie madoff of course
is serving 150 years in prison at butner
correctional center um
and andrew has vowed never to speak to
his father again and um has no knowledge
also ruth changed her number recently so
bernie couldn't get in touch with her
and we have no knowledge of whether he's
read the book but we would of course
assume that he has read the book and
will read the book because he's been
very involved in anything that comes out
about him he reads that he comments on
it
so we'll see
i'm waiting
i'm pursuing an interview with him
actually so we'll see
a new book
well an article magazine article
okay um can you tell us any uh
interesting uh things that have happened
as you've promoted the book or
people comment came up to you or
anything like that
that's a great question um
basically it has been a very interesting
experience since the book came out
you know i i wasn't sure obviously this
is an authorized biography um
i would not put my name on the book if i
didn't believe entirely in its contents
but it is a book that is sympathetic to
the relatives of bernie madoff and
given how to the extent to which
people's lives were destroyed um you
know there's so much anger so much
vitriol so much hatred so much sadness i
mean there's just so much wrapped around
this story
that a lot of people have been unable to
separate you know bernie's family from
bernie himself and i thought that there
would probably be a lot of outcry and
there has been a lot of outcry on the
internet um i haven't personally been
you know accosted or anything like that
there's also been you know very
interestingly a lot of people that have
had their minds changed i mean the night
before my book came out 60 minutes did a
piece on the book and on andrew and ruth
madoff and
a lot of people had their minds changed
as a result of that 60 minutes piece and
andrew and catherine who have started an
emergency preparedness business called
black umbrella have gotten you know
hundreds of letters from people saying
that happened to me too obviously on a
smaller scale but um so there's been a
surprising kind of amount of that as
well and they have had
literally you know from the general
public at large from the media there's
been no support you know leading up to
this because people just automatically
assumed that they were involved as i
assumed until i really spent significant
time with them
when you were approached to write the
book what was your initial reaction
well i wasn't actually approached to
write the book i it happened much more
organically than that um like i had read
from a book i had written about my own
imposter father
uh the fiance of andrew had randomly was
at my reading and
wanted to spend time with me and the
first couple of dinners that i had with
them i actually had spent thanksgiving
at their house the first thanksgiving
after the scandal
and i mean i'm estranged from my own
father for very similar reasons and i
wasn't going to thanksgiving at my house
and they invited me to thanksgiving at
their house and of course as a
journalist i was completely curious
about what it was going to be like
and you know it was very interesting i
mean there were a lot of new friends
that they had made since the scandal
mark was not there there's a huge rift
between the brothers that i go into in
great detail in the book but i had no
idea about that until you know i got to
know them but um
after two years they were finally ready
to tell their story and finally allowed
to tell their story because there's been
ongoing settlements they've been muzzled
by lawyers
and at that point it was just obvious
that i was going to be the person who
was going to sit down with them but even
two years into my acquaintanceship with
them i was not at all convinced of
andrew's you know innocence and it
really wasn't until i sat down with him
and he gave me such a detailed
explanation about the way the businesses
are separate the fact that um they were
completely you know investigated by the
government their files every single
computer file everything was taken apart
they were never indicted
um the people that are you know ready
that are in jail or awaiting trial would
have every reason in the world to turn
in the brothers or ruth if they were
able to to get a reduction in their own
sentence and weren't able to do so so
there were many mitigating factors in
addition to the whole psychological
component that convinced me
i may be confused about this but is
there a book coming out being that's
going to be written by the fiance
no no no the fiance of andrew madoff no
no she participated extensively in this
book i see so this is a book she's
connected with yes yes um andrew
madoff's fiance catherine hooper is the
person who showed up at my reading in
2009
and she was instrumental in giving me
access to this family actually um you
know the family was completely
muzzled quiet not speaking to any press
whatsoever
i was really the first person that they
spoke to and that was the result of my
interactions with catherine
questions
hi i'm just i was curious as you uh
explored this story how did you did it
change how you thought about
your own father because i read your
other book and that was so great um and
i'm just wondering what is what the tie
is between the two that's such a great
question um
you know
i have not spoken to my father my father
hasn't spoken to me i should say since
2003
um when i first wrote a piece for
esquire about what i found out about my
father i wrote that piece anonymously
and that led to a graphic memoir that i
wrote and illustrated and
you know i of course it's a process
going through an estrangement with a
parent a separation a betrayal
and in the beginning you know i had all
of these feelings about my mother and my
feelings about my father and what was
really interesting for me was to sort of
watch them at the beginning of that
process themselves to see how much anger
you know andrew has against his father
to see how much anger he had against his
mother which is starting to abate you
know through the process of
time
talking with her hearing what she went
through during this whole thing because
andrew and his brother
left after the confession and
didn't speak to their parents again
until mark killed himself you know so
andrew had no contact with his mother
for two years
and so to watch him
do that
put my own story into perspective
and well you know i'm the anger towards
my father has long since abated and i
would speak to my father if he wanted to
speak to me you know i feel like it's a
process and i'm seven years into the
process and andrew's right at the
beginning of it so you know i've been
able to sort of talk to him about what
my experience was but you just have to
go through it and it takes time so
anyone have any other questions
no
okay well thank you very much for having
me
[Applause]
for more information visit the author's
website lauriesandell.com
is there a non-fiction author or book
you'd like to see featured on book tv
in the near future on book tv
and now the final live event from the
2012 tucson festival of books diana
henriquez will talk about her book the
wizard of lies bernie madoff and the
death of trust
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
thank you for being with us today
i would like to congratulate
congratulate you all on your wise
decision to come and hear diana
henriques today you'll know what i mean
in an hour when you leave here feeling
smarter and more in control of your own
financial future
diana b henriquez is the author of the
new york times bestseller the wizard of
lies bernie madoff and the death of
trust
looks like this you can buy your own
copy right outside afterwards in the u
of a bookstore tent in the u of a
bookstore itself or in the signing area
which is signing area b near the madden
tent so we hope to see you all there
before writing this book diana has been
a writer for the new york times since
1989 and before that she was a writer
for barron's magazine a wall street
correspondent for the philadelphia
inquirer and an investigative reporter
for the trenton times in new jersey
in 2005 she was a finalist for a
pulitzer prize
and won a george polk award the worth
bingham prize for investigative
reporting and harvard goldsmith
harvard's goldsmith prize for her series
exposing insurance and investment
rip-offs of young military consumers
she is also a member of the new york
times team that was a pulitzer finalist
for its coverage of the 2008 financial
crisis
the wizard of lies is her fourth book it
may be her first movie uh hbo and robert
de niro's tribeca films have
commissioned a script it is being
written right now and is due at the end
of the month so keep your
keep your fingers crossed for that one
and now let's welcome dan henriquez
one thing that is really wonderful about
this book is that if you really are very
unfamiliar with
wall street with the markets with hedge
funds with bernie madoff it is a book
that really anybody can understand
however if you are somebody who is a
really sophisticated investor hedge fund
man hedge fund hedge fund manager
you will enjoy the book to it you won't
feel that it talks down to you at all so
today what we're going to do is talk
about bernie madoff who he was what he
did but we don't want to leave anybody
behind so if you're not familiar with
the story we're going to start with a
little primer on
who is bernie madoff what he did
and
i think importantly
why he did it
if his his what he says in the book is
that he really did intend to be a great
financial advisor and that he intended
to get great returns for his clients and
he just things kept going wrong going
around going wrong and he dug himself
into such a hole he couldn't get out so
i'd like to get your take on that well
of course that is the classic ponzi
scheme rationale um
it's you and in fact it's usually true
um
you know a ponzi scheme is
more typically an opportunistic crime
someone who does get backed into a
corner and lies to themselves that's the
first big lie a ponzi schemer has to has
to tell is to himself
and i say himself advisely ladies
because they almost always are men i
don't know why but
you can count on two hands the number of
female ponzi schemers so i'm using my
pronoun advisedly
i don't know if madoff is telling the
truth about that
i do believe that the ponzi scheme that
he constructed began much sooner than he
claims it did
but his story
that's footnoted with least reliable
source in history
but his story is
that
some of his large clients got
nervous after the 1987 market crash and
started to make withdrawals of funds
that they had promised they would
continue to reinvest
and that pressed him and pressed him and
pressed him back into a corner and in
1992 he finally started stealing a
little money that was coming in from
hedge funds to cover withdrawals from
long-term clients thinking
that the market would recover he would
his strategy would work again and he
would be able to work his way out of
this hole
by 1998 the hole was billions of dollars
deep
and he says he knew he would never get
out and he
spent the next decade expecting the ax
to fall at any moment and indeed as i
described in the wizard of oz it almost
did several times this is a man who had
more cliffhangers than the perils of
pauline i'm showing my age there but um
he
he had had so many near-death
experiences in fact that i'm convinced
that at least for most of 2008
when the markets began that precipitous
climb he thought he might make it
through this storm too
because he had already survived so many
but he didn't those were remarkable
times and the the
sad thing about bernie madoff's
uh
fraud was that it was his investors
thought it was highly liquid
so all these hedge fund investors
uh treated it like their money market
fund you know this was their liquid
assets and when everyone in the market
started to get so nervous in the fall of
2008
and demanded their money back from
you know every tom dick and harry's
hedge fund
um
where were they going to get the money
to pay those guys back a lot of their
investments were not liquid they were
they were locked up in chinese cement
companies or in long-term real estate
developments but they had to cover these
withdrawals well we'll take our money
from bernie
so intriguingly enough people started
pulling money out of bernie because they
trusted him
to be liquid he was their
their rainy day fund they didn't start
pulling money out of bernie because they
suspected something was going wrong and
instead they thought that he was a
trustworthy place to take this money out
of
money poured out at an astonishing rate
by one estimate from the trustee who was
liquidating the made office state in
bankruptcy
13 billion dollars
poured out of madoff slush fund in 2008
half of that in the last 90 days of the
fraud
so he was circling the drain very
rapidly
and told me that he knew right after
thanksgiving of 2008
that he probably wasn't going to make it
through this storm
indeed what he tells me
footnoted again least reliable source in
history
is that he had decided
to let it fall apart he was just tired
of the tap dance
tired of the constant pursuit of new
cash
um that he just decided to let it fall
apart rather than to try to keep it
going one more time
he claims that people were still
offering him money in those latter days
still trying to give him money to invest
and he could have kept it going but he
decided to quit now since i think madoff
has a pathological fear of admitting
failure about anything it's interesting
that he won't even admit that his ponzi
scheme failed no no no he he he wasn't
fired he quit it sort of that kind of
mentality
but when he was arrested
arrested after his sons to whom he had
confessed
turned him in to law enforcement
what they found was a man who was
privately quite secretly managing more
money than goldman sachs
more money than jp morgan
much more money than george soros
this was a man who was allegedly
managing almost 65 billion dollars
so imagine that he was your money
manager
and you went to bed on december 10 2008
thinking your retirement fund was
what million and a half 2 million 7
million 10 million safely tucked away to
see you through retirement
and by nightfall on december 11th it was
all gone
that was the power of the story to me
that
that moment of instant transformation
it's like what happens in fairy tales
you know the the
cinderella coach becomes a pumpkin again
just like that so there was that
that
uh
sort of almost mythical quality to what
happened in the madoff scandal
i
knew
early afternoon on december 11th that
madoff had been arrested it was a name i
recognized from my years of covering
wall street he would
had this not happened he would have been
a minor footnote to history in the
formation of the modern over-the-counter
mark at the nasdaq market
and i saw the headline
called the source at a regulatory source
and said how big are we talking about
here
he said huge
and hung up
so
um i grabbed the story by nightfall we
knew he had confessed and been turned in
by his sons
and at that point it
it moved beyond financial fraud to me a
great enough story and became something
almost shakespearean at that point this
was
such a profound betrayal of trust
by him
and then he was indeed betrayed by the
two sons he confessed to
i felt there was something universal
about it by any measure it is the
largest ponzi scheme in history whether
you count the 65 billion dollars in
paper wealth that people thought they
had the day before his arrest
or the 20 billion dollars in
out-of-pocket cash losses the amount of
money people had given made off and
never gotten back in terms of dividends
or withdrawals it is the largest in
history it is also the first global
ponzi scheme the victims included a
teacher's pension fund in korea a
catholic school in saint croix victims
all over the world were pulled in to
this ponzi scheme so
it it was historic
by every measure and
i think has some timeless lessons for us
as you can tell i'm obsessed by the
story
and think it's one of the most
interesting
criminal cases and one of the most
interesting human dramas i've ever
encountered absolutely
it's often said of ponzi schemes and the
people who invest in them that they
played a role in their fate that they
were greedy that they should have known
better that they didn't exercise their
due diligence but a lot of the investors
with madoff were really financially
sophisticated people who felt that they
were exercising due diligence so i'd
like to talk a little bit about the role
of trust in our
financial decisions yeah i i meet this a
lot with uh
you know someone smug in the audience
will stand up and say oh
you know the victims were greedy
if they hadn't been greedy they never
would have gotten caught
well one of madoff's brilliant
innovations in the ponzi scheme
was that he did not appeal to people's
greed it's true ponzi schemers often do
the classic ponzi scheme is you know the
25 percent a week
you know the hundred percent on your
money in six months that's a classic
ponzi scheme and you're right you'd have
to be crazy to fall for something like
that or you'd have to be greedy
or ill-informed but madoff wasn't making
that pitch
madoff for most of the period of the
largest amount of money he took in was
underperforming the fidelity magellan
fund
let me say that another way his victims
would have made more money
by investing in the magellan fund than
they made investing with bernie madoff
so why did they invest with madoff
they weren't greedy they were frightened
the market had become increasingly
volatile increasingly complicated
everyone's trying to run their own 401k
their own pension plan in their spare
time while they make the money to put in
it
and
madoff offered safety and consistency
not high returns
so that's
another twist of the knife
his victims were people who thought
they were being more conservative than
anybody else who thought they were
taking less risk than anybody else they
were willing to give up the money they
might have made in the magellan fund in
order to be safe with bernie madoff so
it it is not true that ponzi schemes
always victimize the greedy um madoff
understood that when times are volatile
and investors are frightened or
desperate you can victimize the scared
and that's what worries me right now
jill frankly is that in this very low
interest rate environment
savers who are trying to save for
retirement on you know a half a
percentage point
um are going to be scared
about
what to do with their money how to make
money and they're going to be vulnerable
to the next bernie madoff who figures
out that if they don't offer you the sun
moon and stars
just two percent a year that's all
you'd fall for it
so
the
the notion that the ponzi schemer is
always this big outsized personality
not true not true of bernie madoff the
concept that ponzi schemes are always
trying to pull in the greedy with
sky-high returns
not true not true with bernie madoff so
what madoff teaches us that a lot of
what we thought we knew about ponzi
schemes isn't true
and that's why we need to learn about
this ponzi scheme because i think
crooks read books too
[Laughter]
this ponzi scheme went on for an
astonishingly long time and if i were an
entrepreneurial crook and i wanted to
know how to do it
i might take some pages from bernie
madoff's story
so i think it's important that we know
that story
and when you read the book you'll be
really struck i'm sure as i was at the
incredible amount of hard work and
creativity that went into sustaining
this thing
bernie madoff had a very loyal deputy a
guy who was a high school graduate was
hired right out of high school
and became under bernie's tutelage
really this computer wizard and the two
of them
set up this incred incredible amount of
trickery and i just want to read a
passage to show you
what i'm talking about
um at this point in the book there were
two uh stories in the media one was in a
in a publication for hedge fund managers
right so it's sort of obscure and one
was in barron's magazine where diane
used to work that both questioned madoff
and saying
a lot of what he's saying doesn't make
sense a lot of the things that he's
saying that he's doing
in the options market for example there
there's not enough money in that market
there's not enough shares in that market
it's not possible that what he's saying
is true so at that point neither of
those got a whole lot of press but but
bernie obviously knew about them and was
concerned and he called uh one of his
biggest investors at a group that he
really depended on for a lot a lot a lot
a lot of money many billions of dollars
and and had the guy come on over and say
are you worried come on over let me show
you how i do what i do so
his name is tucker the guy who comes
over when tucker arrived for this
impromptu due diligence visit madoff was
ready thanks to frank de pascali's
creative efforts besides the phony trade
confirmations and account statements
that had been generated for more than a
decade he set up a bogus trading
platform that made it appear as if
actual trades were being conducted with
european counterparties although the
reciprocal trader was actually an
employee on another computer terminal
hidden in a different room and he had
the clincher apparent proof that all the
stocks he claimed to have purchased were
safely held in madoff's account at wall
street's central clearinghouse the
depository trust and clearing
corporation officially called the dtcc
but informally known among veteran
traders as the dtc this was the acid
test for dipascali's masterpiece a
computer simulation of a live feed from
the dtcc he had taken care to duplicate
exactly the clearinghouse's logo the
page format the printer font and type
sizes and the paper quality of actual
dtcc reports of course those counterfeit
dtcc records would always verify that
the required number of shares were there
in madoff's account safe and sound
how could you not
fall for that it's just it's terrifying
it is
it seemed to me that all that effort
if put into legitimate trading
exactly would have would have produced
some money um the creativity was really
quite astounding um
when people say oh folks should have
known should have known
i'll give them that the statements
looked a little crude the
customer statements not these these
reports were right up to the minute
exactly what a man like tucker would
have expected to see
um
but
madoff kept old letterhead stationary
from his earlier addresses
and an old electric typewriter
so that if he had to create an authentic
looking document to satisfy a regulatory
query or an accountant's query he could
do so he could you know get the old
letterhead have somebody type it out
with that old bouncing ball remember
those and stick it in the file and and
answer whatever question they thought
would have to come down the pike
um deepa scully uh his first big
breakthrough was in 1992 when
one of madoff's earliest conduits of
cash two accountants who i call the
freaking frack of this story you could
not make characters like this up for
fiction or they tell you you were just
too over the top but these two
characters had been funneling money to
madoff for years and then they got
caught by the sec in 1992 this was one
of madoff's first big crises
and
they supposedly had 440 million dollars
that the sec told them
hand it back to investors
well
madoff stole the money from another
account gave the money back to these
investors
they all promptly wanted to invest with
madoff again
now these were the only people who could
have gotten out of this ponzi scheme
with all their profits
and walked away safely because the sec
made madoff give the money back
all the earnings all the profits
everything
if they just walked away but they didn't
they wanted to come back and invest with
bernie
but
these two accountants had only had six
accounts with madoff
total and through those six accounts
30 some 3 500 people roughly
were invested
well now bernie's got 3 500 people who
want to invest
3 500 accounts what does he do
he buys a new ibm computer
deep escala uses a very simple mail
merge software program to create a
program that could allocate a given set
of trades across all of those accounts
based on how much money they had and
generate the thousands of account
statements that madoff now needed to
produce
he that was when he really
automated his ponzi scheme and this is a
man who helped automate the stock market
so he helped automate the ponzi scheme
as well
it's often said that a good rule of
thumb for financial decisions is if it
sounds too good to be true it's probably
true but this goes way beyond that and
you have a different take on that i know
every writer has those lines they wish
they'd written but someone else did
this is one of those i give credit to
pat huddleston for it but it is the most
brilliant insight into the modern that
is to say the madoff ponzi scheme
if it sounds too good to be true
you're dealing with an amateur
think about it
a professional knows to make it sound
just good enough to tempt you
but not
make it sound too good to be true
and madoff was a pro
he never made it sound too good to be
true
a smart ponzi schemer won't
so if you think you can defend yourself
from a ponzi scheme or by staying alert
to anything that sounds too good to be
true i've got news for you that guy's an
amateur he's going to get caught long
before he gets to you
um
it's the pros who are going to make it
sound just good enough to sound
attractive
um
just good enough to
interest you but not so good that your
red flags are going to start waving and
your arm bells are going to start going
off uh so that's another one of those
lessons i think we need to learn about
the modern ponzi schemer and even you
were taken in by bernie native no not
financially but not financially
i did i i
just to give you a sense
of how persuasive he was
i interviewed madoff in prison i was the
first uh journalist to be able to go uh
interview him in in prison in august of
2010 and the deal that his lawyer
insisted on was that the interview was
embargoed for this book he didn't want
it thrown out into the media there was a
media firestorm engulfing his family at
that point he didn't want lighter fluid
poured on that fire so that was the deal
i'll talk to you
but you can't use any of it until this
book came out
i agreed
but i said
when i first met him it's a two-way
street
you know i will embargo this
material for this book
but you can't then go give this material
to other people you can't go do other
interviews oh of course not of course
not i waited 18 months to try to get
this interview
so bernie assured me he actually assured
me in writing by email subsequent don't
worry diana this is a direct quote i
won't let any other interviewers get
ahead of your book
well of course he was lying
he was lying he was it was on my second
visit with him in february of 2011 he
was talking my phone to a reporter from
new york magazine
i had fortunately found out about it i
have very good sources
uh and i confronted him i said what are
you doing we had a deal and he
bought he told me why he was doing it
and maybe i misunderstood our
arrangement i said i didn't
misunderstand anything
um and that's why my second interview
with bernie madoff showed up on the
front page of the new york times the
next day i told him the deal's off it
was embargoed for the book when you were
observing the embargo but you're not so
the deal's off
and he got very agitated about that but
as i was racing from the prison to find
a computer somewhere at the
raleigh-durham airport and file this
story for the next day's paper it
occurred to me that i had actually
trusted
bernie madoff
not to talk to any other
authors
even though he was behind bars
as a swindler when he made that promise
to me
i mean can you imagine how persuasive he
must have been when people still thought
he was a genius you know it gave me a
kind of insight into
how convincing he was
that i don't i'm almost kind of glad it
happened to me because you can
understand something intellectually you
can talk to people and i talk to dozens
and dozens and dozens of madoff victims
and they can tell you their experience
they can tell you how convincingly he
talked to their widowed mother and
assured her that her money would be safe
and it it's
it's an intellectual understanding yeah
i got it he was a persuasive guy
but when it's happened to you
when you sat there and said oh great
bernie's not going to talk to anybody
else
and you realize why on earth did i trust
him why on earth did i think he would
keep that promise to me then you really
understand the emotional magic that a a
first-class ponzi schemer has because
that is the non-negotiable job
requirement for a ponzi schemer you must
be able to make people trust you
if you can't do that you got to go into
another line of crime
you know embezzlement bribery something
else you can't be a ponzi schemer
if you cannot make people trust you and
this guy is so good he could make me
trust him a little bit when he was
already behind bars so that's how good
he was
and along those same lines the the
madoff story really destroys the notion
that you can't cheat an honest man
uh so the honest men and women here
today what can we learn from that what
can we do to make ourselves next round
less vulnerable to the next madoff well
you'll in the in the wizard of oz you'll
meet a couple of uh uh you'll hear about
a couple of stories of people who had a
chance to invest with madoff
and didn't
they were spared
um and i want to tell you one of those
stories um there was a retired
businessman if i told you what uh retail
chain he launched you would immediately
recognize it um
and he had angled for six months to get
an appointment with bernie madoff to get
him to manage his money because he'd
heard so much about him new had friends
at the country club who invested with
bernie he gets the appointment goes into
madoff's office with his accountant
the the business band's accountant and
they sit there and talk a little bit
about it and they get to the nub well
what's your fee bernie say well there's
no fee but i have a two and a half five
million dollar minimum
five million dollar minimum i think
bernie made up the minimum du jour
based on who was sitting across the
table but in this case it was five
million dollars
and the guy said
well you know
i never give a first-time money manager
more than two hundred and fifty thousand
dollars to start with then later if you
do well i'll put in more but
that's my limit two hundred and fifty
thousand dollars
and madoff said well i mean you can put
in two and a half million now but it's
gotta be five million by the end of the
year
and the guy was tempted he
he really wanted to invest with this guy
but he had this rule
a good smart rule and it had worked for
him for decades
and he stuck to it so he said
sorry stood up
shook hands with bernie chit-chatted a
little
walked out never realizing he had just
dodged the bullet
because
he didn't walk away because he suspected
bernie was a crook
similarly a charity on long island had a
chance to invest with bernie madoff
and they wanted to they had donors who
invested with madoff and they they knew
that they could do so much more good
if their money could grow at the nice
steady pace that bernie offered
but they had a rule
they never invested with a money manager
who didn't hold the assets in an
independent custodial bank
some independent third party a bank or
trust company that held the stocks and
bonds a third-party custodian they're
called on wall street
so they said well we we only invest with
money managers who use a third-party
custodian and bernie doesn't
well couldn't you make an exception just
this one time
no
we won't
so they too
didn't invest walked away not knowing
they dodged the boy neither one of them
suspected madoff was a crook
they both thought he was a genius
they both trusted him
but
they had rules
that were developed to keep them safe
from excessive risk
and as tempted as they were by this wall
street wizard
to waive those rules
they stuck to them and were spared
so that's what you can do you can
sit down figure out what your level of
risk tolerance is
figure out what seems to you like a good
smart way to manage your money and
they're the basic commandments don't put
all your eggs in one basket
only invest with someone who uses a
third-party custodian or stick with
tightly regulated mutual funds and bank
cds that you understand and that you
know regulators are watching like a hawk
so
those are some basic rules
you can have those rules many of
madoff's victims had those rules the
trick is
don't waive them for the people that you
come to trust and admire and think are
geniuses
we all have wizards in our lives you
know the people who seem so bright and
so successful and so good at what they
do that you trust them with anything you
trust anything they said they're just i
mean they're the tiger woods of golf
they're the the wayne gretzky of hockey
i mean they're the george soros's the
the peter lynches of the magellan fund
these geniuses who are just larger than
life and of course you trust them
well trust them but do not wave your
rules for them because that is what will
keep you out of trouble sticking to your
rules even when some glorious wizard is
tempting you to wave them
and just going back for a sec just out
of curiosity the guy that you mentioned
the retail chain store owner he's not
identified in the book wouldn't he be
awfully proud to say
i could not be tricked by bernie exactly
that's exactly the line i i fed him
that's exactly the sales pitch i used
and it didn't work
he just is he just very private yes
yes i mean i it's what i said to him i
said wouldn't you want to know
that yeah
that people to know that you he said but
he said what i said he didn't walk away
because he was so smart
he walked away because he had this rule
but he still thought bernie was a genius
he didn't twig that bernie was a crook
and that if he had discovered bernie was
a crook i think he would have let me use
his name
but but he didn't let's talk about the
madoff family particularly
ruth his wife was really vilified in in
every facet of her life from her
hairdresser wouldn't do her hair anymore
she couldn't get a table at her favorite
restaurants anymore
his sons i think got a bit of a pass
because they turned him in although
their their lives are really affected
but you do seem to believe that they
were not in on this you talk about the i
do and that's one of the most frequent
questions i get is what did the family
know
uh did ruth know did mark or andrew made
off sons no
um
i mean we're sitting here more than
three years after his arrest
the
madoff
bankruptcy trustee
has
reviewed i think this number is right 28
million documents
that were drawn
from the madoff firm's records the
basement of the lipstick building in new
york and that storage area uh where they
they left their uh
older records
not one bit of evidence has surfaced
that implicates ruth mark or andrew
not one of the five people awaiting
trial on criminal charges in the case
have implicated ruth mark or andrew not
one of the five people who have pleaded
guilty
have implicated ruth mark or andrew i
think at some point i have to say to the
people who say oh they must have known
prove it
because i don't think you can
i couldn't
i could not find anything that
implicated them and i found a number of
suggestive bits of evidence that
go in the opposite direction that
suggests that they did not know for
example
madoff had a near-death cash crisis in
2005. it's it's uh there's it's the
excerpt on the back of the book jacket
is from that uh episode in 2005. he was
facing 105 million dollars in redemption
requests
he had 13 million dollars left in this
slush fund
if he wrote those checks they would
bounce and the game would be up it would
be over
13 million dollars is all he had
he scrambled he borrowed money through
his legitimate firm he moved the money
he borrowed over to london and then back
into the slush fund so they use it to
cover uh expenses but from that
uh experience november 2005 until the
following spring his ponzi scheme is
living hand to mouth it is scrambling to
get enough money to cover these regular
redemption demands without blowing up
during that period of time
neither ruth
his sons nor his brother altered their
use of company cash in one
uh in it at all
they continued to borrow money from the
firm they continued to use the money the
firm's money to make uh entrepreneurial
investments and venture capital
investments
well i'm sorry if they're your
accomplices
and you're
and you're down to your last million
bucks you're gonna say family hold back
right
you're gonna say sorry you can't take
that money out
they did not take all their money out of
their accounts
as some of the employees did
they just continued to use their made
off piggy bank as they always had so
that doesn't suggest to me that they
knew that this ponzi scheme was in the
dreadful peril that it was in
let's look at ruth's situation
whether or not madoff was
unfaithful to her with the particular
people who claim he was unfaith faithful
to her
she believes that he was unfaithful to
her
what kind of lunatic
cheats
on a woman who can pick up the phone and
call the fbi
and cut a pretty good deal for herself
even if she was his accomplice
so that didn't make sense
third thing
from the beginning from the day of
madoff's arrest until mark's death by
suicide on the second anniversary of his
father's arrest
both he and his brother were represented
by a single defense lawyer a criminal
lawyer any lawyers in the room you all
immediately twigged didn't you
if two people are facing criminal
investigation
they can't use the same criminal lawyer
why well it's clear i mean if it you
know it might be that the very best
thing for defendant a to do would be to
roll over on defendant b to turn him in
and try to get a deal
the same lawyer cannot represent both of
them under those circumstances so the
savvy defense bar in new york knew
as the months went by
and the same lawyer continued to
represent mark and andrew that mark and
andrew were not facing criminal
investigation
ruth was um was confirmed as an innocent
spouse by the irs the summer after
madoff's arrest when she reached a
settlement with the government to
forfeit all but two and a half million
dollars of the 80 million dollars that
she had had in her own name
um
mark and andrew
can as i say continue to use uh the the
family firm
um and were often in disputes with their
father
which if they'd had this guilty
knowledge they certainly would have won
more often than they did so i add it all
together i think you'll have to
keep an open mind and decide whether i
persuaded you
but i was persuaded that
ruth mark and andrew did not know
about the ponzi scheme until madoff
confessed to them
he believed that by confessing by not
fleeing not running off to some place
beyond u.s jurisdiction that he would
shield his family
from the kind of vilification and and
antipathy that was hurled at them it was
one of the most astonishing things i'd
ever seen
but he was completely blindsided by the
amount of anger and hate that
fell on them anyway and and frankly so
was i it is extremely uh atypical
for the family members of a white-collar
criminal of any sort
to fall under that kind of attack you
think about it if you think back to
michael milken anybody remember mrs
michael milken
you think back to ken lay and jeffrey
skilling
anybody remember their children being
chased through the streets by
photographers and paparazzi
no mobsters
organized crime figures mrs mobster
anybody remember her being dragged into
the spotlight no i mean the gotti family
notwithstanding which seeks the
spotlight themselves that's noteworthy
exactly because it is so unusual
so it was not unreasonable for mayoff to
expect that ruth mark and andrew would
be left alone if he stood up confessed
his crime and took the heat he was
absolutely wrong
and
what they experienced it was a
remarkable
trial by fire
um
if you
accept that they were innocent and then
read what happened to them
i think you will find it hard not to
feel some compassion for at least those
members of the madoff family why do you
think that was was it because the sheer
number of victims or
you know i thought about that why was it
that we as a society stepped so far out
of our normal reaction and i think it
was the times i think it was the
anger the sense of public betrayal
that everyone felt in the fall of 2008
um
there were a lot of faceless villains
that fall remember you know lehman
brothers had failed we'll name one
person from lehman brothers
uh aig had blown up with derivatives
desk well did he name one headliner from
aig
outside the wall street world most
american citizens couldn't they those
were faceless corporations that had
somehow brought us to this brink
of financial meltdown
and then we've got bernie
a face
a family
someone to be the target of all of this
free-floating rage and anger this sense
of being betrayed because that's what he
did
he betrayed people who trusted him well
that's what wall street did
it betrayed people who trusted it
but it's an it
he was a hymn
and a her and a them
and i think it was the mood of the
country that made them so
much a target
of public rage rather than anything
unique about them
and ruth stood by her man for a long
time and in fact when the book ends she
still is standing by bernie and that
that has since changed can you talk a
bit about that yes it has changed and i
can talk about it because i was able to
interview ruth this fall for an article
in the times
about her life since then
she
realized
that
her
loyalty
to bernie
was costing her her family now why did
she stay with him
the one time madoff lost his composure
in my first interview with him in prison
in august was when i asked him whether
he regretted
that ruth had stayed whether he wished
she'd made a different decision
and he started to to weep as he tried to
answer that question he clearly
uh feels very deeply for ruth um and she
had loved him from first sight at age
13.
she met him when she was 13 and he was
this bronze 16 year old lifeguard
he walked her home from that party and
walked her through the next
55 years of their life
she married him at 18.
she adored him she thought he was a
genius
she she worshipped him
and he needed her
worship in in a very concrete way
she told me that she just
after 50 years
could not walk out on him
at this at the most horrible moment of
his life
um
it's hard a little hard for me to
understand but i've been married 43
years i can tell that there's some
people out here who have been married
more than that
and she put it to me she said well what
if it was a child what if one of your
children had committed some terrible
crime
would you walk out on them
would you would you cut them off and
never never talk to them again what
would you do
very hard decision and it was a hard
decision for her made even harder by the
fact that she really didn't have any
place to go
think about it her sons weren't talking
to her they'd walked out of that
apartment and because she had not walked
out with them they had cut her off
her friends well they were all made of
victims
even if any of them were inclined to try
to take her in their lawyers would never
have let them do so
no one could even speak up in her
defense in public without being vilified
so
she really had nowhere to go
she if she walked out on him she was
essentially homeless
and she felt compassion for him so
she stayed
finally
in the fall of early fall of 2010
she realized that it was going to be
impossible to reconcile as much as she
tried to reconcile with mark and andrew
they refused
to see her if she continued to visit
bernie and call him and talk with them
by phone they spoke by phone quite
regularly she did not visit him that
often in prison because it was a long
long trip from florida where she was
staying near her sister
to north carolina
so she went to him and told him i i
can't visit you anymore or it will cost
me my family i i have to choose i have
to stop coming here and you have to help
me stop
so
she attempted to pull away that fall
and
he kept calling
she changed her phone number
he kept trying to call
and then she learned about her son mark
suicide
the last time she spoke to bernie madoff
was the day she called him in prison to
tell him that their son was dead
and she has not spoken to him since so
he is truly uh estranged from her
uh in an in an absolute way she has not
spoken to them she has begun to
reconcile with her son andrew uh as she
had hoped she would
but that was a
that was a very difficult decision and i
i'm loathe to be critical of her
her decision
without standing in her shoes
at the time
you think of how much
pressure she was under how completely
dispossessed she was
i don't know if any of you followed the
publicity about the madoff auctions when
the u.s marshal service auctioned off
their possessions to raise money for
madoff's victims well some of the
possessions logically should have been
auctioned off she had a 10 and a half
carat diamond ring of course you sell
that the the homes you sell those the
boat
obviously you auction those off the us
marshall service auctioned off eight
pairs of her pantyhose
her used yoga clothes
all of the moisturizers and shampoo from
her bathroom cupboards
i can prove it because it's in the
inventory
that that the us marshals posted online
she was that utterly dispossessed
old pocket books
used shoes and boots
all of it
scraped out of her house
put on display at the brooklyn navy
yards and auctioned off
so
i haven't been through something like
that
i haven't experienced what she
experienced and so i'm a little loathe
to question her her decisions
she had been um
somewhat
not pampered person exactly although
certainly they had great wealth they did
not live at plutocratic levels like many
of the hedge fund managers that we've
come to know certainly very very wealthy
a little naive
a little innocent about the world and
utterly unprepared for what happened to
her in the aftermath of her husband's
arrest so
you know i'm i'm inclined to say i'm not
sure what i would have done in her shoes
i just thank god i wasn't in her shoes
there is one body who should have could
have put a stop to bernie madoff and
that's the securities exchange
commission and in the book diana
detailed several times when the sec did
investigate madoff a little bit and two
of them would go investigate and then
they'd stop and then they wouldn't
really file the report or it wouldn't
get shared with other offices and then
later someone else would investigate a
little bit so they came sort of close a
bunch of times but nobody really knew
what the others were doing so then after
the whole thing unraveled of course they
they
started taking it very seriously
and there's one point in the book where
some sec inspectors visit madoff in
prison and they want to know how did he
elude them for so long
and so
i just think this is a really telling
part of the book they um the attorneys
talk about the phony account statements
that he generated for years and years
and years that diana has talked about
and um and some when they call them
phony account statements uh made off
objects and he says well they weren't
really
phony account statements and then
they're the the lawyers are the
inspectors are sort of incredulous and
so there's a pause and then madoff says
i could see how you might see them as
false
but when i read that it really made me
think about the the phony war heroes who
you know buy the badges online and they
go to the parades and they do it for
decades and decades and decades and
after a while they believe their own
press and i wonder if there was some of
that with bernie madoff do you think he
really did believe that he was this
genius that the world thought he was i
do
i really do i i think as i said earlier
the the first lie a ponzi schemer has to
tell us to himself
um the lie that he can somehow get away
with it or that he'll somehow work his
way out of it the lie that somehow this
isn't that bad
so yes i think he was as adept at
deceiving himself as he was at deceiving
other people
um and it was so odd how he bristled
this was the sec inspector general who
visited him in prison in in jail
actually when he was held in new york
and he he was outraged at the notion
when this guy said well didn't you file
false documents
with the sec
and he said no i sent the sec the same
documents i sent my customers
and the inspector general said
but weren't those false documents and
that's when he uttered that line after a
long pause
i can see how you would think they might
be false yes
so
he
defended himself
um
my mom was a psychiatric nurse and she
used to tell me that the the mind will
not see what it cannot bear to see
that people will defend themselves
against knowledge that they cannot bear
to acknowledge
maybe there's something of that
in madoff's insistence that he he really
was an honest and successful money
manager for many years um the government
says oh no for most of those years you
were a crook
he really was filing honest records well
no he wasn't um
so i i think he can't really bear to
face
who he really is
um and until he does i don't know that
anything like the kind of remorse
that we might expect to see in a man who
has caused such devastation i mean
besides his son's suicide two other
investors committed suicide and the
aftermath of their made off losses a
retired british
military man who went into a park and
blew his brains out and a french money
manager who slashed his his veins in his
office because he lost his own and all
of his his clients money so i mean aside
from the financial wreckage you know
charities that had to close their doors
and and people who were living on social
security because they had nothing left
there was the human wreckage
and yet he still would argue with me in
emails that we exchanged that
you know the victims are going to get
enough out of the bankruptcy process to
make all this right again
as if dollars and cents could ever make
it right again
um so
you know i would press him on that i
don't just sit and listen when i'm
dealing with madoff i don't i don't
waste time trying to argue with him but
i do press back on the side of reality
and say
wait a minute you know there's no way
you can make these people whole
even if the trustee is able to get
100 cents on the dollar
people had to sell the family home they
expected to leave to their kids can't
get it back the kids who had to drop out
of college because they didn't pay
tuition can't get those years back you
can't put this
mess of broken eggs back together again
well i can see how you would say that
so
i'd like to open it up to your questions
there are microphones on on either side
whoever makes it there first go ahead
sir
relationship with the sec please
i'm sorry
his consulting relationship with the sec
it was always an informal relationship
um he was a noted figure in the in the
securities trading industry not familiar
to retail investors because so far as we
knew he didn't have any retail customers
um he was a behind-the-scenes guy an
infrastructure guy
so the sec consulted him and his brother
frequently about rule making that would
affect wall street trading he was in the
vanguard of pushing towards more
automation of trading
24-hour trading globalized trading
things that have all come to pass that
madoff was an advocate of quite early
so he would serve on
advisory committees roundtable
discussions um you know he would be part
of the delegation that the industry
would send to the sec to argue about
some rule change or another but he never
had an official consulting relationship
with them
how important
was the notion of affinity fraud
i'm from minnesota and at least in
minnesota a large part of the jewish
community
was involved not so much because they
had direct contact with madoff but
because they trusted their friends who
had yes had this trust in me that's a
wonderful question and there's no doubt
that affinity fraud as many of you may
know is simply the the process of
preying upon some affinity that you have
with your victim whether it's ethnicity
or country club membership or religious
faith
um
that you play on that affinity to
develop trust which you then exploit
through fraud
was this an affinity fraud certainly at
the beginning in its early roots it was
madoff's father-in-law um
who
was a
source of some of the early investors
who invested with madoff at a time when
madoff insists he was legitimate
and might have been
he he knew people at his country club it
was a jewish country club so those
people got to know bernie um he
bernie served on boards of uh
you know of yeshiva university of uh um
jewish philanthropies uh he re he became
known in that community so yes initially
it was an affinity fraud certainly he
was playing on the trust
that he gathered simply by being a
member of that group a respected
generous philanthropic member of that
group but by its end
by indeed the last decade of its life it
had left affinity fraud far behind you
know
the
uh sovereign wealth fund of abu dhabi
lost 440 million dollars with madoff so
you know investors in the persian gulf
who never dreamed that this little
jewish kid from queens was running their
money um or who did know that he was
running their money and thought of him
only as the senior executive of nasdaq
were investing with madoff so it far
outstripped its affinity roots but
certainly it started there
could you discuss uh the folks who
withdrew
phony prophets
and their rationalization
that they really should keep that money
even though it was a ponzi scheme by
definition and came from other people's
uh pockets
you know the tragic thing about a ponzi
scheme and that's such a good question
because it hits right at the kind of
heartbreak that makes ponzi schemes the
most diabolical financial fraud i can
think of it doesn't just pit the victims
against the villain
it pits one set of victims against
another set of victims
and there can be no winners
but
what the law says and now the law in the
second circuit in new york has said
that the way
you weigh the equity in these cases is
on a cash in cash out basis
that the the people who have already
withdrawn the cash they gave madoff
don't get any more
until the people who didn't get any cash
out of their accounts have been made
whole too
and then if there's anything left we can
share and share alike so the efforts of
the liquidation right now are to deal
with the so-called net losers the people
who gave madoff more than they ever got
back
trying to make them whole
the net winners
surely the most perverted term ever
because they are not winners by any
definition that we would understand they
were just as tragically betrayed they
lost money they thought they had but
under the law
they received all the cash they'd given
madoff and in many cases even more
they received money that made off stole
from other people
and used to cover their withdrawals
which they thought were legitimate
earnings on their investments
there's no way to make this whole if
you've robbed peter to pay paul
how do you undo that
you take it back from paul to give it to
peter
paul isn't going to be happy about that
he's going to believe that that was his
money and i'm sympathetic to that
but peter is going to say no it wasn't
your money it was mine
so
that's the kind of legal heartbreak that
is stretching out now for years uh into
the future as this tangle this knot is
unwound you can see why i get a little
upset with madoff when he claims that
you know money can fix all this
no way
we have about one minute left so one
more question
with respect to mrs madoff it's called
unconditional love
and i'm sure you would have shown the
same thing and she didn't
end up exactly destitute right two and a
half million but the question i really
wanted to ask was
had bernie managed
to manage this until today with the dow
back at 13 and and the banks bailed out
would he have dodged another one i think
he would i think he would
uh just in in ruth's uh defense there
she settled with the government uh under
a forfeiture agreement that allowed her
to keep two and a half million dollars
she still has not reached a settlement
with the bankruptcy trustee so how much
of that she will be allowed to keep when
she's reached a settlement with the
bankruptcy court we don't know yet and
she doesn't know either
but yes i do think
if madoff had been able to weather that
storm he would still be going strong i
really do believe it i think he was
already dialing his returns down by the
june by june of 2008 he was only paying
4 percent
he'd be paying a percent and a half now
maybe maybe
75 basis points he'd be paying very
little but it would be more than you
could get in the money market fund and
you'd be happy to have it wouldn't you
so yeah i think if he'd been able to
weather that storm he'd still be going
strong and to that end i'd like to close
with the final words from diana's book
that is the most enduring lesson of the
madoff scandal in a world full of lies
the most dangerous ones are those we
tell ourselves
so let's thank diana henriquez
over at
signing area b by the made up by the
made up by the mad intent
and that wraps up our live coverage of
the 2012 tucson festival of books all of
today's programs will re-air tonight
beginning at 1 a.m eastern
and now on book tv paula included
speeches by the speakers of the house of
lords and house of commons you can see
it at 9 pm eastern on c-span
our guest on newsmakers this week is
robert kuzami mr kuzami is the
head of enforcement for the securities
and exchange commission thank you very
much for being here this week glad to be
here let me introduce our two reporters
who will be asking the questions ed
wyatt is business section reporter for
the new york times covering regulatory
issues for the paper and andrew ackerman
covers the sec for the wall street
journal and dow jones news wires
gentlemen thanks for being here mr white
we're going to be in with you
uh mr kazami the financial crisis
continues to ripple through the economy
and the financial markets you've brought
a lot of cases both against companies
and against individuals but there still
seems to be this perception out there
that that the real culprits who cause
the financial crisis have not been
brought either to justice or have not
been
fined or punished or
brought to bear on
for what they did
do you think that's true at all do you
understand those feelings among the
public so certainly i understand the
feelings given the breadth of the loss
and the impact of the financial crisis
on people's livelihood and on their
savings and investments
but having said that as you indicated i
think our performance has been
very strong in this area over i think at
last count 102
entities and firms have been charged and
most importantly over 55 ceos cfos and
senior corporate executives for conduct
across
the mortgage-related areas from issuing
companies like countrywide and new
century to
those firms that issued cdos with
misleading statements such as goldman
sachs jpmorgan wachovia
citigroup to the mutual fund complexes
who
loaded their funds up with riskier
mortgage assets than they disclosed to
their investors like morgan keegan
schwab and other companies so we've been
active across the board i understand
those views by the public
we have a specialized unit set up to
handle these cases we're vigorous across
the platform
some of the concern sometimes is is is
reflected in comments that why aren't
more of these folks in jail
the sec does not have criminal authority
but we work closely with the justice
department in these cases so um while i
understand it i think our record is very
strong in this area do you think you've
hooked the biggest fish that there are
or are these firms the biggest firms
that people have the most awareness of
are the people at the top just so good
at insulating themselves from decisions
in cases that you do bring that we don't
see the big executives getting charged
well you see the big executives in
certainly some of the cases on the
public company issuer side in
countrywide new century
and those companies we've charged ceos
cfos senior corporate officers um in the
investment banks it's a little different
because
the cases that we've charged in this
area is the issuance of a particular cdo
that was misleading
those kinds of transactions often don't
get vetted in the executive suite right
some information does
when you're talking about a public
company earnings reports and disclosures
in prospectuses to investors
those types of matters are signed off by
ceos and cfos cdo transactions and other
deal specific matters often
aren't vetted at the senior corporate
levels now don't get me wrong we we
follow the trail of evidence wherever it
leads but the nature of the transactions
um is a little different and so you're
not going to see as many prosecutions of
those folks for those types of
violations as you might otherwise but
again we look strongly uh and thoroughly
across the entire corporate network
andrew ackerman
yeah when you came to the sec three
years ago the agency's failure to detect
the madoff ponzi scheme was this giant
cloud
that hung over the agency and i guess
i'm wondering to what degree do you
think that the sec has recovered from
that tarnish on its reputation
look i think that the agency responded
in exemplary fashion to
both
the madoff revelations
as well as the financial crisis i mean
as you would expect and any entity
public or private we took a hard look at
ourselves
in terms of what we could do better and
the result of that was that the
enforcement division underwent its most
significant restructuring in 40 years
created specialized units to focus on
priority areas flattened management
created cooperation programs to get
earlier better evidence of wrongdoing
created a co function to handle
in a better and more efficient manner a
lot of administrative and other tasks so
that so that the investigative staff
could spend more of their time doing
that a lot of reforms across the board
great deal of talent um um was available
and came to the commission and those
kinds of reforms were repeated across
the division so
from where i sit um as indicated by
their performance the agency has
responded extremely well
and you know done the things that it
should do which sometimes can be
difficult to do but do a cold hard
assessment of what we were doing good
and what we're not doing good and making
the necessary changes but what are the
types of cases that you're bringing now
that you couldn't or didn't pre-crisis
pre-this reorganization pre-made off
well look
as significant as madoff one i don't
want that to overshadow the fact that
the commission uh historically has
brought
just year in and year out many very
significant um
cases that have identified wrongdoing
and brought people to justice i think
what we've tried to focus on since the
restructuring is a greater emphasis on
specialization so that we can identify
wrongdoing earlier in the cycle
before the investor
funds are gone and in areas that perhaps
are not quite as transparent as they
otherwise would so we're getting to them
sooner we're not waiting for the fund to
blow up or the headline to appear but
we're in there earlier so for example in
our asset management unit
we took a look across all investment
advisors to see who were earning returns
in excess of their competitors for
certain strategies and whose returns
were static
over a period of time when you would
expect to see volatility now those two
factors
aren't necessarily
indicative of wrongdoing but that would
be the kind of fun that you want to take
a second and hard look at to determine
whether or not there might be a ponzi
scene going on or false evaluations
things like that so we're using more
data to identify um subsets of firms or
individuals that we want to take a
closer look at
just to come back to
the
sort of
the impact
meetup had on the agency do you feel
like
you know when you go up to the hill and
ask for more resources that that
continues to
like be a headwind essentially in in
your request for additional resources
and is it still is it making your job
harder i guess that's what i want to ask
no i don't
i don't think so we haven't forgotten
the lessons um uh by any means but i
think that that there's enough of a
track record
of honest reform
and um and proactive efforts
that um
the honest critics will see that and
[Music]
don't use madoff as an example to deny
funds and look even even for those
persons who are still troubled by madoff
i think the statistics make it clear
that even if you take that into account
we are significantly underfunded i think
the chairman recently gave the
comparison that
while we are responsible for regulating
35 000 entities those are public
companies broker-dealers investment
advisors transfer agents
as well as in the enforcement division
anybody who might commit securities
fraud and yet we are about the size of
the d.c police force and i think that's
one way of getting a measure of of how
our
our size and our budget compares to the
task at hand
how has technology enhanced your efforts
we've tried to do a lot in the
technology area really just to to
introduce efficiencies
so for example we
we had an antiquated e-discovery system
which is the system that collects all
the information that we get
electronically in our investigations and
just to give you some sense of the
volume i think we probably get anywhere
from three to six terabytes of
information a month across the division
for its investigations i think the
entire library of con congress printed
book edition is 20 terabytes so we get
massive amounts of data we had an
antiquated system that that lacked
sophisticated search capabilities and
sort of um artificial intelligence and
we're now implementing that
we have new financial extract software
so that we can now you know when you get
massive numbers of broker dealer records
or banking records you can quickly
download that into spreadsheets and
databases that can be manipulated where
frankly in the not too distant past that
stuff was being done manually
we are centralizing
some of our collections work where we
pursue people for the fines that we've
assessed or the distributions where we
give out money
to people who have been harmed we're
centralizing that so that
investigators out in the field can spend
a higher percentage of their time
in their core competency which is
investigating fraud and misconduct but
you know the budget i think the entire
sec enforcement budget i believe is
roughly excuse me the entire sec
technology budget across the entire
agency is about 100 million dollars of
which enforcement gets a just a fraction
i know one firm
one wall street firm that spent nearly
five billion dollars on technology and
communication and equipment so that
starts to give you some sense of
of while we're doing what we can with
the money
greater technology budgets would be most
welcome but if it's not made off
i mean if there are other
i i guess if if it's widely understood
that you guys are underfunded don't have
the resources that you need yet
you're saying that madoff didn't have an
impact on that so why i mean why is that
why
why do you think
lawmakers appropriators are reluctant to
give you guys the resources you need
look i i don't really want to speculate
on why
some
choose to support our request for
additional funding and others do not
all i can say is um i think the funds
are needed i don't want to create the
misimpression that we don't
very consciously use what we have we
have gotten nor do we use the lack of
funding as an excuse i mean look we're a
we're an enforcement regulator with a
lot of sophisticated talent we have some
advantages that those that we
investigate don't and so
as i recently testified before congress
we punch well above our weight class
from my perspective and i like our
chances in uh
in our cases
and there are some cases where look
we're going to put whatever resources
are necessary
to to see the case through to the end
kind of regardless of of some budget
constraints but look why
why some choose to support and others
don't i can't tell you i can tell you
that with dodd-frank of course that's
only increased the burden
on the agency mostly on the rule-making
side because of all the work they have
to do
and so we were underfunded i think in my
view before dodd-frank and dodd-frank
has only
increased that workload 15 minutes
and you bring cases
in
particular against large firms in a lot
of cases they're settled before they go
to trial
and
they're usually settled with some
consent decree
and the payment of a fine
what evidence do you have that that
those settlements actually deter future
wrongdoing because there have been a lot
of cases where
particularly among the large wall street
firms they
make settlements for violations of the
same section of the securities act over
and over
seemingly without any uh any additional
penalty
well um
first of all we do take into account um
the prior track record of a particular
firm in deciding what kind of penalties
and sanctions um to assess
there are some limits however on what it
is that we can um
uh we can assess there's a certain
ceiling that's based on a per violation
formula or based on the the amount of
money that the firm earned
in terms of what we can assess that's
why the chairman has actually requested
congress to grant additional authority
particularly in the case of firms that
have violated a prior injunction or
order to be able to allow us to assess
greater penalties but we take that into
account and look from where i sit firms
take very seriously
an sec investigation
and the sanctions that come with it
they study
our cases corrective action is taken
across the industry when they see one
firm
being subject to an enforcement action
they look at their own shop in their own
house to determine whether or not they
have the same problem and try and
correct it
so there's a real
ripple effect to our actions that i
think achieves a significant deter
effect also we prosecute you know a
large number of individuals i think in
the credit crisis cases
75 percent of our cases are filed
litigated which means we are going to
court and litigating against individuals
and firms you know we're only accepting
settlements when we believe that it is
uh close to what it is that we could
hope to get if we went to trial but we
would be you know not
not doing our job and not protecting
other investors
if we didn't settle a case where we got
close to what we
hoped to obtain and being able to get
the money earlier so we can distribute
our investors and so that we can use
those saved funds to go out and
investigate the next fraud but with the
biggest firms you know even if they pay
150 million dollar penalty
that really is you know a few days if
not a few hours worth of of revenues to
them are you saying that it's because
we're legally restricted from assessing
bigger fines that uh that we can't do
something or do you think bigger fines
would be more meaningful to these
companies well look i don't think
trading revenue or profits is the proper
metric for whether or not you know what
a particular fine um should be
we have uh
as i said statutory limits on what we
can find but we operate aggressively
let's take goldman sachs for example
which you know sort of engendered some
of this debate that's the case where the
firm expected to earn 15 million dollars
for structuring the abacus deal they
paid 535 million dollars penalty now
that is 30 or 40 times what they
expected to earn that is a sharp cold
hard message
to firms and risk managers and business
heads that they should be very careful
about the transactions they engage in
and that the fines and penalties that
they may face are not just a cost of
doing business but there are cases where
our penalty authority restricts our
ability to
obtain
sanctions to give you just a quick
example if a if an investment advisor
earns
uh has a hundred dollars worth of assets
and they earn a twenty percent fee they
earn twenty dollars for managing those
assets but if they engage in fraud and
and cause a hundred dollars worth of
losses the most the sec can get is
twenty dollars in disgorgement because
that's the amount they earned and
another twenty dollars in a penalty for
a total of forty we can't get the
hundred dollars back under the current
law and that's another area that the
chairman has asked for additional
authority
uh
this may be in the policy weeds or in
the weeds a little bit but it involves
zombies so um there's a front page story
you're talking about the funds yeah
private private equity zombie funds um
there's a story in the walls wall street
journal friday about how um
the sec is looking into these funds
there's someone quoted to that effect um
can you
explain how big a problem you think this
is and if we should expect to see
sec enforcement cases in that area
well i won't really comment on what we
expect to see but look it is i think
it's a good example of what we're doing
differently now the asset management
unit which is handling this first we
went out and hired a lot of private
sector experts
risk managers portfolio traders
mutual fund operations personnel to come
into the commission and work with us
both to help us
investigate wrongdoing and also to tell
us kind of where
where the rocks were and what was buried
underneath them and this is one of those
initiatives where
we identified this phenomena which
really is
fund managers who are sitting on assets
that can't be sold or their valuations
are so low that they really don't want
to sell them and so they're not
particularly active but the manager is
continuing to earn fees year in and year
out that the investors are paying and
not seeing any return
and we're going to take a close look at
that and see whether or not there is a
problem also
under dodd-frank now these advisors will
be required to register if they have
more than 150 million dollars worth of
assets in general so going forward one
of the benefits of dodd-frank is now our
examiners can go into these um advisors
and look for things like valuation
problems and zombie funds and things
like that so another uh issue tied to a
potential enforcement action revolves
around lehman brothers the biggest or
one of the biggest bankruptcies ever
the agency spokesperson is on the record
saying that you guys
i still have an open inquiry into that
uh the the bankruptcy into the failure
of that firm
um but there's apparently a memo where
staff have said they're not of a mind to
bring any enforcement cases
can you say if there's a reasonable
prospect that there will be a case in
that area
yeah i really wouldn't be appropriate
for me to comment on the status of a
particular case except to say as we have
said that the matter is still under
consideration and analysis we we looked
very closely at the examiner's report we
conducted our own independent
uh investigation including you know
reviewing millions of pages of documents
and dozens of witness interviews um and
the matter remains under consideration
so that apparent memo isn't the final
say on the matter
well i'm not going to comment on a
particular memo or what it said or
didn't say but that's the current status
of the case
you've brought a lot of insider trading
cases uh recently and i think you've
beefed up that that area and it's been
helped by technology the the very
biggest cases though uh have been
brought as criminal prosecutions uh by
the u.s attorney's office
how involved and and where were you
involved in those investigations and or
has have you in those been
pushed to the background somewhat or uh
have you been
critical in gathering the information
and uh and
bringing them to justice yeah look we've
we've we've brought parallel cases in
every one of the insider trading cases
that have been brought um
including those brought up in new york
arising out of
the galleon fund and expert networking
we work very closely with the criminal
authorities in these in these cases and
provide a lot of expertise
a lot of analysis a lot of document
review
we do joint witness
proffers together and we work very
closely with with them you know we have
more resources and more expertise in the
markets in general
and the criminal authorities obviously
have
additional
tools in their tool shed
with respect to search warrants and
wiretaps and the threat of jail as well
so that together we make a very
formidable
force but we've brought cases in
parallel cases in every one of the
matters that that the u.s attorney's
office in new york has done as well and
it's a it's a long-standing partnership
of great benefit to both agencies but in
a lot of these investigations
the justice department gathers
information but they're not allowed to
share it with you is that right and does
it work the same in in the other
direction do you gather information that
you're not allowed to share with them
now generally there are there are
restrictions on the sharing of grand
jury material and some restrictions on
the sharing of wiretap information those
are probably the two areas you're
talking about
but there are ways to
construct an investigation with respect
to the grand jury issues
so that we can steer clear
of those prohibitions wiretap authority
is more difficult we can get wiretap
information we just can't get it on a
timely basis we can get it at some point
down the road but there are there are
ways to navigate around that and
obviously the benefits
of
not um the benefits of wiretaps uh
is so great as you saw in the galleon
prosecutions that we want to make sure
we don't do anything to um to disrupt or
or imperil the use of those devices we
have just four minutes left last
questions uh the dodd-frank uh
regulatory overhaul gives you guys the
authority to give a lot of money
potentially to
people within companies who blow the
whistle uh on uh fraud
you know at their companies
why haven't we seen any whistleblower
awards when will we
well um
look the awards
are made
only after the conclusion
of a matter
where there's been a determination that
a million dollars in sanctions have been
ordered because that's the threshold
amount
and so that just takes some time for the
cases to work their way through to the
point where a final judgment has been
approved and those kind of sanctions
have been have been awarded so
it's not surprising or a cause for any
concern that it hasn't happened yet the
whistleblower office is is thriving
we're getting um
we're getting a substantial number of
complaints and i think excuse me tips
and referrals and more importantly i
think higher quality ones which is
exactly what we hope for you know the
whistleblower program along with our
cooperation program where we offer
reduced sanctions for persons who come
forward with evidence those are two
more of the tools that we're trying to
use to get the information sooner about
wrongdoing
there seems to be this perception among
republicans on the hill that the
whistleblower program is sort of
undermining you know this internal
compliance
uh regime like the company that people
are you know they want the money so they
go straight to the sec they don't bother
going through the internal system at the
companies uh what do you think about
that we heard look we i think we
received over 600 comment letters when
we were drafting the whistleblower rules
and that was one of the big concerns and
we recognized that concern because
frankly a strong internal compliance
department at a company can do a lot of
good to prevent wrongdoing and so we
didn't want to disrupt that so we struck
a balance in our rules where we included
a couple of matters including being able
to take into account whether or not a
whistleblower went first in-house to
their compliance officer in deciding how
much
they should be able to see more money if
you go get more money you don't lose
your place in line because there are
certain deadlines so if you go in-house
first and raise your complaint you don't
lose your place in line in terms of
eligibility
and are you seeing more tips more
whistleblowers who have already gone
through that internal process than not
well i think the the anecdotal evidence
is and we kind of believe this from the
inception is that people despite the
financial incentives still go first
largely to their companies
to try and correct the wrongdoing and
it's only when they don't get the
satisfaction that they think
should be should be obtained do they
come to the authority so i think a lot
of the concerns while legitimate have
not been borne out by the practice
like any uh agency you have to marshal
your resources if you had more as you
asked
what sort of cases would you bring or or
what areas would you look at that you
haven't been able to now
i think with more resources look we
would we would we would be able to do
deeper dives it's not so much new areas
because we cover
the waterfront in terms of the types of
violations we have active offering
frauds and foreign corrupt practices act
and insider trading and accounting and
disclosure fraud but i think what we
would do is we would have more people
being able to react sooner
and conduct investigations at an earlier
stage so that we could
stop fraud before the investor money is
lost that's probably the single biggest
thing that we would do as well as
frankly we would have more
paraprofessional and support help and
i.t resources so that we would be able
to again better utilize the the the
talent that we have now and a closing
corollary for me we've heard you argue
for additional regulatory authority more
dollars better technology and larger
staff i mean really if one thing could
change to make the investing public
safer what would it be
um
from the enforcement perspective
i think it would be
larger budgets to be able to give us
better technology and more support
staff and more private sector experts
thanks for being with us
thank you
we are back with ed wyatt of the new
york times and andrew ackerman of the
wall street journal dow jones after
talking to rob kuzami the enforcement
chief at the securities and exchange
commission is very bullish on the
enforcement overhaul and the success
rate of the sec
at post financial meltdown but what is
the view of the congressional oversight
committees of the work that they're
doing in these past couple of years well
the uh
certain people in congress uh have
complained that uh you know that no
matter how much money they give the sec
they still make monumental blunders um
they did in uh in the recent past with a
real estate deal for a lot of office
space that it turned out that they
didn't need or couldn't fill
continually people bring up the
the madoff case and say you know you
missed that one you missed the stanford
case so why should we give you more
money stanford is the mini madoff which
is only a 7 billion dollar ponzi scheme
in in texas
and your thoughts when you talk to
members of congress about what's
happening there we heard as we said to
mr kuzami he's asking for more dollars
so he can have better technology more
people uh and the like but what's their
view
well their view is that they need to be
more efficient with the resources they
have i think i think
um house republicans certainly are open
to the idea of giving the agency more
resources but they want
broad restructuring at the agency before
they give them any more money
the sec is kind of in this unusual
position where uh they they're they're
funded by transaction fees that they
impose on the firms that they they
oversee on wall street
and so giving them money doesn't
necessarily translate to uh you know an
increased budget deficit like they're
separate from that you know from the
debate about increasing or you know
they're self-funding yeah they're
essentially self-funded um but you still
have you know a reluctance to throw more
money at regulators at this point and he
kind of you know he didn't want to admit
that that the missing madoff was
the overshadowing and that was
overshadowing everything but i think if
you talk to people on the hill they'll
tell you that that you know they're
that's their biggest concern it's also
talked about the
the bettering of their database and
talked about the amount of money they
spend versus the large companies that
they that they are
regulating and the resources on
technology are just uh really apples and
oranges but not only that we've seen so
many instances in post-9 11 of the fbi's
database that the government is
notoriously slow in the technology area
so how good a job are they doing really
with implementing technology as a tool
to find the bad guys well i think uh rob
kazami has recognized that if you're
going to keep up with all of the
innovation that's going on on wall
street you've got to play their game
you've got to use technology to sift
through these huge markets to try to
find people who are
doing insider trading
patterns that are emerging that will
lead you to clues i think he understands
that and he's been very aggressive in
doing it and they have brought more
cases they've brought bigger fines and
they've changed some structural things
under mary shapiro where for example
they don't need to go now to the full
commission to get permission to start an
investigation so
they are they're trying to do that but
look drug lords have more money than
than the dea has
you know criminal enterprises the mafia
had more money than the new york city
police department it's always going to
be that way the question is how well do
they use what they have so the bottom
line i guess in the reforms of the past
couple of years from dodd-frank and and
other actions taken by washington is the
investing public better off a little
more secure
now than it might have been four or five
years ago
i think they are i mean i do think that
there
is i mean there's certainly i mean a
laser focused by all of the regulators
to make sure they don't miss another
huge ponzi scheme to make sure
um they have more resources to
revitalize enforcement i mean that's
across the board at all of the
regulators how would you answer that
well you know i i think they are it's
easy uh sometimes for us in the media to
look and say oh well they found another
investment advisor who stole seven
million dollars
from some elderly investors down in
florida and so what
but that's real money to real people and
to their credit they bring those cases
as well as the 550 million dollar cases
against goldman sachs
they have ramped up uh what they're
doing
there is always going to be something
missed and our job is to point that out
well that's it for our time thanks to
both of you for your first appearance on
newsmakers please come back thanks for
having us
first president's post presidential life
find full schedule information online at
booktv.org or consult your program guide
my name is kathy mccormack and i'm board
president of prop memorial library in
old granite connecticut thank you so
much for joining us for tonight's
program
with local author jim campbell about his
new book um madoff
talks
which has received glowing reviews from
fortune magazine the guardian and many
others i want to also thank the members
of the prop memorial library association
whose generous contributions make
programs like these possible if you're
not a member please consider joining
details can be found on our website prop
memorial library.org i also want to take
this time to thank jess reed and craig
jones from greenwich point marketing
they've helped us all year long with our
zoom programming and without their help
we would have never been able to stay so
connected to the community so thank you
again to grunge point marketing for all
your help
um
copies of jim's book are also available
um on our website
promptmemorial.library.org
also um through diane's books and
greenwich we put a link to both of those
um in the chat
um what else do we have to say this
program will be recorded and we'll send
a link um to the recording um in our
follow-up email and jim has also
graciously agreed to answer questions um
so you can use the um
raise your hand function um in the
bottom right of your screen and we will
let you um ask your question at the end
of jim's talk
and so now it's my honor to introduce
local resident jim campbell jim is the
host of the nationally syndicated radio
show business talk and friends friends
of talk with jim campbell he's the
assistant news director of 1490 wgch and
is known for his hard-hitting interviews
of leading figures from the worlds of
business politics and sports
known for first campbell snagged the
first executive interview with the
former new york governor elliot stitzer
after his resignation
in the first interview with tycho ceo
dennis kowslowski after his release from
prison and the first broadcast interview
with former stock analyst rumi khan a
government informant in one of the
biggest insider training
bus in american history
thank you jim for joining us welcome
thank you it's my honor and i see some
people i recognize up there so i'm
particularly happy folks are coming out
on a wednesday night even if it means
just going to your living room i want to
i got to thank louisa green first
because
she is so nice to me and she jumped out
and invited me the minute the book was
coming out not so much for the town of
greenwich on the board of the library
the boy scouts etc kathy for inviting me
kevin mccarthy director of the library
for inviting me jessica reed for the
technical support we even had a
rehearsal last week she's so efficient
so um i'm honored to do this and i think
people are are going to be stunned at
how little they know about the madoff
story despite the fact that the general
perception is it was one guy operating
behind a curtain who pulled off a big uh
ponzi scheme and actually he was enabled
over 40 years by all kinds of uh of ways
from co-conspirators who i call his big
four which are his major investors who
actually bailed him out on occasion and
came to have the power to extort him
um the willfully blind conspirators
which was the hedge funds that fed all
that money into him and knew something
was up
what i call the unwitting conspirators
the sec and civic who uh sec five
investigations they missed on and um the
witless co-conspirators his high school
graduates he hired in the 17th floor of
the lipstick building two floors under
his legitimate business with top-notch
business school graduates
so this has been kind of a whirlwind let
me give you uh my first question i
always have to answer is we had nothing
to do with the timing of bernie's uh
death that uh i was coming home from the
wgch having been up since 4 30 in the
morning and doing the morning news show
and at the intersection of uh
sound beach and the post road
across my phone it goes you know bernie
madoff passes away and i was a couple
hundred yards from the shell station
there i was going to stop and get a
snack
my phone starts exploding
and texts and phone calls i get to the
snap place and i'm told that i'm on
bloomberg uh radio in 10 minutes and
that they'd already announced it on
their website so i had to go uh
sprinting home to do a seven-minute
interview with um bloomberg that they
knew about before i did
and then i got the uh the new york post
called and asked me to write this is the
middle of interviews now the new york
post asked me to write a 2 000 word
article in the afternoon for the next
day's paper that the editor said he
would tease on the front page if i would
get it done
and i'm like trying to figure how do you
write 2 000 words
um
you know in a short time span but he was
good to his word the next day was on
like page five or six i got out of bed i
looked at the new york post mobile app
and it was the number one trending uh
article
at the time
then i got some more of the
tabloid type calls the daily
mail of london called me and asked me if
i knew who was getting the body of uh
from the bureau of prisons
and
i turned that you are kidding me so
you're not asking me that question
and um
no they weren't kidding and i said well
i can't answer that question i don't
know and then i got some other bizarre
uh
ones and a picture that was in one of
the articles of the numeric express bill
you may have seen it and it shows ruth
madoff charging 57 000
in one month on the corporate credit
card was a private firm it did not mean
she knew about a ponzi scheme but it was
kind of like looking at the firm as a
piggy bank well anyway that got picked
up by one tabloid and then i saw it all
over the world all these foreign
articles that would come in i'd
recognize 57 000 and jim campbell i
couldn't recognize it in other words it
was all some foreign language where
there's french spanish and on and on so
i kind of learned not one of those
tabloids called me to find out it was
just 57 000 was all across um the world
so now we'll go back to 2011 how did
this thing ever happen uh
i'm nobody they don't know who i am the
madoff family and all of a sudden you
know bernie's talking to me for what
turned out to be eight years
and i i was uh taping a radio show that
was actually gonna be live and the day
before the the author who had worked
with the family on a book said that um
andrew madoff would talk to me off the
record
and um so i called him and i right away
jumped all over him you know i said your
father gave you 2.2 million dollars to
buy a co-op in the last uh months before
this went down shouldn't you be giving
that money back right away and then he
stunned me by saying absolutely and he
seemed very open and answered any
question i wanted to
and then i um so said the show's on
tomorrow he said well you say it's live
i'm going to listen and if you say the
same thing i want to make sure that you
do so he listened
and the second coincidence uh which
everybody knows around here old
greenwich ruth was moving uh his mother
from uh florida to old granite so i
offered to take her out to dinner to
lunch
and so uh andy set it up at the beach
house it was uh in december there was no
one in the restaurant we got there she
arrived in sunglasses which she did not
take off even inside of the restaurant
for a while
then orders a chef's salad but she
proceeds to devour like she's not seeing
food and we ended up hitting it off she
was incredibly nice um good chemistry uh
we were walking out and i said you know
can i get a picture of us ruth she stops
and she goes you're wired aren't you she
thought i'd set her up
but once i convinced her that i was not
wired that it was a legit conversation
off the record uh she hooked me up with
bernie
and
i told her and it took about two weeks
for the prison assist uh email system to
approve us coming together
and so i told bernie bernie said andrew
and ruth have vouched for your sincerity
so i'm going to talk to you hopefully to
dispel the myths about this and the
misperceptions uh so he obviously was
going to try and uh
tell me his his version of uh reality
and uh ironically andrew
madoff on december 10th bernie confessed
the afternoon before he was arrested by
the fbi the minute bernie confessed
andrew never said another single word to
his father ever again
so when bernie vouched for andrew he was
either making that up where he was or
ruth had uh conveyed that
and
bernie and i go back and forth with
these beautifully seven uh page
handwritten exquisite handwriting
letters and as well as emails once he
had a stroke there and i ended up with
about 400 pages and that's how we got to
where we got i um
i told bernie at the end of that i got
to figure out what to do with all this
i've never written a book or anything
but there's got to be a book in here and
i got an agent we searched around for a
uh publisher and there was no interest i
got another agent and he sold it and
signed a contract with mcgraw-hill
inside of one week
and and so that's that's what started
and i told bernie i'm gonna vet every
single word you said and he said jim i
accept those conditions uh probably to
his regret
but um that's what he did
so that leads us up to the story now and
um
i try to convey first off that this was
not an event that happened uh alone that
this would have been this could have
been stopped in five minutes in three
different ways at least that i have
uncovered of which the it actually
lasted for 40 years
um which if you know anything about a
ponzi scheme they last for very short
durations and they inevitably have to
fail because you have to have more money
coming in the front door than it's going
out the back door because there's no
real investment activity going on some
investors money is being used to other
to give to other investors so you've got
to have more and more people so that's
why they have to fail generally and um
if not for all these uh co-conspirators
uh in the various ways i address he
would have been caught
relatively quickly another thing that
surprises people is that normally the
wizard behind um the curtain and in this
case bernie was on the 17th floor of the
lipstick building behind locked doors
that his own sons did not even have
access to and they ran the 19th floor
business which was 100 percent
legitimate and ethical uh called the
market-making business they did trades
for discount brokers customers working
for the firms like um schwab
so anyway um bernie is uh is downstairs
there and he wasn't the guy that made
all the money uh a guy named jeff
jeffrey pickpower who was the biggest of
the big fours bernie called them took
seven billion dollars out of that hedge
fund
that's nine times what bernie madoff
stole to hide into the he took it and
hid it in the back door of the
market making business when it was
having solvency problems plus the family
obviously took a lot of extra money out
when when you know ruth is charging 57
000 a month but this guy pickhauer is
the guy that made all the money the
three other guys each made a billion or
two um
as well
the most unfathomable thing to me was
that
you would think logically that what
happened was bernie's writing this very
legitimate business he's very highly
regarded much the regulators on wall
street he treats his customers with
great respect
and you would think well something bad
must have happened he must have lost
some money
and while it's not legal he says i'm
going to double down it's a gambler's
mistake do a little ponzi or something
to keep it alive we'll catch up pay off
whatever happened and then we'll be back
and no one will ever know what would
happen
and bernie told me a story just like
that that he'd never told anybody else
he he didn't even tell his lawyer this
story um and his lawyer ike sorkin um i
spoke to because bernie waved attorney
client privilege which is unusual uh as
you know
so i said oh okay bernie so at least
there's some logic even though you made
a huge mistake because it was criminal
go in and start vetting everything read
the forensic reports of the consultant i
talked to the fbi
bankruptcy trustee and lo and behold
bernie at the same time he was building
this successful business which became
the number three market maker from zero
broke the monopoly of the new york stock
exchange was building simultaneously the
biggest criminal enterprise in wall
street on the same uh in the same time
two floors down
different types of employees he hired
each
for each he could he found honest
competent people and he found people he
could manipulate didn't understand what
he was doing and he ran them both so you
can imagine how compartmentalized his
mind was
the legitimate business was worth three
billion dollars in and of itself at pete
exclusive of any hedge fund
so you have to uh you have to go figure
so these big four guys um came to have
this power they could extort returns
from him um he grew to hate them
and in a sense this was a reverse robin
hood because he had a whole bunch of
what i would call average not high net
worth investors who were putting in
money all the time over 30 40 years and
they were of average wealth and they
built it up over time a punching scheme
is easy to detect by the way because all
you have to really ask is where's the
money
are you trading with anybody who are you
trading with
not much more than that where's the bank
account do you have an accountant and by
the way he had an accountant who was a
one-man uh band in a strip mall in new
city new york wasn't even legally
licensed to do big public accounting um
jp morgan his bank at one point said
somebody should call to find out if it's
a car wash or not and it turned out it
was a laundromat because he was
laundering money he was also invested
with bernie
so none of these simple ponzi tests were
done
and why is that
we'll go to the sec
they conducted five separate
investigations of bernie and never
uncovered the ponzi scheme never really
uncovered the 17th floor
never really figured out that they were
charging him with the same uh what they
expected was the same offense in each
investigation even even after they
cleared him
the time before they thought he was
doing front running
and front running is when you're a
market maker jumping right in front of
your customer because if you know if
your customer is going to order ibm
that's a bullish signal right he knows
what the customer is going to do you
jump right in front of it you take a
little slice because you know the market
the market's going to go up that's how
they thought he was able to guarantee
results because he was cheating and he
knew what was going on and he was
jumping right in front of his own
customers the funny thing was bernie
never once ever did front running never
once would have done that to his uh
customers and we can talk about
robinhood if anybody's uh heard of that
because they have abused their customers
in a way that bernie uh
would never have
so
as the sec misses investigation after
investigation
there's some whistleblowers harry
markopoulos you probably know of
we're looking at this starting
in the late 90s
didn't understand harry and they didn't
want to listen to him they thought he
was disgruntled competitor
but
to give you some examples here here is
a way that the sec could have solved it
in five minutes bernie in fact told me
he gave the sec his account number at
the depository trust company all you
have to know is that's a clearing and
settlement entity that all your trades
have to go through
and he gave them the account number
which was zero six four six
and the market making business every
trade could be traced and finra and the
sec did that
no problem so bernie gives him the
number and he's expecting them to ask
okay we're calling about his investment
advisory business we're told it's a sub
account
in the 646 account and they would have
found out in five minutes there was no
such sub account there was no never any
ia or investment advisory or ponzi
scheme trading ever
ever to go through the dtc
and guess what
sec didn't make the phone call
even after he gave the information
um
it's pretty amazing the whistleblowers
knew bernie's strategy
called a split strike conversion
sounded very complex i could never find
any of his victims or even the traders
on the legitimate floor up on 19 who
could explain it to me but you know what
which is what he designed it to be but
if you understood it conceptually it was
very simple
it should have mirrored the stock market
which means highly correlated which
means most of the time it should perform
as the stock market does
so the reason that harry marcos could
figure out within two hours was that
he found that was actually five percent
correlated it mirrored the market five
percent of the time in other words
it could not do anything that bernie had
said and by the way if it had mirrored
the market it couldn't have gone up
every month
bernie never had a negative month in you
know 20 or 30 years so his whole
strategy never made sense even if you
could understand it and no one uh
apparently did and the um sec uh
did not
so where did all this money come from
that was going into uh bernie's hedge
fund it was coming from what it called
feeder funds and these are hedge funds
whose job it is to say i have luisa's
money this is she's very conservative
i'm gonna look across five or six
portfolios and i'm going to put her
money exactly with what fits her
objectives
in other words i do a lot of due
diligence that i promised to luisa
before i take her money and she feel
comfortable with me and then she trusts
me to go put her money in there in
return for that um the hedge fund
charges its normal fees which everybody
in greenwich knows it's two percent of
assets twenty percent of uh the gains
under this is the hedge fund capital and
the feeder fund just takes one percent
for due diligence and and helping do
administrative work
these guys
what they ended up doing bernie did not
allow any due diligence which right off
the back would ask you why would the
hedge funds accept that
well maybe because bernie passed on all
those lucrative fees that i just
mentioned back to the feeder funds
basically so they wouldn't ask any
questions
so he was basically taking money in
taking no fees for it other than
stealing it as a ponzi scheme and giving
hundreds and hundreds and actually
billions of dollars to the feeder funds
in what are really kickbacks uh if you
will
which they call uh fees and in return
they didn't ask any questions not only
did they not ask questions bernie made
each of them sign an agreement that they
had no discretion on the investments
at the same time he told the sec that he
had no discretion on the investments the
feeder funds did and all he did was
execute trades
so you can see
you have the sec missing investigations
never having the right people they never
look to investigate a ponzi scheme you
have the feeder funds pouring this money
and never asking bernie any questions um
so that um uh that they would just get
fees in return for
taking people's money often not even
telling them they were putting it with
bernie's fund and often not telling them
that they were only with one fund all of
it with bernie they were supposed to be
diversified
i'll show you some slides in a bit that
show you how he pulled this off but he
had a small staff on the 17th floor
these were high school graduates
unsophisticated didn't understand uh
wall street and uh
they back dated every trade which means
the trades were all fake they didn't
realize it was totally illegal they
never realized it was a ponzi scheme in
40 years
and just to show you how bernie knew how
how to hire his administrative assistant
who was a good source of mine on the
legitimate floor she's a hundred percent
honest he paid her 125 000 a year with
no ira
her equivalent job on the 17th floor she
did all the phony training for picktower
for instance who would dictate his own
returns
her last year bernie paid her 670
thousand 000 salary and she had a 58
million dollar ira
had the same job basically uh as eleanor
so you can probably understand why she
didn't talk nor does she ever figure it
out because
all of her money was in the firm when it
went down so she obviously didn't know
it was a
it was a ponzi scheme
thing is blown up now um all these folks
have lost money they lost 19.5 billion
they'd invest that they thought
based on their financial statements they
had 65 billion dollars so you turned to
shipping
what is civic the securities investor
protection corporation it's the
equivalent of the fdic
the fdic has been around since the new
deal and has never failed to pay the
money that it says it owes up to that
limit to any investor ever and never
cost the us government a dollar
shipping on the other hand
did not tell people certainly these
innocent victims that they didn't intend
to cover a ponzi scheme they said
there's uh this there's no real
investment activity so we can't cover it
and uh furthermore since the gains are
fake we're not gonna recognize your
final statement we're going to recognize
only the original investment value
so imagine oh you're you're a merrill
lynch client opening up your statement
and finding out that number isn't real
and furthermore that the sipc doesn't
really intend to cover it and
furthermore they didn't have enough
money to cover it they've been told 16
years ago before the bernie went down
that by the gao that they lacked enough
money to handle a major
wall street brokerage crafts and
bernie's firm only had 230 people in it
so what did cipic do
not one dime of the payments to the
madoff victims came out of the civic
fund
instead they went to madoff victims
remember everybody lost their money at
the end
any madoff victim that had withdrawn
more money than he put in over the years
they went after to claw back money
any madoff investor that left more money
in other words hadn't taken it out they
were to get that money
and they basically raised 14 billion
dollars uh that way taking it from one
set of
madoff investors and giving it to
another set
never struck me as very fair was legally
uh
case law uh supported that
but um
a lot of victims
not only had money clawed back that they
had lost even though over the 30 years
they may have taken out more they may
have had no money left they
had their homes uh gone after they had
their iras gone after the average age of
a made-up victim was 75 years old and
some of them had to go back and work in
walmarts
and um and things like that and in my
opinion if the sec failed five times and
civic didn't have the money on hand uh
really honestly to pay them back
why shouldn't these of investors been
considered out since the government
basically had cleared bernie as legit at
the same time this was going on the uh
tarp program uh was putting 800 billion
dollars into wall street firms exact
same time to keep them alive while the
madoff victims uh went down and went
through court proceedings for years over
money uh that had been clawed back
now there's one other area
that also totally missed this
ponzi scheme and that's his bank jp
morgan the only entity anywhere that
actually could see into bernie's account
and see what how much money was really
there bernie told me that he never had
more than 5.9 billion dollars on deposit
at what was called the 703 account at jp
morgan the last three digits um the rest
was supposed to be in the market or
it was fake ponzi money and jp morgan
didn't even clearly understand that it
was for the investment advisory ponzi
business they thought it was legitimate
market making account even though that
account had been in bank of uh new york
for 30 years
and um
if you have a
equity strategy which his was it's quite
simple to say his bank account has got
to show payments for trades
counterparties and it's got to show
dividends coming through it there should
have been four billion dollars of
dividends that flowed through this
account and there should have been
payments to counterparties nonstop
instead 170 billion dollars flew through
that through that account 170 billion
there wasn't one dollar of dividend ever
deposited there wasn't one payment to a
counterparty ever made and jp morgan
never uncovered that
and that's only one of the three things
that jp morgan screwed up [ __ ] i have
to tell you it's kind of painful i went
to tops with jamie dimon who's the ceo
of um jp morgan now and i gotta tell you
testament to his character i asked him
if i could come in and speak to the
people there even though jp morgan
completely screwed up
and he let me do it and just this week i
i offered to give him a book and i told
him i would not be insulted if he if he
blew it off and he that he wasn't going
to like it but he has taken the book
and at the same time this civic trustee
that i was just telling you about
his claim to fame is that they raised 14
billion back out of the 19 so he claims
to be the most successful ponzi scheme
uh retriever despite the fact that he
got the money from other madoff victims
he refused to see me three times
um because the truth is more complex
than he tries to parlay it that 14
billion he took two billion dollars in
fees and expenses off the top of that um
that came out of the civic fund not the
madoff
uh victims but that's still two billion
bucks that could have gone uh in my mind
the bulk of it to um to the investors
that lost all their money
the um
the final things before i show you some
slides on this
this scheme in many ways was also a fr
tax fraud scheme
um there were two conspiracies in my
mind the government never pursued and
one was these biggest investors these
big four and the others were doing major
criminal tax fraud um pick however
himself was calling up and he would say
i want this gain for x y and z go back
dated and then he'd call up during tax
season i need these tax law uh lost to
um you know uh
center offset the uh the gains no one
has ever been prosecuted criminally for
that none of the hedge fund um managers
who did the due diligence and humbled
the money in there without asking
questions have ever been penalized uh
criminally
the other thing was um
the international feeder funds and what
in particular you'll see her picture
later on
funneled incredible amounts of dirty
money in in other words they were doing
money laundering for russian oligarchs
he's european oligarchs colombian drug
drug lord money um to the extent that
the colombians threatened j.p morgan
when jp morgan was trying to take money
out of a madoff uh hedge fund this again
the government decided never to go after
these folks and um i mean it's a little
dangerous to go after these guys by the
other hand it was um grossly illegal
bernie said to me he didn't even know
who was in the international you know
coming in through the through the banks
and feeders um
over there
um i'll talk briefly about reforms and
then i'll show you um
um
some slides and you can uh you know
shoot questions at me
the first thing that when i started
there are 30 reforms at the end the
first thing was in individuals and i
tried to say that individuals need to
think like a doctor in terms of that
hippocratic oath do no harm first nobody
understood what bernie was doing
secondly bernie was telling people on
january 1st what their return was going
to be anybody that tells you they can
guarantee your market return in january
you should be running the opposite
direction from them
because it cannot be done
and thirdly sadly um you can't
necessarily necessarily assume the
government is going to be there for you
the sec did not find it
uh cipic did not have the funds to
reimburse people and did not feel they
were obligated to since it was a ponzi
scheme
and so you need to take responsibility
for your own investments in a sense you
need to be conservative you need to
understand it and my hero was warren
buffett the the market has gone up nine
percent a year for a hundred years
bernie was paying about 11 in the last
few years
buffett would say invest periodically
regularly in a low-cost index fund and i
would say take that nine percent and
sleep at
night yeah in the end hundreds hundreds
of people
should have gone to jail and literally
only a handful did from the 17th floor
and when bernie passed away it was the
last single person uh in prison for what
is the biggest ponzi scheme uh in
history
and if you'll let me now let me
let me show you now some some slides uh
when i did the cbs sunday morning uh
interview the uh
jim axelrod was a correspondent and he
found um
the
these documents so compelling that we
just sat around the table and did uh
what was called the b-roll going through
these things we were going to walk
through old greenwich where i'd first
had uh lunch with ruth and ruth would go
to the bagel shop the upper crust bagel
shops we were going to kind of do that
kind of thing and she would have walked
at the beach but he got so into the uh
document so i i like to show them this
is the post article by the way that was
the 2000
words and what i thought was great about
the post he simply could not accept any
losses that is the fundamental issue
here with bernie he psychically could
not tolerate losing money
so the legitimate business he was making
commission money right which means the
market's up the market's done he's
making his commission
so he goes into this investment advisory
business and holy cow i don't make money
on every trade so he stopped trading and
made it up he could not live with it
and um they got that they put that
headline in there i thought that was a a
very good catch on their part
this is the uh lunch outside the little
pub with um ruth when we were leaving
and you'll notice she was comfortable
taking this picture unlike the first one
where she thought i was wired this was
after uh after after a couple of years
uh knowing her we would have regular
lunches and um and then a lot of text
messaging and emails and you know
she was
she lost 800 million dollars in net
worth she paid 100 million bucks to the
justice department they left her with
two and a half million dollars of which
500 000 of that went to lawyers and
she's the most resilient human being she
had no complaints about it with me she
she said i'm we're from queens we're
average people
i don't care i'm now driving a beat-up
car uh that was dangerous when it came
around uh corner she moved into into an
apartment eventually that she was paying
2 900 a month she had to turn in every
receipt to the bankruptcy trustee over a
hundred dollars
and
she was just functioning
it was very estranged with bernie by
then having been cult-like devoted to
him and
also telling me frankly she was upset um
they had uh that he had some affairs
that she found out about uh during this
whole process um they were dating since
they were 13 years old
this is andrew madoff who was of course
the first person i met and that's his
girlfriend catherine hooper who um
is the person that you know let me into
the uh into access to a lot of people
and who told me that despite her belief
that she thought to the depth of her
soul she believed andrew was innocent
but she told me says if you find it jim
i'll accept it which i thought was
pretty amazing and she was true to that
um she just sent me a letter a couple
days ago saying she loved the book and
she um
and basically thanked me for pursuing
the truth
now this is the uh this is what freaks
this of the cbs jim axelrod out on that
one side is the front page and the end
page from jim from regards bernie that's
the seven page space letter that's the
um
that's the first one which starts off
i'm going to go on my sons and wife's
recommendation
and these letters would come out
with just compulsion to rationalize his
behavior
on the other side is a one sentence
letter to andrew and catherine who you
just saw
and it says i'm so sorry dad not even
love dad but i'm so sorry that was his
confession to them or his apology i
should say
and that's what he could get out he
didn't know who the heck i was that you
know uh i'm jim campbell and he's
writing these
passionate you know seven page letters
and he could write his son only a one
sentence letter um saying i'm so sorry
so uh
that says a lot now
here's what an actual madoff statement
looked like that every month they would
get this is an actual victim from
chappaqua actually
i'm not sorry from our mind and as
you'll see these are all legitimate big
cap stocks
um and a fidelity fund um u.s treasury
market uh treasury bills and um
there was so much detail
that it snowed his uh investors every
single thing on this page is fake except
for um the name of the of the victim of
the name of the firm
they would come stuffed with con uh
trade confirmations he did tons of
trading they would come chronologically
in order um it gave the uh
victims a real sense of this guy so
ordered so structured and
remember he said he passed on all those
management fees because he was just
taking commissions he wasn't really
making the decisions he was just doing
the training but where that yellow box
is is where the commission is supposed
to be listed and you'll notice it's
empty
so some of the fakery
he didn't quite get
there were also
trade confirmations on dates and the
stock exchange was closed but people
hadn't didn't figure out there were also
confirmations with the prices that did
not match anywhere in the range of that
day's trading so there were ways to have
seen that it was fake
this is uh one way i talked about the
depository trust right he had which is
where everything has to clear so
everything's got to be there
he had a fake system that showed a live
feed
to the depository trust and if you'll
notice you can't see it closely but this
is for the date of uh november 30th it's
a
a security position
at that time
but the investigators found that this
was actually entered in the computer in
december
so
literally he was making up the live
screen showing positions for trades that
happened that he actually typed into the
system a month later
this was how he did the laundering of
money out of the ponzi scheme into his
uh
his his office and the 703 account of jp
morgan in this example it took this is
an actual example that 4.3 million out
of it deposited into his personal
account at morgan stanley
once it was a personal account of morgan
stanley it went to the market making
account which was at the bank of new
york which was the legitimate businesses
uh bank account and then it went into
the back door of the
market making business hidden in the
trading profit and loss statements
and this was profound because there was
800 million dollars of what looked like
trading losses until this money was
pumped in
well who ran the trading desks andrew
and mark madoff
so it was very
on the surface incriminating that how
could they not have known that bernie's
fudged all this money through their 800
billion bucks is a lot of money
and i was able to find literally the one
person in the firm
that saw the actual p l's before bernie
fudged them
that could vouch for whether mark and
andrew have seen it and this story is in
chapter eight
um it's real touch and ghost story it's
uh um
i think you'll get a kick out about
reading and i also go through whether
ruth um knew or not and how she was
what were the question marks there i'm
the first guy that made a determination
on the family's complicity on knowledge
of the ponzi scheme
now this was what bernie called and i
i'm not jewish right my yiddish is bad
the stoop account file
and this is what what what would happen
bernie would promise you uh
in this case it's 18 for the year
so we're in november and as fake trading
has you up for about 9
so all of a sudden he's got to get you
in one month to 18
um
the literal translation of uh a stump is
to push up it's slang for sexual
intercourse and what he was doing was
in the file was putting whatever we took
taken trades to push up to that 18
which means he might have to have show a
hundred percent gains through the stup
file to get louise's 18
uh that he promised and this was this
was uh going on for for decades
these are the actual ibm uh
as400s that were out of date in 1980
that he was using to run this 65 billion
dollar
scam i took these pictures the fbi
turned them back to the forensic
consulting firm and they were locked in
the closet
and uh they let me go in the closet and
take pictures of uh of this machine just
think 65 billion dollars this machine uh
all it did was print out fake stuff
um
there's the spreadsheet that harry
markopoulos figured out everything was
fake in two hours
on the right which is interesting
is um
there is a fund
that copied that no that was actually
identical to madoff's called gateway
it's a mutual fund
and that blue line represents the actual
results from bernie's strategy if you
did it legitimate
that red line is bernie's fake green if
you notice it's straight up no
investment line looks like that and you
know whose line that really is that is
the new york mets sterling equities
made off uh results
uh because they had their account with
him
and they had
483 accounts with bernie and that's
that's what theirs looked like over this
time period bernie's went up 48
the actual uh
other one went down 20 and they were the
same strategy so you could have seen
just by looking at a publicly available
mutual fund uh that it could not have
been done
this is the infamous american express uh
charge that ruth charged 57 000 on that
month there's all kinds of names of
folks in the family who did not work at
the firm who were basically using the
firm as a piggy bank the great irony is
this is bernie's card as he as the
holder of it and he was charging zero
dollars on it
but everybody else was uh jumping into
it
now remember i mentioned that uh
accountant in the uh one man strip ball
well bernie had all of his tax stamps
and stationery in his warehouse uh out
on long island because bernie did his
own taxes
so it was they they found all the
equipment and that's the guy's name
also found in in the warehouse was all
these lottery tickets and nobody knows
what these were for but to me these
represent bernie's desperation trying to
figure out how to get out of it because
he told me
that at the end gym he was hoping there
would be a nuclear attack on wall street
so that it would wipe out all of his
records
that's how he was thinking that's how
stress so i wouldn't be surprised if he
was buying lottery tickets at the same
time to try to figure out how to get out
of it
now this is uh the international money
laundering story this is sonya cohen
she ran the the
she ran the money laundering theater
fund she owned a bank called bank medici
in austria that was basically taking
money out of this russia to cyprus to
her bank and then into bernie
and the scary thing is is sonja looks
like bernie we call her the evil soul
mate um and she's also never been
criminally charged or anything but she
has been um
she had a lot of money clogged back from
from her fund
now this is how this is how i ended i
dedicated the book to my father who i
say gave me the moral foundation that
bernie madoff so sorely lacked and what
i tie this back to is eleanor spoleri
who i mentioned earlier was his
legitimate uh honest secretary
and she was friends with all the folks
down there it came up at the same time
they grew with the firm and she said
that be that she used to be absolutely
tortured
what made some people go one way on the
path and some the other way
and
in the end this thing is no more than a
morality tale
and a tragic one uh that is you know uh
mark committed suicide andrew died of
cancer um and um there were other
suicides uh as well
and
to get right down to it you know
the decision to take that path even
bernie had two paths right he had
legitimate and the illegitimate so it's
uh it's really it's really a tremendous
story and i hope that gave you um
i hope that gave you a little bit of a
flavor of it um as as we've said the
diane's books has the book there because
i think you'll find it a fun read and i
think you'll get the message that
that i try to get across with this
wasn't one man's scheme this was a
failure of the system and he was enabled
to get this done
and you may be stuck with more of me
because uh netflix is uh bidding on my
book and i'm supposed to hear literally
later tonight or tomorrow so you may see
this on netflix but yeah thank you that
would be kind of exciting um
for a guy who's never written a book so
i have a face for radio so hopefully you
won't see me
now does anybody want to shoot questions
at me
jim we have two questions in the um chat
actually to start with
um luisa asks he says a question for jim
and this is during your presentation why
do you think these investors didn't
analyze their statements i find this
statement for the person in our monk
fascinating why do people continue to be
swindled by these ponzi kings
yeah you know um i would ask the victims
if they went through their statements
and
often they did and or because they look
so official um i know some that went
through every single every single
statement because these confirms there
might be 50 60 in one month
but the other thing is that this was an
affinity crime is 85 jewish on jewish
charities and
this whole network was communicating and
going in i interviewed uh i talked with
jeff matthews today he was a hedge fund
he ran he was from greenwich he ran a
hedge fund for 23 years you know what he
told me today
he's one of the most honest people i've
ever met
he told me he had 80 investors over
those 23 years and in those 23 years
precisely one investor asked him what he
was doing
none of the others did it was all his
reputation
bernie had a pristine reputation and he
was called the jewish team bill he was
as secure as the u.s government he would
deliver no matter what
and um
it was a con and uh
now that how does that excuse the feeder
funds because to me that's the real
question these guys were being paid to
be experts and to promise to louisa they
had done that they'd asked the questions
they verified it and by the way bernie
did not allow any independent custodian
that's something that you should always
check on because an independent
custodian has the assets so they're
there they know the trading is there
they can't be hidden bernie wouldn't
allow that for obvious reasons and never
did
um so people want to also
believe it there were a lot of people
who knew something was not right but you
know what
maybe he's doing a little front running
maybe i'm going to look the other way
he's our crook
happens all over wall street you know
let's let's just uh look the other
direction and then there were more that
knew he was lying didn't know it was a
ponzi scheme and those guys in my mind
are you know are complicit uh in that
sense
but i come back to where
you got to ask those questions you you
got to understand the strategy if you
can't understand it in about two seconds
something's wrong
and um he designed it that way every he
he admitted to me he would try to
explain stuff so no one could understand
it
and the funny thing was the strategy was
completely conceptually easy and he
couldn't do what he said it could do
and nobody seen it nobody seemed to get
it not even the sec
by the way the sec has a group in
washington that does that they do they
look at investment returns and results
they figured out in a couple of hours
about the same time harry did that it um
it could it couldn't work the way bernie
was saying and the message never got
back to the examination team on the
ground because the sec was so poorly
coordinated nobody spoke to each other
the branches didn't even talk to each
other so uh they that never got that
message never never got back along with
the failure to call the uh dtc for five
minutes
i hope i answered that louise that's
kind of long-winded maybe
jim
next question from sandy is bottom line
you explain what he did but why
good question
um
you know
i say i think um
psychologically when i when i talked
about the the
once you accept that he didn't do it
because he got in trouble and that he
made a mistake and that he took the
wrong path because he lacked the courage
morally to get out of it that he did him
at the same time that's when it becomes
you know
so hard to understand so obviously he
has tremendous powers of psychological
compartmentalization
which by the way he had no insight into
the prison shrink had to tell him that
even though it seems kind of apparent
doesn't it and um
so when he was successful in the market
making business making commissions and
then he could not accept losing money on
the other side
he didn't know what to do and this is
where he lacks remorse in his mind in
his mind
he was pressured relentlessly by greedy
investors
they wanted returns returns returns
always positive all was up he had to
deliver
he gave his sons millions of dollars to
buy homes when he had no cash because he
couldn't say no to his sensitivity it
could not become apparent that he
couldn't deliver anything
he saw himself as a victim of his of his
investors particularly the big four's
greed
he said to me jim
i am a product of the corrupt culture of
wall street and if you've never managed
the high net worth person's um
assets you won't know what i'm talking
about these guys cheat they don't pay
their taxes their money's offshore
and all this was was
deflecting responsibility he could not
take responsibility um for basically
anything it was always someone else's
fault and it was always pushed on to
somebody else
when he says these were greedy investors
and everything who was the person
telling them what the returns were who
was the person making up the return who
was the person giving them everything
they wanted who was the person that
bribed the feeder funds
bernie
jim carl asks do you think his biggest
individual investor carl shapiro
knew what bernie was doing or suspected
anything
well first off jeffrey pickhauer was his
biggest carl shapiro was one of the big
four
they obviously knew he was short cash at
periodic times because they bailed him
out
um it's not likely they knew it was a
ponzi scheme because they left their
money in there too although when you
look under the hood they did a pretty
good job of not having much there when
it ended
um but uh
i think that they were completely
complicit in the tax fraud um as i said
the coward called in his own own results
as he wanted he actually dictated his
own capital gains um but the smallest of
the big four guy named stanley chase um
he never
not only did he not understand the
strategy he said don't tell me i don't
want to know what it is but you may not
lose any of my money
you know
and uh and bernie never did
jim luisa asks did bernie ever talk
about his prison experience how did he
adjust after living such an incredible
lifestyle
you know we didn't end up talking much
about that because of the fact that um
the assumption was i'd come down there
at some point and then the warden kept
vetoing it so we didn't get around to it
i will say that um
barney has a charisma um not a gordon
gekko charisma but more of like a
grandfatherly uh and he knows how to
bring people in and i think
they thought he was cool there because
he pulled off this incredible thing
and so i think he was doing he was doing
all right he followed everything about
the case that all the court cases
you look at the stuff he gave me it was
um
unbelievable memory recall he was
reading all the transcripts um so he was
he was staying very plugged in and um
um he had his he had his story and he
stuck to it he would admit to me the
ponzi scheme and the stuff that he
criminally admitted he wouldn't admit
anything else he would never admit that
it started one day before 1992 ever
and um he stuck to that story
and you know of course it looks to me
like it was going on since the early 70s
so um he could never come clean really
and i don't know that he ever came clean
uh to it to himself and uh again he
thought he built a legitimate business
and he thought that he wasn't given
enough credit uh credit for that and uh
his investors he at one point told me he
says you know anybody that thinks
they're gonna earn twice the uh treasury
bill rate should know there's a lot of
risk there so they should have known and
jim i warned him there was fraud that
there was a risk of fraud in these kinds
of investments too
imagine the goal of telling is that
what's their fault that they i there
could have been fraud why didn't they
find it
it's hard to believe it it's stranger
than fiction and also i don't know if
this is conveyed but
most nobody knows this do they it's it's
largely untold
you know it's kind of good to get to get
the word out and put the whole thing uh
uh into into into perspective
i hope you know
i hope you do buy the book and read it
by the way too i have to put a small
pitch in for that and diane's books is
your independent bookstore so you're
supporting a local uh greenwich firm and
i have we have bookplates so i can send
anybody who wants to sign uh a signed
book plate and uh and you're welcome to
contact me with any questions by the way
or if you want to talk directly or
whatever and you can ask as many more
questions as you want
anybody else or
i don't know where jessica is
yeah i'm right here i actually have a
question jim
um i'm just curious if the investigation
and perhaps this book if if any of it
has led to any like reform or
policies or better investigations for
other
you know
that's a good question um yes i've
talked to harry marcos about this
because harry's the man that you know
basically first uncovered was a ponzi
scheme and the sec wouldn't talk to him
as i said after it all went down the sec
did talk to him and he says the sec is
very good now at detecting ponzi schemes
and and by the way there's they come
every month they just people are doing
ponzi schemes it's some kind of a
sickness i guess
but they are very good he said that if
one happened offshore remember we talked
about all this hidden money and the
money coming in if one was done offshore
he thinks there could be another bernie
but that's the only way
now
other reforms you know i i in the book
call for i talked to you about how cipic
and finra are both run or owned or
funded by the brokerage industry and i
think they should be mates independent
like fit the fdic and they should be
properly capitalized and i don't think
that
um
investor
feeder funds hedge funds should be able
to say they do do due diligence just in
their marketing for sure i think there
should be some legal requirements so if
luis is giving her money she knows he
actually did follow these steps but the
assets do actually exist this is the
investment strategy he's following and
and uh
and those kinds of uh those kinds of
things
the sec needs to become more of a
proactive cop what the sec people think
that's what the sec does no what the sec
does is come in after the mess is made
and try and clean it up
and i mentioned rob i don't know if you
guys know about robin hood but robin
hood is very hot right now it's an
online broker that says they give free
trading right well how do they give free
trading you know how they give free
trading they get they direct their
trades to exchanges um in return for
getting a rebate for sending them that
business right it's called payment for
order flow guests who invented payment
for order flow basically bernie madoff
but bernie did not screw his clients on
price
robinhood was taking such a big rebate
that their customers were getting
inferior price execution
get this to the extent that they paid 34
million dollars than if they'd gone down
the street and paid a commission because
they were
probably so greedy they were taking so
much money plus
what did we say that
do no harm
you know invest in a low-cost mutual
fund
massive ongoing trading is dumb
it's not going to work and because i
give you free trading what are you going
to do you're going to sit in your
basement and trade
and so
you know to me the sec
they did sanction robin hood for that
but the question is robin hood is still
making all their money and payment for
order flow
and is still trying to encourage their
uh investors to basically follow
everybody off a cliff because when you
make money in trading this is how it
happens all the time it happened to me
when i tried it younger you make some
money you think you're a genius right
you're not a genius the market was going
up so then you say i'm a genius i'm
going to go on margin now and borrow
money because this is so easy so i'm not
going to borrow money i don't know
what's going to happen i'm going to lose
all my gains and i'm going to lose all
my money because i was on margin and i'm
forced to sell it
and that's what happens and um you find
out that you can't beat the market and
particularly when you're an individual
sitting in your basement who doesn't
have the access to information that the
wall street guys do
those are the kind of to me the jury the
sec should be
protecting investors who are doing more
stuff up front force robin hood to
disclose exactly what free trading
really means and to disclose that
they're not screwing their customers um
by giving them an inferior price uh
quote so that they can stuff money in
their pocket
um and these things really never seem to
totally uh totally go away
unfortunately
jim uh two more questions luisa asks
what have the undergraduate and graduate
business schools done regarding teaching
ethics and business did bernie impact
the way our future business leaders are
trained
uh what was the first part of that did
the is this is is there going to be an
impact on business schools
um or uh an impact on uh teaching ethics
in business school
oh
you know huh
the you know what made me laugh i'm
doing a
virtual zoom to the entire chota alumni
body um in june and a guy um who's at
chode asked if he could join the panel
because he did research with a harvard
professor who talked to bernie sanders
as an expert well guess what i happen to
talk to bernie about that harvard
professor he's a professor of ethics in
the business school at harvard and he
lied to bernie by taping his calls
without telling him
and wrote
in his book that bernie he asked bernie
about uh andrew's death and he said that
bernie
spoke about it for half a second and
then switched to interest rates and this
is an example of how
sociopathic bernie was so i asked bernie
about that and bernie said that first
off the guy told him it was it was an
interview about ethics not that it was
about directly the scheme not that he
was taping him either and also he said
jim i was on suicide watch for the
prison when andrew died so this guy's an
ethics professor and i intend to pop
this on this guy at the choke thing
which um i'm sure going to come as a bit
of a surprise but
dennis um
kozlowski and jeff grant who you know
from greenwich probably a lot of you
this same professor um interviewed them
too because he was a book on white
collar criminals both of them had major
problems with his ethics i found the guy
to be nice i interviewed him on my show
um
but
can you teach ethics in business school
you should be able to it needs to be
ingrained in the culture of the school
and in the course uh in the entire
course though not just one course that
looks like they're you know trying to
stuff and i went to uh business school
of dartmouth and it's a very small
school and it is very culturally focused
on team play and doing the right thing
and not backstabbing each other and all
that kind of stuff i can't speak for
some of the other schools
you know who i'm talking about
and jim it looks like this is our final
question from sandy
did you find your entire experience
surreal
you know uh
somebody
i think jim axelrod or somebody asked me
that like
first off
all of a sudden and this i have
i've never been able to fathom this i
find myself in 2011 suddenly emailing
the most vilified criminal in the entire
planet
and that's
that it's just it to this it boggles me
to this day and the other thing there's
a recent thing is it is you know that
catherine uh hooper andy ruth and bernie
all trusted me with their legacies none
of whom knew me
and knew anything of me and knew that i
was going to pursue the truth
um so it is taught and it is totally
surreal first off the whole you heard me
get total luck getting to bernie right
total fortuitous luck that bernie dies
right before the book comes out and i'm
on cbs with six planned viewers
and now netflix is interested in this
thing the netflix director told me that
if i go with him we would i would this
documentary will be seen by a hundred
million people in 28 days
i mean
it's totally surreal the the guys the
director who's the top director for the
true documentaries is saying jim my
people say i have to get your book and
i'm sitting here saying
something's wrong here i'm a first-time
author and this top director is
basically begging me to get you know to
work with him shouldn't it be the other
way around shouldn't i be like
you know begging the guy so it is it is
surreal um and you know i do hope though
my dream was more than any of this other
stuff was that this would be the
definitive account of this story and
that the true untold story and the
failure of the system failure all of
that would come out because it hasn't
come out and um you know i think
fortunately this set will end up being
it in part because um madoff has passed
away so there's going to be nobody else
that's going to be able to get into that
uh that side of the equation and nobody
else has tried to tackle the other stuff
so hopefully
hopefully this book will sit as that one
of my idols is bethany mclean who wrote
the book on enron called the smartest
guys in the room
and that book um is like and peter
elkind co-wrote that who's also a friend
bethany did a blurb for my book on the
back
i wanted this to be sort of like that
and i can't pretend to be bethany she's
brilliant and written multiple books but
this was kind of my hope that i might be
like in the minor league you know with
her and that's what my hope is
thank you so much jim for joining us
we're so lucky that we got you before it
seems like you're going to be a very
busy man for a very long time with this
book oh i love this is all great it's my
hometown
well we're so lucky
i would do anything for louisa anything
from louisiana anything incredible
thank you so much and we hope that
someday we're going to be able to host
you in person at the library thank you
everyone for joining us good night thank
everybody for coming out take care
[Music]